so
someone goes about a vice of i'm my reaper with my conflict
Of course I see one she hates comment as I'm in the the click go live section whenever I go live
There's like a
Oh my short went up
Oh, Moe short went up. Oh my god
Hold on a minute hold on a minute. I just approved the release. Let's call me and hold on a minute
I wasn't supposed to have
Good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon. I'm currently in my YouTube comment section. I think I just had approved in a sus comment
That I may need to get rid of
Sometimes I actually approve a comment and I'm don't worry like I'm not insulted about it
But they mentioned another time that I was green and I'm like
I'm strong equals. I'm green. Let's leave it at that
Give one and get even good afternoon. How are you? You will give a rebee debris. We know we be you know
I did it
I
Had a short that came out. Oh my god, congratulations to me
And I
fricking
Finally I
Finally have a short and then I have a short coming out in four days and guess what I've finally edited the most a collab
I did I
Finally edited the most of the collab. I just need some title it and then I get up load it
and
As there is meme ASMR should be up right now if I'm not mistaken if I schedule that properly now
I do have absolutely horrific news and it's bad news for everyone across the board
So for those of you who weren't in the stream yesterday, please don't worry
It's absolutely ridiculous for a streamer to ask for 12 hours of your time. I am not insulted if you do not know this I
purposely took
Medicine to put me to sleep as soon as I went off stream I
Ended up staying awake another like what four hours
Maybe even five so I'm back to being exhausted didn't fix the problem
I woke up ten minutes ago. I'm shattered
But I think I can make it happen
Did you like the meme plot for and
If you haven't seen as there's meme audio is up and she keeps you dry with her boobies in the rain
And
Right today we're doing Elden Ring part two and then next week when next week starts. It's Elden Ring part three
However, I don't know if there's gonna be a pushdown and stuff if so
Baltro will be an Elden Ring stream most likely and
Mecha salt will be wrecked as well to make way for Elden Ring because I don't actually know how much
Contents up ahead so when the game says DLC my brain goes. Oh, it's something. That's 50 percent shorter than the main game
But some people are saying no this thing is who you mongous you mongous what?
So yes, it goes Elden Ring part three and then I do an AS the more stream
That's not my thing yeah, I
Fuck up that's not right
The ASMR stream should be for you. Why does it say 2 p.m?
Unless that's EDT
Sorry, I'm gonna have to change that and my my delirium. That's not right
So it should be 4 a.m. ASMR stream at the usual time then two hours later
We're gonna do two hours of script writing. I'm gonna gauge interest
I'm gonna gauge if people like it if people like it. We'll come back to it another time and then
I've been among us collab with Yumi plus and it's gonna be a zero mercy
She be and me versus in quotation marks Amy Mamosa
Rainy what the fuck that's about her name wrong. I
Have oh my god, this is what I see this is why you can't fucking make anything creative when you're like delirious
and
And then the next day supposed to be mech assault campaign mode mech assault is an old ancient xbox game and
It apparently is eight hours long and then I'm gonna make a membership ASMR after the eight hour stream
The time zones are right. They're in EST like the rest of your schedule
But where does it say that it doesn't say that is an EST that's the problem
I
Shouldn't know have like yes 9 p.m. EST and brackets
anyway, and
So if Elden Ring is complete then we're playing about row if we're not playing about row and mummies gamble in the house
Wait, yeah, if we don't if Elden Ring is finished
Then we're playing but we're gamble in the house. Look at the right side of your schedule
All right, but there's three different time zones mentioned on it
so
So people are to go the first one
Am I missing where it says all times displayed at EST I literally cannot see it
I'm looking everywhere that you can see my freaking pupils
Looking around I see there's three time zones in the right column
But then in the actual schedule is just picked a time
Where?
You know what the fun thing is you guys are never gonna know what the offline
Ed it looks like of my schedule. I was giggling away
Cuz em Emi was being a cutie pie and
Then I was like wait no one's ever actually seen the offline mode of what my schedule looks like
Ed no starting right binding of Isaac for two hours. I doubt it. Well, I
I'm gonna need no because the problem is
Runescape part wait runescape part four doesn't tell everyone to download the movie
Right, so runescape part four and part five. I'm gonna try and finish cooking in those two
I don't know if it's possible
But in runescape part four we're watching the John Wick series
I know I said I didn't want to watch it, but I had to basically I
Couldn't find any other trilogy that I wanted to watch
So then I said no we'll do that and then in runescape part five
We're actually gonna sit and just watch
The girls is live streams because I can't keep up with them
However, I can keep up with them if we can watch them whilst we do runescape wine
So on the last day, I'm literally gonna sit and watch all the streams that I wanted to watch from the girls
Okay, each girl I'm gonna pick a stream where I'm like, I'm I want to watch that. I'm I want to watch that
I'm I want to watch that and
Cuz like I really want to watch as there is monetization stream. I don't have fucking time like when I finish this
Um
What is it called when I finish this um um?
Endurance stream, I'm literally gonna go and put subtitles in the mimosa collab so then it uploads
Before I stream tomorrow
Oh
Yes, John Wick is one two and three wait. No is the fourth movie already
Right, I'll edit that before I tweet it because I just want to watch John Wick one two three
I unless for I don't know how long they all are sometimes movies are like two and a half hours and I can't do that
He shoots his pufusal. Oh my god. It's already out. I can he keep up the fourth one
You said there's a fifth one in production
Bro, he that man a break let that man retire wasn't that the whole plot line that he's fecking retired?
Oh some of yous have got a cheat honestly
Making same one after same one after same one nothing but a cheat around you. Oh wait. No, I can't go in the middle
I go here
Whoa, yeah, I always forget that I
Always forget that
Force one is
169 minutes long, so it's two and a half hours and they didn't wrap it up in two and a half
I
What's the plan of action I've no got a clue I think we're going back to the DLC I have a tonne of flasks that actually heal me now
The irony that you speak about break for what force is the last one all right
I
Spoilers
Right, okay, we will watch John. Wait, I thought someone said John with fibers in production
I'm like what fucking like hands is gone to like some some kid and be like take take on my legacy
Where I just annihilate everyone and I actually only shoot how many guns are physically possible in the chamber
I
Did you upgrade your weapon not quite?
But I do have to acknowledge that the refunds are carrying me through everything
It's just something like that. There's a bit. No, that's how the fifth minute. There's five offer fucks thing
I'm gonna have to change my movie choice. What is a trilogy or some sort of movie?
scenario that all from the same thing
That'll give us like ten hours
roughly I
Need ten hours so we can just fucking wine out max wine out
No, I can someone said spider-man. I might just do spider-man so we can all laugh at the dancing scene
We should watch one piece. Are you John? I'd never be off stream for how long?
Yeah, Toby McGuire's big Spidey man. I might do that. I
Would say shrek one to three, but I didn't like the third installment. I think it's shite. I hate it
and
Fortune load
The reason why Lord of the Rings is out of the question or the Hobbit is because I'm doing it on Christmas and I'm doing it on
My brain won't hold on let me drink my tea. Hold on. Let me drink my tea cuz I'm clearly not awake right now
Christmas what you plan that forehead? Yeah on Christmas day. We're watching Lord of the Rings and then on Boxing Day
We're watching the Hobbit
Maybe the final destination I have a really big fear of flying and I can't really watch
Oh
Blade is through movies is play those vampire ones. I don't think I've seen that
Boxing day is the day after Christmas. So the 26th of December so 25th Christmas 26th is
Called boxing day in the UK
It's where you put on gloves and you're supposed to box someone that you have
Like negative feelings for but it's supposed to be done in a comedic way and then after I'm fucking with you
That's absolutely not what boxing day is but boxing day is on the 26th of December
I think it's a retail shopping thing
Blade yes
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I couldn't help it. No boxing day is a thing
I think you're in what statistically what I recall is that it's supposed to be everything's on sale
So it's just another way for the
Capit the cogs in the machine to spend all their hard-earned money
So boxing day yeah, just like so you can start the new year fresh. You just have a little go at each other
That's terrible
What if shadow of the earth tree it was shadow of the freak tree and instead of playing the DLC we just
Played with each other and go
Okay
Very interesting
Are you gonna reimburse me for the DLC then if we do that?
I have no idea what I'm doing
Ah
Who's leading me who's what we're doing
When you get picked up by cops tell them strong I told you so
Everyday is boxing day. They should have seen this
Sweeper pulled off yesterday a TKO double on shorty. All right then all right then sirion sirion
Actually, it was a servants Christmas the people were who were on staff for Christmas parties and fees
But actually exchange them on boxing day. I think Poland do it. Is it Poland do it the day before as well?
That could just be making utter pish up. I really
Um oh my god, I don't have live chat on no
Didn't miss how many messages. I swear. Why is freaking talk chat even a thing on YouTube?
I want to see all the all the terrible remarks
Right, I'm gonna be honest my socks are full
Oh
My souls are just being cheating don't you want right where we're going stage front? We're gonna see
You're ignoring us. No
I'm supposed to go around part. I
Didn't even know there's a difference so basically it goes like wait a minute
Can I hear the enemy?
Hear the enemy I think
I don't know why I can't remember why I turned it down
Are we deciding on a challenge?
I can't do it right now
Are you squiddling me right now?
Wow spent the last few days moving along with a 20 hour drive
So I have a lot of the box to catch up on but I'm glad to be settled and back to live you
My days were too quiet without you around. Oh, yeah, you couldn't have you couldn't handle when I was
In your ear all the time you can
You need that back. Have I conditioned you to need the yaps so badly. Thank you for the 50 Spidey. Holy crap. That was a lot
and
Mummy he was so loud was he
There I've turned him down. I'm sorry, but he Brian Brian bit end over Brian right now
I
TTS is loud game is loud. I think Johnny's just deaf
Okay, I put the game down I
Put Brian down by six
decibels I
Oh wait, is this the lion behind this cathedral?
I also in my browsing
Apparently very popular church driver. What's his name? The one that wipes blood on the wall. I
Don't know if there's any refunds are able to do this fight. Let's find out
There's a few refunds that can do this fight. Let's see
How the fuck you were here right by the end of the stream. Are you guys not sleeping or insomniacs or something?
How the fuck is anyone here that's still standing from yesterday? Hello?
Right, this is a boss fight so it so someones don't count. I'm like not putting you to war
Are you guys getting any sleep at all? I'm getting worried like it doesn't matter if I don't get sleep
But you guys are getting sleep. Hello
What we're two melee experts. We've got blade the
Oh
Right
Right, so the way we do this I send you guys in for the kill. I sit and commentate. I slept for 11 hours
She's she said sleep. She says what is sleep? What is the oh no sleep? Oh, she can't meet our sleep schedule
It's not your sleep schedule. That's terrible
Sleep in this economy four hours is plenty of sleep. Oh god the ritual. How could I forget?
So if you guys were unavailable yesterday, please don't worry and you guys can stream site me
I'm actually gonna pin our
Multi-player password because I forgot to do that
And I'm very excited to do this
So yesterday when we play
You know when you hear all those stories about the pre-war rituals necessary like they the women would cast
Wait, what I've looked at or generate as men golds audio is very loud
Which is causing some of the viewers to just
Complain despite the loudness the viewers are all right
Anyway, anyway, anyway, right multi-player password is
That's how you spell password. I am so sorry. I'm clearly not looking up right now
I
Terrible see absolutely terrible
Right, so we have a pre-war ritual from around these parts
I never send off a refling in a battle with this boy cherry. I take it
And this is what we do every time oh
Oh, oh you give me a hero's run
Okay, I'm not gonna open it right you ready
Go jump the Scottish women right I can't is this the is the lion. Oh god
Okay, we seem to have two melee
Beeflings everyone does have a magical spell refling down. I want to go for it. I want to help I
Take it back. I don't want to help. I don't want to help. I don't want to help
You guys dodging that
I need like a bow and arrow, I think I go grab the start getting a bow and arrow. Oh
I
No, there's no way I'll let us have a few attempts, but I'm sorry. There's no way. Oh
Yeah, take that 300 damage, baby. Oh
It's freaking ours just got me
Okay, I did 300 damage you're welcome me playing
Oh, yeah, oh my souls I forgot about my soul. How many is it was actually quite a lot. I
Didn't even know the game would remember that
How are you doing there?
I
Canel
I'm gonna need a crossbow bolt or something actually helping these fights. I can't even reach the enemy
before about stamina
Holy shit
Am I gonna fuck up being near this repellent? I think I may be I mean he's doing fine without me
I'm not being funny. I think I'm fucking it up if I interact at the face
Ah, wait, hold on. I want to help if he's getting
Stop it I commandeer to kneel. Oh, I cannot predict that that's like such
Oh
My gosh, I think I'm gonna have to get some sort of magic spell so I can
Commentate and help briefings instead of like I wanted to do a two-hand. I've never done a magic bill before
I
Didn't know he had lightning
Honestly, it's kind of frightened
Leave that refling alone shit
How am I running him? I don't know. I'm just outpacing him gently
I
Think the enemy honestly
Okay
Wait, that was just things
Hit from a distance oh my god
Bruh, okay, I thought I'm starting to understand why people may or may not have done the DLC
That was like hard
Who wants to try it the reef oracle
reforeacle
Foreacle me mommy
Now please don't worry, I'm not actually putting your name down for any
Main game stuff like when we go adventure in this your name does not get tallied against any like a walk around stuff with me
I'll finish this piece
Oh
Lovely
No, did you not come in
Yeah, but you clearly have better connection right we have a bleed build from the looks of it skinny Molyneke late
Bleed build and then we have a and second
Maybe we have some sort of magical staff you guys want a little pre-war ritual moment
Can't send you in a battle now without
getting your rewards
surely if you're gonna defend the house of
Strony you get what's going to you
Well, oh cuz I was in the jump animation it didn't like that
Guys don't look I'll die immediately. Thank you. Right. You're ready. Yes, steady
You be have to do some clips. I'll literally just like my IQ
Okay, he like loads up quite a bit
Sorry
I'm just trying to like get a feel of his attack pattern
He seems like slight delay, but he can definitely like do a back kick into stuff
Which is quite curious
Yeah, but he can turn so quickly as well. This is I
Must say this is a fantastic boss. This really is the design his capabilities. I've only seen phase two, which is lightning
Yeah, this as well. This is a nasty amount of work nasty nasty
But I love it. I have to admit. I love it. It's like a whirlwind type of whack again
Yeah, see the effects of that is fantastic
Don't worry lads. I helped for 200 damage. I really did. I really did. I cannot imagine
Anyone playing this solo. Oh my god. It's cheeky little spank on his butt
He it's because of his a bit he's free and he's free and
He's a male he's a Tom cat. He's a male Tom cat he's free and
Okay, I got 400 on them there. I'm so good at this game honestly
Wow, wow, wow, wow
Oh
Dear that was a fantastic attempt. So
Just trying to see it. So it seems to do a dive down and then a back sweep
Just trying to tame off accordingly
Yeah, he yeah, he can react instantly as soon as the tackle changes. He will swipe you and oh, sorry. Sorry didn't mean to do that
Okay, oh
That was for me
Rats, sorry, I thought he locked back on to the other replant. I do apologize
Some may find solo easier for the boss fight
Well, no one said that some may find solo easier actually because of more flash
Does everyone have I'm sure I think everyone's got the fast we'll give it a few good tries
If not, I'm actually fine to explore elsewhere. Like I went past all those scorpion places
And I wouldn't mind backtrack into all the scorpion places and because I feel like this
And this DLC Russian on my dick. Thank you. And this DLC is got so many areas to go like so many a doubt
We're actually stuck here so quickly and to explore in the DLC
And so we can do some adventuring and I'll just take you for walkies
Unironically solo can be a bit easier because the boss is more predictable predict all over
Predict all over your butt, but predicts of all
Okay, ready
Daddy
You guys have the lie down a mo always blessing us. Oh, we're getting play. Good man. Do you guys want you at my blessing?
There we go bless bless to impress
Okay, let's get it
Get it. Let's get it. Oh, sorry. Sorry. Got bit. Got a bit. Hey, got a bit excited there
Okay, okay, I'm picking up my soul. Oh, wow. He never does that first
Holy shit. Give me that. Oh, I missed my souls. Wait, I can't see anything
Oh
Reflings get a little bit rolled off the bat, but that's understandable happening say wait, you know aggro change. See it's so hard. Oh
I rolled I should have rolled into right
Do a whack do a roll
Wow that aggro is so unforgiving. I
Can't even be mad though. It's so good
Wait, what's that glass? I don't even know what my wondrous physics the deep flask is
I'm just shoving it on though. We all just have a good time out here
Okay, that was actually really lucky with it. I would even get that spanking
I'm wondering. Oh, that was a big tally whack. Honestly, that was a lot of damage there
It came to cornering him, but he doesn't like it
Did I get electrocuted if I spank a car a
We bet wait you can't hit on money electrocuted or am I going crazy making that up?
What are you doing tonight? No, I can't help
No sugar that was the rolling some twice
Oh
No, we were actually doing so good
I'm so sorry
We were actually doing so good. It's that it's that second bait. He does against me
I need to roll into him, but my instincts are like roll away roll away enemy enemy. Oh
He got me in two hits
Oh my god, I've killed all the refunds with two left there. Okay, and come Clarissa
a
Russian
And
Oh, no, no, no, that's a fucking MPC. I'm sorry. That's an MPC. Oh
Why am I born like this?
Why am I born like this it's a fucking MPC
The MPC is a reflin to know she started hitting
The invader reflin. Oh, she looks straight up follows you around. Wait, how far does she do you follow me down here? Oh
She like she like proper hangs out
Wait, can I just we'll do the fight I promise we'll do the fight
But does she like proper come and whack like the scorpions and stuff?
Coming
Go kill scorpions I
Didn't know that in-game MPCs would do that. How do we join scrawny BPC be
Elden Ring be Elden Ring DLC and then you can come join me
Yeah, she go go kill that MPC go kill that
We'll kill it
We'll kill it MPC. Oh, she does fight it. Whoa. I
Don't know how I dodged all of that
Sorry, I'm probably making this week for the boss attempt. I'm just so curious
So she does that's curious. I didn't know in-game MPCs would walk around. Yeah, that is
Fascinating sorry
The password is reflux. Yes
So in multiplayer if you do your password and then you'll use what's called a tarnished furled finger at the
Same location I'm at and then you'll be able. I'll be able to summon you in and
I can only summon two good reflins at a time in one bad one, but I can't summon bad ones right now. Are you ready?
No pressure since only ones are refling and the others an MPC
No pressure at all
I
Fucking
Oh, she's doing magic
Whoa
I can't even fucking see none
Oh
You've done something to me, I don't know what I'm magic. Why is this a thing? The thing just changes
It just changes. I wasn't doing it right. I didn't count. I didn't count no one no one should be embarrassed
I didn't count I didn't count because there was one end of you. Well, this is starting well
Well, we're gonna give it a few times if it doesn't work
We're gonna go exploring cuz I like exploring
Cuz we've got so much of the map to go as well like tons of the map
Okay, here we go
Will you not had a shot
Is that wolf the fridge or my just hungry
So
Oh
Jack you've not been in these are my chosen warriors
Surely we will be successful. Nah, I'll give us quite a few shots and then the AI tank in the boss so hard
I swimper in
There's so if you didn't know there's no like voice chat in the game or anything like that
But there are coconuts in the game
Which is hilarious because there's one coconut that's crying, but it sounds like whimpering
So the reflins come in and they go
Okay, the ritual has been
The reflings are safe yet again
Hello. Yes, you look he held a coconut and the coconut goes
That kind of locking onto the boss might be detrimental to the crazy movement
That's what I think like whenever I go against the wee dragon or whatever it keeps locking onto its chest
Can you stop going for me one this is feeling very targeted
We didn't even get an attempt
It's because I'm going for the souls I think I'm gonna have to hold back. I can't believe it. Oh
That was
Okay, I'm starting to understand why people are like, bro, what the heck no one can even play this unless you and
Before anyone's like get good scrub up fucking relax. Okay one relax to
Oh wait, I can actually help in the fight now. How do I use it? I need balls
Well, what I do I just aim
I
Said I just aim can I actually help in the fight right hold on I need to bless you to first door I
Can actually help in a fight question mark. I need to go by arrows
I don't know right need to lie down
That can bless you get good scrub. How much of yesterday's 12 hours stream was spent dying not a lot
We actually we went we went and done a lot of stuff. You want pre-ritual? Oh wait, you give me something
And give me one ball
Pre-ritual
You can't like you know go lie down you got crouched. Oh
Wow, this refunds it. Let's go. He's ready. He's pumped right. Let me get the crossbow ball on for you
This reflin is not messing around. He said nah move aside. You absolute noobs. You threaten
Have I assumed it's like auto-equipses
I
Assume the crossbow balls are all equipped it. Let's go
Yeah, surely they're most locked and refling
Okay
Okay as if
As if you're coming for me hold on
Right so what aim and then shoot
Oh my god, it's rapid fire
Am I hitting I think I'm hitting. Oh my god
Speaking of hitting I'm getting hit. Oh
I'm getting hit
Please don't twerk on me. Please don't work into me
I'm gonna my dinner
I'm out of animals. I'm out of arrows. How am I out of arrows? How does that work?
Nope, that's melee
Okay, wait
Hold on you guys hold them off. I'm just gonna figure out how to equip arrows. How the fuck this?
And put that one in there surely no don't heal you goobur
Okay, I'm helping I'm helping
What the fuck how is this not working? No, don't why I don't understand
It eat
Mommy snake is us. I'm trying. I don't understand
What the fuck is going on
We've got lightning with no got ace
Pop a magical dragon on this way hold on
Hold on again
Oh
Did that work no you
That work
It's a tornado
Oh, I miss hold on I missed a suck
Oh
Hold on I suck at this game hold on hold on. Oh, no
Wait
Somehow the like phase two attack doesn't hurt me as much as the other one
I'm helping I'm helping
Very one damage you have to be joking. That's funny is anything
I'm helping taking the aggro look at me. I'll take the aggro. I'm totally doing right now. I don't fucking
I'll just melee them. No my furry fling
Do I have enough to I'm just gonna have to
Fucking melee with my body
My bloody I'm million. Oh, I want to at least get a hit in with my wee thing
Hit him hit him with it. Yeah, I think I did it. Yeah, fuck you
Bitch
It feels different things to damage you need some more blue bars to rapid fire. Oh, I never did any of that
The repeating fires a weapon are
Okay
That was very unique. Have hardly any crossbow balls. Do you need to buy them all? Do you want?
I
Didn't really understand that but I had fun on the list, which is the main thing though
Okay, let's see
You had a short you've not had a short yet
I don't think I've seen you today no
No
Okay, can't wait for you to get to get to bail
Looks cool, what's the password to join it be it's pinned
If you didn't multiply your password and you're at the same location as me
Which is the stage front on the DLC
You may be able to carry me or I might just mess everything up in the game
Wow, we've got here. Who have we got here? Let's take two melee boys
Any melee player? Oh wait, wrong one
Pretty long cheeky pre-war ritual
We are good to go
Get my crossbow ball on so I can be of some use to my darling
refling
Not sure I'll try and pick up my souls because I quite a lot
Finally home from a week of camping without signals
So got a week of screams to catch up on still 25 minutes behind
But how to train your dragon is a good trilogy candidate for a watch a lot. Oh it is but it makes me cry
I remember like ball in my eyes at my grand's house watching that
I
Really not understand in the inventory system. I have tons of arrows selected
Whatever bear with me bear with me
Thank you so much for the tip a milk cadmium
I'll be able to fight hit that and actually respond in just a moment. You see I'm doing what's called
You look away for a second
Hold on don't zap me. I'm swapping. Um, I don't get it. I really get all collected
Why are you doing that now I just put what I
Just put that on
It's a great ball. It has to be a ball ball. I'm so confused
Why doesn't it not all put like our own chamber? I mean, I guess I know our
kind of special I
Know arrows are like kind of special but
I'm healthy. I'm doing what's called tick damage
Oh, he's getting all it on I think I'm out after this
I think that's all my balls
Other than that, but why can't I use it then ultimate ball?
No, it's not
I'm so sorry, holy crap imagine watching your ally on the field like shaking her wife and around
She doesn't know what an error is going on. It's because it's not a regular ball
It's like putting a nine-volt battery in and a triple a battery slow. Okay, that makes more sense
Do I have an arrow
You reeflings you're doing great sweeties. Keep it up. Mommy's mommy's just gonna
I actually didn't pick up a bow and arrow at one point
Keep it up darlings. You're doing great. Mommy's so proud of you
Keep that focus maintain that focus
I've got a weapon of mana. Oh
You're doing fantastic. Keep it up, honey. Oh
Wow
Where's the foot that not even have a magic staff that I can like do something from afar with oh
You're doing great, honey
Unable to use it
Where's my weapon I can't even use it. Why would you let me equip it if I can't even use it? Oh
You're doing amazing sweeties. Oh
You're doing fantastic. No, no, no. Oh
No, this can't be
Okay, I'll see jump into it. Oh, no, it's not a jump into it kind of attack. Fuck you
Oh, I can't see anything. I'm just happy to be here. Yeah, it's not happening not with me anyway
Not with me. I am I the one it's not possible
It's not possible
Take this yes, that's right. Take that 300 damage, you know, you like it baby, you know, you like that damage
Oh press B, but far too late
Wow, no shot that any other
Oh
So Danny
Your character literally isn't smart enough to use magic. I I think that's a pretty on par with me
I
Don't know how to get an arrow, but I do have it. No, I do have arrows
I've 20 arrows
So I can totally help it like oh my god, I can help so much for real for real
There is no, that's the NPC stop stop. I'm getting tempted by the NPC stop it
You're so stinky
You can respect if you have a level here people can just drop balls for you somebody draw for a couple stacks of balls
Just so I can continually go like
Oh, you've not had a shot
Do you want to hear my five head gaming tactic I did today? Oh
Rilke Kadman again. Thank you for the tip finally one from a weaker captain without a signal
So I got a weaker streams to catch bro. You need to like times three those streams. Oh
Wow
Holy crap. These are a lot
Okay, okay. Okay. We might be in the money. We might be in the money
Possibly in the money. Okay. I definitely can help out. Holy crap. How do you guys have so much stock?
You guys should be like a shop in this game, right? You ready for the pre-war ritual. Oh
We're getting blessed as well. I might need to hurry with the ritual for got a blessing on. Oh, hold on
Oh, right. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go get us in there get us in there because we've got a blessing
That's activated and I don't know what they mean. I'd assume the time out
That shouldn't be time out. No, don't look at me
Why don't look at me
Don't look at me. I'm not even got my ball out. Oh, oh, hold on
Pause the fight. Pause the fight. Hold the music. Pause the tunes
Hold on hold on hold on hold on. Oh sure. Let's just spam out like these balls
Okay, one at a time. One at a time. Let's go
This is called tick damage. Right, let me pick up my soles actually while I'm at it
I'm doing it. I'm doing it. A lot of incantations have comedically short duration. That's what I'm like
Okay, we need to go like now. I
Think I'm just shy of like a hundred pairs of balls unless it's you guys doing damage and me just not
Comprehending. I'm doing like nothing to help
She would need a real carry aspect to do like this and smudge it
Oh
Whoa, okay, he did not appreciate the
He did not appreciate it. What do you mean? I'm just I just have a crossbow. I'm not doing anything special
We're doing it. Should I do rapid fire? Nope, I'm getting rapid fire. Not the other way around, but it's
No, I didn't like that. I don't know why
I'm helping I'm helping
Mummy being scared in the corner while she sends in the reef wings to the colony. Oh sugar. We're down one
I have that
No, I
Have a girl I have a girl I repeat I have a girl give me over here. Oh, no
We're actually doing pretty decent. I think we can do it. Holy crap. Reflex. I honestly think you can do it
I have faith
I'm happy to camp. Sorry. I'm happy to do this. I actually genuinely have faith for hardly have faith
And
I'm actually doing decent amount of damage over time because accumulatively decent damage
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa?
Why why is the arrow keep coming to me I'm just a swimmer
Where's streamer luck I don't know why I'm not risking it though
Holy crap. We might do it
You guys are actually so pee
It's all my crossbow, I'm sorry. It's all my crossbow. I had to reload there. I had to reload there
It's literally all my crossbow. Sorry. What was that 62 damage? I
Absolutely, absolutely
Absolutely, please leave me alone. I can't see anything. Please leave me alone. Please leave me alone. I need to heal
Okay, okay, no, it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine
Just a few more. Ow my freaking kitty
Just a few more
Do not die. I swear to God we fling if you leave me alone to say I'm gonna be so sad. I
Do not give you permission to die. Do you understand? Do you understand? Well, you did not understand. That's terrible
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please crossbow, please
Are you serious?
I had to hit one more crossbow. I can't even see the
fucking HB
When will you learn?
When will you learn? Are you joking? It was one HB. Oh
My gosh
Come on game you suck
You knew exactly I should have won
Bruh, that's twice now. It's been on me and I've completely bowled the art
You just hey man
You both just wait, how did you guys respond faster than me?
Am I miss under it? Wait, am I being dumb?
You can equip two different bolts that wants to swap
How would I swap
So when you come
Wow, we did fantastic there. Someone please give her bleed bolt. Oh, I think someone may have already possibly
I don't think any briefly I don't think anyone plays with a crossbow. So no one actually has like crossbowls to go
There's also something called Lord Heals that you can get from turtle cope that can heal the reefing. Oh
Oh my god, I can't fight the gender norms. I want to be a healer so bad
Are we going you want to oh
Do you want to go for it and you want to go you just want to go straight into it?
Okay, no ritual. So a kiss and a kiss. Good luck. Let's go. Let's get to it. Let's get to it
Everybody to it to it
Not me, you're not actually supposed to go for me hold on I need my
Through my brother
Look at that 36 damage, you love to see it ladies and gentlemen
36 that okay, I will say as humorous is that is to land like 40 damage
I am actually it adds up. Okay. It's like a numbers game
Number goes higher the more time I hit this crossbow. I
Can not believe that. Oh
My god, I
Mean he is reacting
And I I think I do take our group wait a few times to chill
Like even that small agro there, yeah, and then I'll go agro again
One two
Wow
Oh, it does three rotations geez
Oh
I'm keen to get in the attack pattern just a little bit like when he does a big sweep
He does a delete second one, which is what always gets me
Oh, he said I see your lava. I'm taking off the board
I
Got agro again one swipe pause, maybe no
Didn't quite understand that I guess he's in a different face, so he'll react differently and do different
So it's a bit okay back to me
Which is fine happy with that. Oh, he's asleep. Sorry. I think I just fucked up your special attack on him there
It was an honest mistake
I'm doing it. I'm he's not giving me agro
Yeah, the reflins are just bouncing between the agro between them both
I mean, maybe it's kind of good that it's done like that
I'll maybe try and lure him away
Right keeps moving so much. I'm missing all my shots
Oh
Some heavy damage one reflin is down. No, we've so got this. Sorry, but we're actually getting so close
We are a hundred percent getting so close
I'm gonna see if I can take that agro a bit. Let him jump into me. I'm afraid I'm not familiar with this wind phase that much
I don't really know what he does
He does that
Learning learning not good. Not good. Okay. He blocks his lightning phase
So he has he has different elemental phases. No, he doesn't because he just used winter and ice and oh, shit
Oh, well
There is we did fantastic. I'm not even mad. I'm not even mad. I don't have enough time to swap to my other weapon
I don't have time
Okay, that's not bad a hundred percent. We have this fate. I'm not leaving. We have this fate. I'm satisfied that we
Definitely have oh wait, dad. Can I not do spirit ashes? Oh, no, I can't do spirit ashes because I have it as a crossbow upgraded
I think it's probably level one
um
We a hundred percent can do this. I have faith. I'm sorry. I have faith. I believe
I believe in a thing called love
Yeah
A hundred percent have oh
Why did they do that?
They know full well what they're doing when they do that
You can put your sword in another hand
Like that
And how do I get it out?
Oh, sorry. Sorry. I'm just practicing. Oh, we've got blood bone bolts. Let's check them out
Uh
Causes
Blood blood loss build up so it has less damage, but it goes for
Like critical build up. That's curious
Perfumers bolts
Uh flame balls black key balls. Okay. The reef one. So you want it right?
That's your ritual
Uh a hundred percent think we'll go there
A whole 45 that seven damage
All right, let me quickly get my thingies my thingy my bobbers
I yeah, I'm making a hundred percent of this fight. I have faith
I don't know when you learn the enemy too too silly damage
That was one that was two. Yeah, I did it too early. I know I'm getting it now though. I did it too early
I get it
I don't know if I'm going to get like a notification that he just gets to bleed out damage. I don't think so
I've taken the aggro. They can get a few hits in
I know I'm not taking the aggro
Holy holy
I'm helping I'm helping okay, we're in lightning phase. That's good
When we get into the wind phase, that's when we know we're the
I think it's lightning then wind and then ice elemental phases and then that's when we know we're in the money or not
We're getting there we're getting there 50 percent 50 percent delayed jump. No
Oh
We got a critical we did get a critical
But only okay, we've got we've got ice we've got ice. I repeat there is ice on the board
One refling does go down
However, he's he's getting so low
Oh
How do I change my weapon?
This'll do this'll do donkey. Okay. Whoa. I figured it out. I don't think I'm gonna win but I figured it out
Bro, you need to calm down like seriously need to calm down. Oh crap. It's strong
I'm not mad. I'm not mad. We still have that. I'm I'm so happy
Oh
We can do it we can do it we can do it if you really want
Here we go, uh russian you've got two tally
Bolt delivery
No, that's hilarious
Uh, hello, it's your delivery. Oh what you got for me?
That bolts that's hilarious
Stop being so funny refling stop it your humor is unmatched bolt delivery
If he bleeds a big chunk of his health just disappears
I can't tell if it's the reeflings getting a good big tallywack in or not
Well, that armor looks really unique. It's got like ram horns that come all the way from the front to the back
Oh
Explosive balls if I've messed around with explosive bolts before
I had a great ball great balls
Jeez you are not kidding when you said delivery holy crap. Oh my god, we're still going we're still going
My bolt door dasher is here honestly
A ballista five level five ballista is a ballista what's gonna hold
Oh a ballista is what holds these masses
Our mama's understand
Oh
Okay, oh, oh, did you leave?
Will did you have a shot you did at some point? Oh my god, yeah
No, you're kind of in the middle you were recently not
Car in the betrayer
All right
I 100% think we've got this though the ballista will hold the big boy bolts. I mean fucking look at this thing getting
Yeah, like pop that away so I can two hands this
Holy crap, right? Are we are we getting to it? We get a little kisses a little pre-war kiss
Okay, are you ready? Because I don't have any oh wait you draw
Hold on we need to make sure everyone's the ping is working well
All right, we seem to have two melee experts. Let's go melee
I wonder if melee magic crossbow might be the answer
Yeah, how do I
use this
Okay, let's not do this kind of stuff right now. Hold on. Let me get my
Hold on a minute very
Right you
Uh, am I using these right I am
I think I might hold on to them since a briefly is down already
Please understand when you guys play with me there will be obscene lag obscene in the mean
You know what I'm just gonna sort out
The sword take my sword. Yeah, no this sword women
Take the sword
And then and then take the sword only
Oh my god, two hands the sword women. No two hands the sword. Oh for fuck's sake
We tried the freaking
Oh
Wait, why am I not getting any hit registration does he have invincible invisible frames when he perishes someone?
Yeah, sorry. I'm not making this out alive
Hold y lb. That was miserable
Damn this line got hands literally
That rifling got eaten in a bite
Since when does he do hand grabs it must be his ultimate if you're low enough
All right, I'll maybe we'll do crossbow
I want to do that. Right. So that's fire to put them on fire and then that ludge
How's his blood loss build up we'll do that
And then poison build up. Yeah, that does take damage. That's how the game works, right surely
I mean I didn't I didn't twice taterally
You're actually being in
I'm just gonna check there's no one
A mage rifling, okay, let's see if mage melee and crossbow might work. I'm not sure
Just by the way, if it's not obvious, this is literally just two guys in a costume. Look
If they want to do it in their free time, that's fine as long as they just don't
I'm trying to make one of those jokes. We're just like
Terrible joke no one's laughing
Right, let's see
Are we ready a little a little pre-work is
And a little
Okay pre-work is let's go
I know we can do this
Sorry, but I'm not budging from this spot until we do it because I know we can do it
Okay, I'm gonna let him go for me
Not like this not my half a million souls not like this
Okay, now we can help
I've got poison on over bleed sugar I put them the wrong way
Wait, why would you take that first?
It's strange. Okay, there we go. Oh, I miss. I'm too far away
Uh, I'm helping question mark
He doesn't even know who to aggro well me clearly
Me clearly
He can move like so far
Blood and poison works in his case
I I can't react to anything. I'm so sorry. I'm like half asleep right now
I'm absolutely nothing going for me. I'm spanking himself with these crossbow bolts
Oh, no
Nah, this can't be
Oh, no, we're both we're both long range. I don't want him to take the aggro
Yeah, what are you doing? Oh the lightning. I can even react to the lightning if I wanted to
Ah sugar, uh, why left bumper? Yeah, I did it. Why left bumper?
Wow, okay, only to get absolutely decimated with poor reaction time. It's fine. It's fine. I'm not gonna win against fucking half
Wait, how did I dodge that? I didn't even roll or anything
We replays are also two people in a costume to make up the height
bleeding does 15% of the max hp. He's not used to
mage replays. That's why he's so confused
My story I'm late. How's the game so far? So we're back at this boss in the dlc
I know for a fact reeflings can do it because I you missed it. I got one hp in a dreamed
and
You've been in I'm just checking. Oh, you've not had a shot yet today
um
I'm just
We we can do it. So I refuse to walk away basically
I genuinely refuse to walk away because I know we can do it
You're ready to start so yeah
Weapon art is max hp tick damage
Leave some face to use the black knight
Put me in coach I just woke up and I got caffeine in me a yellow caffeinated
I might have to make another cup of tea like so fucking early into the stream. I'm sorry
I'll actually only played like what for 20 minutes and I'm like I need another cup of tea and dine
Okay, uh the pre how do I?
Oh, okay, we're doing the pre-war
As always I don't mind
Okay, we have been doing kisses just to speed things along a bit because I may or may not have been dying all the damn time
Right you're lying down
Okay, wait, let me do a run and start for this one. This is the run. This is the run. I bless. Oh, wait. Hold wait. What?
Oh freaking sake. Sorry. Sorry. Hold on. Hold on. I've got a bit over the else
This is the run. This is the blessing. Mine push gives you
Man shall feel no tighter clam in you humanity
right
I'll do it take damage
Is there even a point in putting my wee sword on? I don't know
I feel like I feel like I just messed things up if I put a second thing
I'm sleep deprived but I can still fight honestly when you said that
Not to brag or anything but I did 15 damage there smile
Why does it not lock to the bottom?
Well, someone poisoned them. I saw that that wasn't me that poisoned them
Oh, whoa
That rifling getting chomps, I didn't know you were in a war
I
Get cheeky bleeds
Whoa, I think that was the bleed there. Did you see that? I think that was me. I'm helping. I'm helping. I'm actually helping
I'm sorry. I was I was a pain attention. Sorry. Hold on
I think I actually did the bleed
Only took me how long
Oh, he's got his aggroed on me. Don't get distracted. Oh, nice walk. That's the problem. He keeps swapping angry
Come on right we're in phase two officially
Oh, we've got a lightning spray
Okay, aggroed that's fine unaggroed that's fine
That's not only complain. It's so freaking hard to tell
Like it feels so quick
of him coming into you
Oh, okay now. I can't dodge all these attacks. How are you supposed to?
Oh, thank god
How are you supposed to do this solo? That was like what six barrage of an attack in one go
Oh, I was too late. I can see it coming but I think because of his phase one
I think in his phase two he's actually faster when he does that attack and it messes me up
Oh
What's that move? What is it?
It's like an ace song
Oh, is this it? I don't want to jinx it, but we're all pretty high health
I'm doing cheeky tick damage with my weak crossbow
Unless I twat it up manually twat it up anyone any manually twatters
Oh my god, we're doing it
Oh my god
Oh my god, I need I need to aggro off him right go right now. No, that's what didn't want. I needed to take aggro
I'm trying to like not cross over. Okay. I have aggro. That's good
No, I don't I've lost it. I've lost it
Oh shit, this sounds like a world of warcraft grade dps. Can you slow down you take an aggro off of me?
Okay, okay
Oh that ace stomp is so big
That ace stomp is so big. Okay. Okay. That's fine. I can handle it. I can handle it. I can handle it
Ah
You so hard that oh, maybe not
I know we can do it. I know we can do it. I'm sorry. I'm not leaving. I know you replants can do it
I'm so proud of you like you guys are putting in so much effort
You guys so have this like you really do
I
Apparently I already have a tally. Do you mean harm you don't have a tally?
I know you replants can do it. I really do. I believe in you wholeheartedly. You're doing fantastic
I know it's frustrating getting in the game and I know there's like and I know you've been debuffed and everything
But use use of got it. I'm so
I'm I know use of got it either so strong
I might need to do it this way if you want the blessing blessing. Oh again. All right. Oh shit. We're going for it
We're going for it. I think are we going for it? Okay. I think we're going for it
Right, you guys are doing fantastic in battle. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go
Oh, and my souls are right there. Thank you for kind
Oh whole 60 damage don't mind if I do
You
Okay, we're just gonna go for bleeds
I wasn't paying attention not gonna lie. Ma. Oh, yeah, okay
It's okay
Let him get up
And maybe when he goes up, I maybe actually oh, I think I just applied fleek damage
Or maybe one of the reasons that actually those melee weapons do look a bit bleed effect ish
So
Really the challenges we just need 10 bleed effect hits. That's it right because if it does
10% of the full health of the enemy
Oh shit, I'm not in position
Okay, okay, go a little cheeky special
So stagger
Strongly be a good girl and cover your ears
I want to thank all of my fellow reeflings for being such good fellow reeflings. I'm still love
Why would I need to cover my ears for that? They're so awesome
Um
Are you being nice to each other? That's awesome girl. Thanks for the fight. That's what I'm saying like you guys are gonna go where?
That's a dangerous move for the distance that storm ice
Oh, I was freaking spam and be
No
That was the fucking run
No, wait, I'm alive
Oh, no, this can't be I was alive
This whole time I was alive. I thought he died. I just gave up
I don't know if that other reefling gave up for the fairest
Oh my god
Relentless that was literally one HP
That was one HP in a freaking ring. Why why do I have a notification on youtube?
Congrats
Oh
YouTube says new copyright match copyright match found. Yeah, I'm just lost the game TV
I just lost the game
Overnote thank you for the five. Wait, what?
It'll be someone that's clipping me
YouTube it'll be someone that's clipped with me. Yeah, literally someone clipped me
Their title is called pvstroni turns you in our puppy. Oh steady on steady on
Wait, relax
YouTube you're so dramatic. It's like this person's stealing your no youtube. That's a highlight
That's that's called a highlight of it. Hey, jeez. Anyway, anyway
This crossbow will create the heavens at bear
right
Russian you've been in twice. I think
shame
Oh my god, I'm gonna sing my ears because I'm having to wear a headset all day well
Having to wear is a bit of a dramatic chair. Your name is chair
Chair chair has come into the pre
YouTube when their own system
Literally, I don't mind clipping at all. I remember people like we're like, what's the rules about clipping the girls?
I'm like, uh, do you realize how much it supports the girls if you like
You know, if you have the free time and you find yourself like you've not
I've got anything to do but you watch the girls
Seriously become a clip channel. Not only can you monetize those clips and make money for like all the time you put into it
You can hone a craft which is editing skills, which is always needed. I cannot tell you how much editing skills are needed
Okay, we're doing the ritual
um
Like don't be afraid to click we're not like I don't know if there's other
Vita agencies are like, we're gonna copyright you. No, we don't do that
Like as long as you're not derogatory or anything like well, I mean the guess is just ignore anyway if it's derogatory
She will never play my name is chair. Uh, wait this other refling time out
Other refling I think your connection might be do-do
Okay
Don't worry fellow reflings every tribe will tire the boss out. He'll die eventually
We know why his name is chair. What because of this reason?
I think those are refling might have timed out
There you are stand right there
Okay
You get done as soon as you come in right let me get my weak crossbow
Okay, we're ready
Are we steady? Do we have any blessings or anything? No, just oh shit. I think I think maybe that was a slight blessing back there, but it's okay
Oh, yeah, that's right. Take that seven damage, baby
One and then one two three
Yeah, so on phase one his oh god, I don't like that. I don't like that. I'll do that again
Don't do that again
I'll get lit. Oh, baby
All right, let me take arrow
Wait, I'm empty
Why am I empty?
See this game actually so confusing
I've selected both arrows. Sorry. If I select both arrows, it should just indiscriminately use some once one
Let's see if I can get poisoned down. I don't know
Hold on hold on
Oh
Okay, hold on. I might just fuck up really badly there. Hold on
Recovered that one
Okay
You want to see the concept art of how these came up with this one
Honestly
You're supposed to take down me
I'm not gonna lie. I was baiting my lips there but not on the good bait in the lip as in the
Munkai is baiting the lips. I don't even know what this wonder is fully done. I don't remember what I put in it
How you randomly? Well, I mean at least that roof needs to peel, but you randomly changed target
I can't give up
I do like that attack though, like they're getting up and doing a spray around the circle
Oh, I need to heal. What am I playing at?
Oh, no
Every fling is down. I repeat every fling is down
We are on winter fiend
So when he stomps it's a three chicken leg leg, uh pattern
No
I'm not gonna waste any more ammo. I'll just melee him today. Come here. Wait, that's not really
Why does chair sound like a cat?
Huh
Oh my squeaky chair
Or did I misunderstand
Right bumper and right trigger fire with left or right bolt
Why
Why would they have it set up?
I mean
I get it
But why
They mean chair's character
Uh
Pineapple you've known how to show make sure to eat your pineapple. No, actually you guys eat tomato
Does that write your name then I'm not going crazy. Do you know n before?
Is there a new refund maybe major refund wants another shot
Oh
Is that
Hold on
Is that her or am I being trolled because that may be her she's fucking addicted to this game
Um
Is that her
It is
No way. I was gonna say you're fucking addicted to this game. Is that her
No, wait, have you already have you already completed the dlc?
I
Have you already completed the dlc
It's her that helmet and weapon you recognize it
Oh, it's so over now. Are we gonna do it? I'm still at the start too though. Have you done the the fucking tiger before?
I should I think I should have made an account that was already ready to go
Oh pre-workist by the way. Mm. We do pre-workist is rounded part
I don't know if you've done it before
No, but she soloed the guy. Are you joking sin is so fucking good for like
one two
three
No, that was a complete message for that. Sorry. That was a different
I don't know how to touch
Oh, you're right, right I'll go for scarlet rock cheeky scarlet rock
Pineapple is trying to serenade the enemy very curious tactics will it play off? We do not know. Okay. Sorry wait
Oh, no, no, no, no, no don't I'm getting better since here. Oh, wow. I just got healed
Wait, you're a healer
Oh, you're a healer
Oh, sorry, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I know you're trying to heal me but
Okay, that was really fucking sin. It's not even in the lobby. Did she get stuck?
The bouncer didn't let me in. I have my stock outside the room only you would manage that that's hilarious
All I hear screaming outside the door
How did you even manage that wait? I'm so sorry guys streamer bias. I want to I want to see how if sin can do it
That would actually be insane
Streamer bias by the way streamer bias
I need to send in. Oh, you've not had a shot today
Oh my god, sorry streamer bias, but I don't know why the hell I was walked to the door. I don't maybe maybe like honestly
Wait, we need to look for a sin. She had a spacky ball
I seek the one with a spacky ball
Where is spacky ball
What are you
Are you down? Oh, there you are right. Let's see if sin can we've got ty lord and sin
I do oh wait
Look, look, look. He's got the mask of the enemy. So surely ty lord knows what to do
Surely and if sin sold this boss just as a warning though
There's severe lag and you are severely debuffed. Okay, I don't know why you weren't allowed in though right now
and
And then traverse limits
I love when it's like yeah, you did sip and damage, I'm like damn straight
Okay completely absolutely oh no, no, no, no, my my my my my my my my my my my my my
My souls, I just lost 500 fricking 500,000 souls because of that.
Lol.
Okay, let's try it again, and you come sentin'.
How?
He's so mean, he needs to stop lockin' onto me.
Right, no, we need to see the capabilities of Sin.
I know she's gonna go absolutely berserk.
We need to wait for Sin to show up, because seriously, I know she's gonna fuckin' rip
up on my new one.
Wow, wow, wow.
El Bereth, you've not had a shot.
Who, Ty, Lord, I do apologize, you just got millisecond and then I completely balls up.
Where is she?
I can smell her.
Oh.
Oh, it's you for music.
Okay, we have our champion, don't blow steam up Mars like this.
If you soloed this boss, you're actually insane.
Did you start on a new account or anything?
She's gone gollum.
Honestly.
Right, okay, we're ready to see.
I am gonna, well, it doesn't matter now, I don't need the souls, so I don't really need to do anything.
I'm gonna let him target someone.
Uh, uh, one.
Oh, I was far too early on that one, I'm not gonna lie.
Okay, Sin is in the battle dome.
I repeat, Sin is in the battle dome.
Oh, I've taken aggro.
That's okay though.
I'm allowed to take aggro.
And he doesn't fuck with me.
The other reefling is stuck outside the battle dome, unfortunately.
Oh no.
Oh no, I need to heal.
I need to heal, I'm already throwing.
Okay, the second reefling did make it inside the battle dome, all is good, all is wise.
We have a lot of aggro going on.
Okay, we have magic reefling.
There's gonna be a lot of aggro switching, she says, as the aggro has been swapped.
The guards are to be wrong, the aggro has been swapped.
There is gonna be a lot of aggro switching.
Wow.
Do I need taunt?
I'm like, do I need to put on that taunt trinket and just run around like a crazy person?
Because only crazy people can run.
You know that's how it works.
Okay, Sin does heal up.
We're about to hit phase two lightning.
Need to be careful, need to be careful.
Okay, I hate when he's up because he doesn't do it.
Okay, her person is taking all of the fucking aggro.
He's not even looking at me, I'm gonna regret saying that.
I literally hook, lane, and sinkered myself to do that.
Okay, again, it's so hard to see who he's charging the attack up for.
Okay, let's see if I can take aggro off them, I don't want to get hurt too much.
We are below 50% health.
I am going for the Scarlet Mortuce!
That was a fucking Christmas miracle, I dodged those other two attacks.
Oh, I got caught up in that one but it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
I still have some...
I think maybe I need to poison, I don't know.
They're flippin' about so much, it's like making my crossbows like undoable.
Okay, I need to be careful here.
I said I need to be careful here!
Okay, okay, okay, take your time.
Let's go for poison damage now on our crossbows.
I have aggro, that's okay, that's okay, that is okay.
I'm poppin' my physics, don't know what it does, but I'm poppin' it anyway.
How do you even come up with boss music, dude?
Not good, I'm down to one health to seek.
God, I think we're all weak, I think we're out of heals.
This team is tired, this is the best I got.
Oh, wow, how did I even dodge that? That was by accident.
I'm not even gonna pretend otherwise, I dodged that by accident.
Oh, no, not like this, not like this.
Didn't that cheeky poison damage?
I'm out, and for that reason, I'm out.
Not the light, man.
Holy shit, me and fuckin' Senna in sync, we're doing the exact same thing as each other.
Holy fuck.
Me, like, it literally means Senna's fucking synced up there, did you see that?
The way we were moving around the battlefield?
You didn't even know what I was doing from behind.
Holy crap, if you still had Bleedbolt, I think I'm out.
Got Flame, I got Poison, I got Ritusei, I got Lightning and Fire.
I don't know what he's resistant to.
Sorry, resistant to.
Okay, let me see, sure.
Is Senna wanting to go again? I think so.
Could you imagine if we do it a bit?
None other than the hit streamers, Senna.
Uh, you even know how to show, actually, Tyler, do you need Senna to do a show?
I love it when Senna knows she dies, it still goes in.
Literally, she's the bravest of us all.
She's probably ready to whack me being like, what are you doing, not helping in the fight?
Yeah, we're done.
After this, you should have a refling take cue to sign Ciclida's fragments to basically help you get scaled up with the bosses.
Oh no, is Sen region? Does she need a moment? Avenge me.
Oh no, is Senna, is that all the time you had?
Rip, rip, rip, rip. Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Thank you for hanging reflings.
Thank you for hanging Senna, that was absolutely fucking amazing.
I was like, wait, there's like a high likelihood that actually is her, because you're so fucking good at Elden Ring, honestly.
Okay, we're giving you a six, you can't rip.
Is Senna certified refling?
Well, I'm a certified imp.
So, yeah.
I'd say we're pretty on par for one another.
She almost carried, no, she did carry, joking me.
Right, mwah, mwah.
We've got a spell, oh, another one.
Another one, and we go.
And we go, I say we go.
I'm sorry, mummy, I was late to the last one.
Don't worry.
The good news is, well, someone took Agil instantly.
Let's build up the rotisserie, and then we'll do build up the poison.
Big wall lips, big wall lips all around, not gonna lie.
Mwah!
Someone got a bleed off.
Right, we're gonna swap to the other one now.
We're gonna swap to poison, see if that even does anything.
Doesn't feel like poison's really doing too much.
That's okay.
We're getting twerked on.
Literally, that refling literally just got twerked on.
I'm sure you all saw that.
In real time, in real time.
Well, someone got ultimate, Eldritch.
Can he not take damage when he's in that state?
Oh no, he can't be.
Strongly imps in refling, honestly.
I'm, like, smiling and, like, biting my lips.
Because it's, like, just so good.
Like, I'm not even mad.
I'm, like, it's just, like, in awe of this boss thing.
Did you stagger him there?
Okay, I don't, I don't know if he's even afflicted.
Mwah!
I'm not even sure he's afflicted with rotisserie.
I'm trying to make sure there's not so much aggro on the other refling at any one point!
Uh, sorry, I feel like literally focused to see what cues the game was giving me to let me...
To let me get away with it.
Oh no, no, no, not like this!
Not like this, refling!
Uh, I don't even have an excuse why I didn't respond in time to that one.
Hey!
Oh, the lightning got me!
Oh no! Right, okay, okay.
Oh, I can't even, I will actually want to let him kill me.
And I can't even get close to him, from the Nile he is.
Wow, we can do it, we can do it.
I'm sorry, I don't care if the stream turns into 12 hours of this.
I know for a fact we can do it.
She's suffering, but she likes it. Damn, guess I'm still too easy from waking up.
Bro got eight.
You're allowed to be eaten with it, boss.
It's been a couple of hours now, and little coachwoman still hasn't yet defeated Big Matt.
Well, if you want to come defeat him for us, you're more than welcome to.
Just to tell you, you did get a second chance.
Um, I'm very sorry, I cannot recall.
F, no, that's MPP.
I can't recall if you had a good attempt or not, and you're one.
You were recent, you're like very recent.
Rushing on the 6th, you've had a few 10s.
Major refund, I think you only had one attempt, you did, you've not had a second.
I'm trying to make it as fair as possible.
You know the rules, you know-
They're never gonna leave me.
That's the sentence.
Lightning, let's get fire and lightning, thunder bolts and lightning.
Very, very frightening.
Galileo, Galileo.
And bolts too.
Oh wait, we got bleed bolts, hold on, we got bleed bolts.
And we've all been dying.
Not gonna lie, I don't think this is the game that wants me to be summoned.
Are you on PC?
And are you using the code Reef in the multiplayer section?
Right, we'll do raw and we'll do fire, cause he doesn't use fire.
So by video game logic, but the multiplayer password up there is just Reef in capital letters.
And you should show up.
Oh, more bleed, tons more bleed.
Well, I guess we're bleeding this guy's to death.
Okay, pre-work is-
Okay, let's go.
I'm playing on PS5, oh it's not cross play.
Well, Reefland is not cross play.
You have been misled, you've been led astray by the lies.
Okay, let him get up, let him get up.
Big dive, big dive, big double dive.
Hit me with a triple dive.
Okay, triple on the dives, I repeat, triple on the dives.
Magic Reefling is swapping that aggro but does get picked on.
Are we all far away?
All of us are far away.
Oh no, this can't be, all of us attack from far away.
I mean, he's already down to lightning phase.
Did we not just enter this battle, Amina?
But I'm getting there.
I'm taking aggro, big jump.
Second attack, third attack with a butt swipe or something.
Posting off the butt swipe, lightning bolt, same thing.
Oh, he's got raw, I think I just saw raw effects on him.
I don't have bleed on him but...
Is that for me? No.
It's so hard to see who he's wanting to look onto.
Looks like it's on Mage Reefling.
Oh no, it's me, my turn.
My turn.
Good, good, good.
Not good, this one is not good because it's so fucking hard to dodge.
I think we're being rocked from the floor.
Again, one, and then...
A whirlwind swipe?
No, aggro changed.
Aggro changed.
Aggro changed to Mage.
No, I always fucked that one up.
Holy shit, you guys did it, you knocked him down.
All it took was three long range reeflings.
Holy shit.
I believe.
I believe, I believe, I have faith in the reeflings, I have faith in their hearts.
Deep down they know they can do it.
They have the strength, I believe, I believe, I believe.
Got reeflings, oh my god.
Remembrance of the dancing lion, I believe, I believe, I believe, I believe.
Thank you reeflings, thank you.
Wow, what did the boss draw?
His head.
Up with his head.
Does this give me better stuff?
Wow, that looks very scary.
Yeah, that's what you get for making this take so long.
Oh, I don't like it, it's actually kind of scary though.
Bro, the major reefing put in unholy work, really?
I can hardly tell, because it's getting very well.
Can I, I can't ride horsey through here.
Oh, it's an elevator, okay.
Wait, hold on, let me get my sword out, you know, like the actual thing that I swing about.
Where is it?
Here I am.
And then hold.
Let's explore.
Because I can't have this spell he uses OP.
What, the moon beam?
What a good boss fight.
Ooh, that's fire.
Ma, thank you for the gifted membership.
Congrats to those who caught it in your face.
Thanks again, Ma.
Wait, if that was celebration for the boss fight, why I didn't do any other work?
I didn't do a single bit of the work.
Ooh.
Okay.
Oh, there's a remembrance here.
I need to go back and get that one.
Reverence spirit, I shall live.
Is this bowling ball alley?
Or is the game actually going to give us a section with no enemies?
Or am I giving the game too much faith for you to let me do that?
That's madness that's coming out of the urge tree.
It looks like it anyway.
A house of thorns, I guess?
Overgrown roots.
Hello?
Are you okay?
Oh, tower of ours, hidden in shadow.
Oh, lofty spiral piercing the heavens.
Lead him safely unto greater godhood.
And in divinity, grant our salvation.
Curious.
You actually did take a bit of aggro off the last fight.
Did I actually?
I just fucking...
I'm just firing my laser.
And by laser, I...
Why is there so much blood here?
Tower of shadow message.
We'll just read it.
The gate of divinity lies in the tower sealed by shadow.
That is truly where Khaind Mekela is headed.
We are no MP...
MP Reans, but we must locate the path that we deserve.
And follow the process...
Is it a fake wall?
Not fake wall.
What?
I've been dumb and I'm just to cut the...
Wait, did I interact with the front?
Huh.
Sealed and obscured by a shadow.
You have to proceed elsewhere.
Okay.
We can't progress at this castle area.
So we will...
We'll go across the bridge.
We've not gone across the bridge.
Go to the three path cross.
And then we'll go across the bridge and all that.
Same for the reefling flattening.
Oh, hello. Do you talk to me?
If you've yet to do so.
Okay, I have a reefling.
Okay, I do my little explore list.
Because boss fights don't really count.
Because it's just like a whack after a whack.
But exploring is like you get to do a lot.
Arrow delivery? No way.
That's funny as anything.
Arrow delivery.
Oh, I need an enemy reefling to come here.
If anyone's at the three path cross.
Reefling flattening, more like reefling,
flapping in, am I right fellas?
Thank you.
Thank you. Oh, thank you.
Okay, I got an enemy reefling too.
I don't really know if I should put down the enemy reefling.
But I'll just try.
Because I guess you get to still adventure.
Just because you're like a whack.
Boo.
Oh, you want pre-ritual?
Does arrow delivery want pre-ritual?
That arrow delivery guy just like actually.
Holy, Rainbow Stone Shattered Bloodborne Fletch.
Did we do Fletching up in here?
4000 Fletch.
Oh, someone actually said that.
They were hoping I'd do more RuneScape after.
Okay, we got the pre-ritual down.
Oh my God.
Did you just...
I've got a Gollum Great Boat Crab.
Look at me.
You want to lie down too?
Reefling?
Oh, you're dropping stuff for me.
More bones.
So many bones.
Eh, bones.
Sorry, not bones.
Sorry, one of them has bones in the tail.
Ready?
Let's do a big run up.
Because we did fantastic on that boss fight.
Perfect.
I will just hold on to...
Oh, he went for it.
A fire dra...
Oh, talisman.
Hold on.
Are these talisman go together and...
Wait, hold on.
Equipment.
Talisman.
Are these complimentary to the bolts?
Nay fire and nay magic against me.
That...
Honestly, that seems pretty good at the line.
Oh, more.
Oh, an arrow talisman for when we do bosses.
I'll swap when we do bosses.
Okay, we need to...
go across the bridge, which Reefling's already done working with.
I have to get some drinks next, actually.
Didn't expect so many clips from yesterday.
Azura's wanting to lick your face.
Bruh, I was like, how steaming is she?
But I think everyone's good to go.
Speaking of everyone being good to go, how dare they?
Oh, okay, hold on.
Hold on, I have something funny to show you.
Are you ready?
Sorry for your...
I'm fucking charred.
I'm not even going to pretend.
I'm absolutely dying.
But like, the good came to die and not the bad came.
Like, I want to be here came to die.
Are you ready for this?
You know how we're playing Belcher next week?
Yeah.
What do you think?
I'm going to get those assets and use them.
What would you think for a thumbnail?
Mummy's betting the hoot.
My poor little Reeflings are going to either be in a cardboard box or not.
It's time to...
Well, it's time to...
Belcher.
Belcher doesn't really work.
Any Belcher?
I'm a Belcher.
That's pretty good.
Mummy's going to be spending all the milk money.
Let's go.
I like that.
Come back because you dodged.
Dome.
Sometimes.
Tome.
Dome.
Maybe it's a warning to not actually come here.
Lost ashes of war.
Okay, we appear to be doing a bit of pillaging.
There's actual things with humanity.
I'm helping, I'm helping, I'm not even gonna hit yet, I'm helping, I'm helping.
I'm putting my great sword on right now.
It has so much more reach.
Scottish English seems to be its own language.
I have such good news for you.
No, the British government acknowledges it.
Fire spark perfume bottle.
Someone's getting hurt.
Wait, Arrow Delivery is getting hurt. Where's Arrow? Help Arrow!
Why? Okay, he's dead.
Oh, another item.
Ooh, a skadoot leaf fragment.
What, when did this game get to French?
Skadoot leaf.
How did I manage to claim that when you were so close?
Oh no, you're getting boring.
Anyone want some calamari?
Perfume bottles are weapon?
Oh my god, this is such a girl's game.
Oh, no, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's just a harder one that's in the main area.
He's got armor.
Why is he looking at me? I'm getting nervous.
Okay, that's what I wanted to see.
Oh no, you made him fall down.
He's embarrassed.
He's going to think about this moment for the rest of his life because he fell down in front of us.
Wah.
I'm out of stamina. Hold on, let me get to it.
Wah. Oh wait, we got a critical?
Oh, we got a critical, alright.
Wah.
He's so stumpy.
Okay, we did it, we did it.
Woah, that's not friendly.
I got a somber smithing stone from his body.
Wait, you can actually farm crafting heroes now?
A shadow realm rune.
Yeah, so grossly the bosses claim weird personality.
I regret ascending that.
Honestly, true.
When have we never regretted a few cheeky comments?
Then you overthink it.
When you go to bed tonight, we be fun.
Then you'd be like, remember that time I did that cringe message in Stony's chat.
Then you worry.
And then when you do think of it, just giggle because I'm giggling with you.
Oh my god, a stagger timber there.
Woah, woah, woah!
Am I going crazy?
I need better armor yesterday.
Wait, so you can finally farm crafting heroes?
Is there something up here?
Oh my god!
The name's McCree, Jesse McCree.
It's Harmu.
I'm playing Fatball.
Sorry, sorry, I'm playing Fatball, a weed dust thing that are real.
I thought those things weren't real.
Is it tumbleweeds?
Yeah, tumbleweeds.
I thought tumbleweeds weren't real.
What's inside?
What?
Inside the box.
Milady?
Oh, that's so cool.
Milady.
Come, Milady, come, come, Milady.
Give me a sugar flat.
Then a McCree, right?
Jesse McCree.
Wait, no, the meme!
I don't have a hat that will go dunk, dunk, dunk, dunk on the thing.
Oh well, we tried.
Tips for Dora, Milady.
The lion head is cool and it gives like five strength and dexterity, but it debuffs here.
I don't know that.
What's the naughty thing that it does to you?
Why?
I thought that was an enemy.
I thought that was a cheeky enemy, not going to lie.
It's coming from an ankle.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Has anyone really been far even as decided to use even go on to do look more like?
What?
What did he say?
Is that true?
Has anyone...
Is that an acronym?
H-A-R-B-E
Part of the...
Okay, so it's not an acronym.
Are you havin' a stroke?
Thank you for the 20s, ask the question.
Are you okay?
Oh yeah.
Carved words.
I abandon here the flesh of my body.
Oh, I guess that fragment is her body.
She's giving body, ary, ary, ary, ary, ary, ary.
Yeah, I didn't know that.
A lot of people hear that.
Yeah, you like that.
You like the way I...
I have my slave reeflings.
They're all the work.
They're just so perfect and submissive
and carry me and let me hold their hand
and praise them and call them a good boy.
Yeah, oh, whoa.
It's really a...
It's like getting the whole...
What?
I don't know, application, you don't need to be off, it's okay.
Okay, I think we're safe.
Hold on, let me put my wee light on.
There we go.
He's not having a stroke.
Wait, is that an actual sentence structure?
It's a really old meme.
Oh.
What are we?
Not this way?
Oh no, the reeflings are split.
What way are we going?
Oh, that's the animal.
Right, someone's just gone on the waterfall
and another one's gone there.
Which way is it?
Right, he's got a fire.
He says, come this way, he's got a fire reefling.
Come reefling, he says he's got a fire.
Which way is it?
Oh!
There's a jump ahead reefling back there.
Don't forget to jump, please.
Seriously.
Oh, to get an item?
What is it?
I got a starlight shard.
Okay, it was just a wee thing.
Wee.
Okay, I got it, I got it.
One at a time.
Single fail, people.
Single fail.
This is a cliff face.
What makes you think we should go
three by three on the side?
You know what I'm saying?
Single fail.
Easy.
Take it easy.
This is more dangerous than the time we went
in the coffin down a waterfall.
Oh, there's a wee turtle.
Hello.
I pet the turtle.
I pet it, I pet it.
So cute.
Okay, sorry, sorry.
Okay, we're doing a Legend of Zelda movement.
We're going behind the waterfall.
I'll go over there.
There is some sort of item here.
Why has a...
Drawstring Royal Magic Hickory?
Not to be confused with fake magic.
Peasant?
Wait, why is there a fake?
Oh, it's because of me.
Sorry.
Doll.
I pet the doll.
As in the turtle.
I need to not do like combat actions,
because that accidentally triggers
aggressive music.
Could you imagine?
If...
If I could turn off and reading.
Wow, what a bizarre concept.
Truly.
I'm so sorry the dev team didn't even
think of it until now,
but I had to...
Someone had to break the news to them.
Well, we're looking at that.
That's a hassle.
Oh my god, we're making flower.
Push it.
Oh, you guys don't want to help.
You're making it heavier.
Oh my god, it's like a real cal...
Wait.
Why did we open it and then go up here?
I don't know who the fuck I'm beating up.
I'm beating the shit out of everyone.
Leave my replay alone.
I love the delay.
Like, I do it and then he's like...
A few seconds later.
That's a good order.
Wow.
Oh, not magic in him, but magic.
Oh, come on.
That makes me come out and around.
Not even Wednesday, though.
No, wait a minute.
Gotta wait for the stream delay.
This is what you guys are playing with.
Whoa, whoa.
What?
This is what you guys are playing with.
Whoa, whoa.
Did I miss something?
Was I not full health?
Was I like 1 HP or something?
Or is he all attack, no health?
Did I miss something?
Was I weak?
I just got one shot?
Um...
What?
I got one shot?
Where the fuck are we on the HUD?
We're on Castle Enius checkpoint.
Are you guys okay if I make a quick cup of tea?
There's 80% health on a single...
Literally, I blinked when I was dead.
I was like, oh, there's an enemy.
Um...
Got absolutely fucking rolled.
Me...
You were actually the enemy.
Whoa, no, no.
Sorry.
Uh...
When you do this on a movie,
don't do three books at the same time.
Alright, you've not done a main quest with me.
Just rushing around...
For somebody to...
You've not had a main quest.
Ooh, lollygagging with you.
We're doing lollygagging with you.
Arrow, you were just with us.
Oh wait, no!
Idiot.
Well, you were both with us.
But now you're with me again.
Oh my god, mommy, you did it?
Yeah?
I killed the lion.
I did it solo,
because the reflins were holding me back.
They were being...
They just got so distracted by the view, you know?
So I had to do it all by myself.
And I'm totally not telling you fibbers.
At all.
I'm telling you the biggest fib I have ever fibbed.
Lying women needs immediate refling correction.
I didn't see some,
I'm just gonna take a word for it.
Do not take my word for it.
Alright, I'm gonna very quickly make a wee cup of tea.
And I'm actually gonna clean out my ears,
because I can fucking seal them.
The view?
That means some refling can see from the back.
No, you can see...
No, this...
This is the view!
This right here is the view!
Then you can still kinda see it.
Right, I'm gonna very quickly make a cup of tea,
and get some food.
I'll be a four whole minute.
Hey, please do get a snack.
Please do get a...
Get a what?
Get a drink and a snack and a stretch.
I'll try and wake myself up.
I do apologise.
It's on my sleepy bambino,
but I had terrible sleep last night.
Yeah, it turns out I'm trying to like do a few things at once.
From Zoom 12 I restreams might not be that viable.
But who am I to say no to a cheeky stream?
Let's be honest.
Who am I to say no?
Right, I'll be back in four minutes, okay?
Give me four minutes.
Okay?
Okay.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Are you squidding me right now?
I have so much food to serve and really greedy got this.
Oh, why are you giving me money? Stop giving me money when I go and, like, friggin' pee and stuff.
Thank you, Zarian, I poor. 10 and... 10 and... 10 and... Why do you have a T in the middle of your name?
10... A... 10... To one... Carbonae... Unwilled... Stage 45... Sassafras...
Not Alessandro... Misacabes in chairs. Stop giving me fucking money for doing that and...
At least let it be an exchange of, like, you get I get, you know? I like that.
Right, my refund's good to go. Where the heck is the other refund? Is he hiding in his...
Hey, are you are you the other refund is he hiding it as an item? I
Knew you were freaking hiding as an item. I knew it
You're so silly. You're so predictable a lot of people and we're on the same wavelength
right um, I
Don't know how we on earth we defeat that guard. Do we just keep trying at the guard or?
What's the story about him
Oh my god, they drop Smith it you can literally farm smithing stones. Oh
I mean, I guess that makes sense why they introduced a new
Like smithing mechanic in this DLC area because you guys told me it's
Never learn it's because it's freaking out the piano
If you want to hear it in Scott because you're super chatted
It's pen in in scots. Yes pronounced pen in
All right, what's going on? We're not going up to him right fuck on me. We're going around here. Oh
Okay
Are we rethink predictable or my program do that? Well?
What programming you don't remember any programming because I made sure you wouldn't remember any programming
Oh, this guy has like no poise whatever
He cannot take this absolute thrashing wait, why am I thinking so much damage?
Are these not easy enemies am I gonna I'm not I'm losing it
I'm genuinely
Oh, he dropped bolts, I guess you can farm them for bolts if you ever needed them right now. We're going for the night. Oh
No, no, this can't be right. He's one hit. So how the fuck do we do this?
I
Does one hit leaves doesn't explain that friendly fire
Fuck he like wallops me when I'm trying to get a lick in
Okay, we're okay. We're okay. We're okay. We're okay. We're okay. We can do it
Right he doesn't have poise against a great sword that's good
We things are just sleeper agent
What's that black rock head
We shouldn't jump
But then again, oh you need intelligence to hold a sword. Yeah, I don't think so
Maybe not hold on maybe not hold on there's some fighting going on out here. We need help
Okay, I helped I helped the fight
Wow, I love
Here, oh, there's an enemy in here. That's what's in here
And then there's a blue read
Sorry, I'm getting so distracted. There's just so many kill things around here
With low intelligence you hold the sharp end of the sword and get hurt literally, I'm like, oh, I'm not smart enough to hold the sword
Oh up there up there, I don't have long range. Well, I do I tell you why but
open open
human
I'm not gonna stop until that catches on you. You understand. But can you open it any slower? Holy crap like
We
And I am gonna have to pause to eat
in a second
Cuz I
make grow avid I make grow avid
Do you remember that sexy milk that used to make food on the TV show and
She called it a micro wavy
Can I will I watch you guys attack with the t-jump down?
No, he comes this way, right? I'll deal with them then
Take that you have terrible poise
Wait, wait, wait, I'm refling. No. Oh my god. I need assassins creed up in this bitch. Oh
I miss well, actually, I didn't miss it. Oh
Little aerial assassination my poor refling is perished because of your frickin dastardly deeds
Okay, okay
Oh my god, they're dropping somber smithing stones. What the heck?
My god
Nigella Lawson. Aye, that's it. Aye. She's like I big big me crew heavy Paula Dean
No, Paula Dean's a stick of butter because she was
Because she wants to get her husband the heart attack
There's it now
The rat who ratchel ray
Is there a new oh, there's an item in here. Oh my god. Yeah, my kfc before gets hold. Whoa and be used sword. Oh
Refling it kind of looks like a bit of a boss, but
Um, um, um, um
Okay, he has shit poise that's what I like to hear shit boys shit boys shit boys
Get stunned get stunned get stunned
Okay gang banged by the rickling. Ah
That's right. Take it take it take it all that armor and you can't you can't we can't stop
All that armor and for what?
No, right at the next save station. I'm gonna eat my nom nom's, okay?
And then I'll get another
My poise breaking is actually so good. That's like retro rock
I did how do you even make the sound of like half the Pokemon there? These sound absolutely ridiculous. Oh
Reflame I can get you in again
Oh, I'm we fling. There you are my little adorable. Hold on. Let me claim the grace
Reflame I got me. I'm starting to think hardly anyone is in this area, which is a shame, but it's okay
Oh
Okay, and then I claim the grace and then I'm gonna inhale my McDonald's super fast at McDonald's
Not McDonald's I actually can't I can have breakfast McDonald's it doesn't make me go
But I can't the main menu
Breakfast it not breakfast
Okay, I'm gonna heal myself as chicken as the as spacey chicken from KFC and then a zinger burger
This will give me the energy to stream
I've got I like this spacey zinger burger in the spacey be chicken baits
I
Will sometimes they give you a really pitiful size bite and you're like, bro
My saying doesn't seem to show up. Are you got multiple your reef link and your own PC at reef? Sorry and your own PC
I
Will give you a pitiful size
Oh, I don't think they like that
Yep
Oh my god, have you ever had apple coleslaw the homemade apple coleslaw is so good
I
Mean as fast as cat it'll be a lot faster than the naturals I had yesterday. I promise actually I've only got a few bites
And the naturals are so messy
Oh
Person size should make you fat or sad
I don't know why
But fried chicken absolutely made them
Like American fried chicken though. I cannot wait to try it. I don't know. I like I watch a lot of food videos
And there's something about American fried chicken that just looks crazy. Did you say apple coleslaw? Yes, I'm not kidding
It's so nice and sweet
He's got meal and for friends
We have another 18 hours this time
I
Surprisingly the burger lasted I don't know how they do it, but
This is another conspiracy non-conspiracy, I don't really actually mind and I'm like convinced they somehow figured out that heating up
Take away makes it taste worse, but having a fresh makes it better
Your mouth animation. Yeah, like if my jaw goes down too much because I'm chewing my jaw goes down
So when I eat my mouth is closed, but my model's like
A little big paper
First food taste better. No say it's not real. I can't be true
No way, I know
But why can't it why can't it taste as good?
Hmm
That's a good point
So food can marinate and taste better the next day
One of the biggest examples is like just your average spaghetti dish or like a pasta dish
The next day because the flavor like infuses better with the pasta
Oh
No, you can tell when I stuff my mouth too big because I go like the model makes the face
Instead it's just the regular
Okay, I'm halfway through the burger. I'm almost done
Oh
My teeth are so full
Thank you to friends on how the degradation of works in the chemical reactions of the food in the boss
Spaghetti always tastes better the next day
I
This is the thing with tomato dishes deep in the flavor look guys get it all sharing our not wait
Why are we lying out on the table? What's going on here? Is this the dungeon? Are we in a dungeon right now?
That kind of dungeon
Cute hamster women
Want to see how much I can fit in my mouth want to see it again
And our behind-the-scenes question
But does watching a ball at times to impact the watch that?
I'm
negligible
negligible so
The YouTube if it's a two-hour bot and you watch it on times two
YouTube will give you will give me one hour of watch time for that even though you consumed at all
But it's better that you did that right then not watching it at all like it doesn't make a difference in terms of thing
The only thing it would make a difference in is ASMR content for some reason the way the ads work on ASMR content
And how it gets recommended I was a bit different. I don't know why I'm gone
The longer someone watches an ASMR video from start to finish the more it's gonna get recommended because YouTube go
Oh people watch this from start to end good
I
Hamster girl for gender. No, I have recent agency came out where we hamster
Watching ASMR in times to speed would be weird
That's basically what times two is more
I get any further known
Get to know fad for this
All meat slime ASMR times to brah that would go for a while
Gentoo these girls we are strong accent to
And
No
This is where things get a bit interesting because accent are in a major appeal
Are I wait once one more bite my burger and I finished it
I
Reef on doing out there
Wow, okay on the topic of accents and feature birds. Yes
It's very good at any moment. You can differentiate any girl
There's a slight
You may argue although this is completely my opinion, but
Who goes there identify yourself? I said identify yourself by the Pope and
There is possibly an American accent debuff in terms of if they cannot be distinguished
now
Obviously Azura and she be sound completely different. They have two very distinguishable voices
But would
Would I want to fill Gen 2 with all Americans? I would be cautious. I would be cautious. I
Want a Filipino I
Want an English or Welsh possibly? I
Want
I want
Satin of other in Europe
Possibly Japanese-speaking I
Want but the variety it did did it just burp you unconsciously okay
But just because I want does it mean I'm gonna get and please do not if you're lurking in the shadow
Please do not think as anyone you cuz I've just said that that's not how it works. I am just saying that I
Think accent differentiation
specifically in I
Guess a vtuber company corporation where we want to call it it's very important
Because if someone goes
If someone goes all that talent sounds like that talent you're up Shite Creek
That's not good
And
Good morning. Good afternoon or good evening. Oh, it's good morning. Good evening, and then good afternoon in the mess
If Jento doesn't have a southern belt like mama, I will
Maybe travel playground
Oh, that's when you put pranks down I was like what the frick is that word again?
What European accent in particular
I
Honestly couldn't be a rat or what country maybe an Espanol maybe a Latina
Or a Mexico I wouldn't mind that on the team
But if I'm gonna get it who knows it doesn't know fucking
Relax already people like fucking throwing shite just because I'm saying my
At the end of the day I do have now as much as I called the shots don't get me wrong
I called up presented
Forward everyone I wanted to be considered to the development team and everyone unanimously agreed with my choices
Which I'm really glad about yippie
As much as I am the barrier. I am not the sale be all end all Luxembourg
Italian or French well
In me I actually thought she would write shall we go replaying?
And one more kiss for you
Thank you. You want a KFC kiss?
KFC kiss just for you. Thank you for waiting whilst I was digesting and
It's actually good morning and in case I don't see you good afternoon. I'm no quote in the movie. I'm doing my own
Oh
My god
Okay, we don't need to jump you can just oh wait maybe jump on the last one
I don't know why torch bearer jumped on the last one jump on the last week
we think
Where's refling?
We playing okay, okay. You're fine. You're safe. You're fine. You're fine
Luxembourg reference. Oh my god Luxembourg
What language do you all speak in Luxembourg?
Luxenese you guys speak Luxenese over there
and I
Think someone asked me I was like, oh, what do you think of an arabic girl and I'm like I'm no being funny
the content that we make I
Don't think it's appropriate for anyone raised in those kind of country can't wait for the German beach of Rome
Hello lights
Yeah, we get some good and yeah, yeah dine and motheisen Spinehound
That's cola drinking. Yeah
Yeah, that's what our German feature is gonna sound like right. Okay edge to the gently edge
The one German absolutely just gobsmacked at the what I've just said. I just said your mother is a pig. I think
That's hot. That's what you want. You want a German? I mean, I'll take a German
I do like a German accent. I've done a German accent on English-speaking German accent
Accent should it shouldn't be overlooked. Whoa. I was a big star there should not be overlooked
I was gonna say can't be overlooked shouldn't be overlooked. Wait. Have we gone the wrong way?
Whoopsies. We've gone the wrong way. Look on it. Oh, we'll put the torch away. We're not sure where we're going
Now the torch is away. I repeat the torch is away. We do not know where we're going
So if we don't know where we're going, we might as well go on an adventure
This will be the furthest step I've ever taken from Lynn Graves
Oh
Reece Lynn
Is it really okay? He's got a torch again. We've got our head and boys. We've got our Baron gently gently
Wait, why did you roll? Why did you roll that? I don't know. There are enemies here. Wait, have we been here before?
I don't know the German. I don't listen to talk like that, but mommy. I can't like alright
Do you want me to do an actual nice German accent?
Fine. Are you block me? Wait, don't go this way. Oh, it's this is oh my god
They literally saved me. I am not kidding. You guys literally just saved me
I would have walked straight down into that
Unironically got saved by the reeflings from blocking me to imminent death
Okay, and an actual German accent. I would like a cute light voice German. I'd stick you on a lollipop
Oh
Where the fuck did you guys go? Oh, you went up the stairs like a cute lollipop German. I'm sorry. I kneel
Oh, no, this can be
Um, okay, this isn't okay. Good luck. Kiss. Mwah. Mwah. Mwah. I think you get sent back to your world. Okay. Okay. Okay
I'm not got the crossbow out. We're gonna see what the damage is behind here
Magic, okay, I can handle it. They're coming for me
I was a bit early, but that was actually very nice timing
What kind of are you trying to give me an enchantment? You are I saw that I caught it
Uh terrible news the poise is high. I repeat the poise is high
Okay
Wait, whoa, whoa, your blessing just caused me to lose like 10 health and no more
I miss right. Hold on. Let me get my stamina back
Curious what a lovely bomb. Oh, I miss sorry
Wow
Are you I don't I can't tell she's targeting half the time
Target these nuts
I like how we all just slammer unanimously. Whoa
Ah stop it. You you she's so much poise
Unbreakable unbreakable. That's not what I like in a woman
Oh
Hold on
I'm a pop my flask. I don't know what it does. I'm a pop it. Oh, it's empty. Of course. I've already popped it. Why wouldn't I?
What's this?
I didn't even know what my ultimate was there. Oh my god, my cup of tea's getting cold. Oh
Should I just crossbow for reason? I feel like she wouldn't have much
Hold on Reesland you guys hold on. I'm a swap to I'm a I'm a swap to my crossbow ball
I've got you. I've got you. Just hold on babies. Mommy's coming. Mommy just needs to aim bot
Right. Mommy's got aim bot. Mommy's got aim bot. Let's go. Let's fucking do this
Let's go
Let's go. Mommy's got aim bot. Let's do please damage
Yeah, let's take some aggro after we
I was very delayed on that response. I'm not going to tend otherwise
Okay, we got an ult. We got an ult. We got an ult. We got an ult. We got an ult. Uh, sorry, uh special attack
Oh, I'm getting my my bubble again my bubble
Mine's not even four times that
Oh, that's just rude mine's not my willy's not big like that honestly. That was that was just
That was hyper that's that category is hyper
Stop moving
As if it changed to me at the last second I saw that pointing at that refill and I was like, oh, I'm not gonna dodge because it's just pointing at that
Wait, stop moving
Right there
Okay
Did I do bleed damage yet? I don't know if I should try and do poison fire
Okay, that's in the wrong one. So that's fire. Okay fire. Why would you be resistant to fire? I'm not really sure
I'm okay. It's fine. I have a lovely cup of tea to enjoy after this very successful thing
I'm I promise I'm hitting all my shots when you see her on fire. That's me hitting my shots when you don't see her on fire
That's me fucking up all my shots
Is it is she doing bleed damage?
What is that? Uh, I guess she's not fire resistant. Why the fuck it?
Okay, we're going for scarlet rock because she clearly knows what she's doing with the
A magic knight
Wait
Get right. Oh, what the heck hold on
You're doing great sweetie. Keep it up. You're doing great. You're doing great. You're doing fantastic
I only have one incantation left
I've done all I can
Oh, no, we're actually gonna have to try and fight. I can't believe it
I know it's terrible
We're actually gonna have to try and play again
Do you mean you can't just carry me through one grave and I love the good thing?
How does that keep being one HB
That was phase two
You'll like to wait for a second and a refund perishes. Literally refunds. They're like witness me
All right, let me make sure I've got decent bows on
She seems to have magical resistance, right? So I should just do the blood one which I do have on
Hi
Right who's coming in yeah, I'm in boys get them in
Mage be mage. Oh my god. Where's my pen?
This piece of paper is going to be filled up so much. I cannot wait to post it when we finish this
Right mage. You've actually not wait. No, this is a boss fight. So it doesn't count
It doesn't count if it's a boss because we might be perishing over and over again
right mage reef in you come
Who's not who was
Oh
Oh my god, I saw that with a cat in my room
Vigo oh Vigo
Okay, let's see
Man, my name is still hiding
It's a broken
I'll check next time we die. I'll check whoever's put their symbol down
And and either everyone can confirm if they're there or not
No, hello, hello America. Hello
You want to lie down on the table here for no particular reason at all
No, I thought Vigo was in the room it was here
Okay, maybe we're not
Okay
Can you both get on that table so I can do my little thing
Oh
The other reason I think you can connect
Oh wait the other reef link could go in this table. No, no, no
Lie back down. Hi. Oh you turn it around right you turn it around. Okay. I thought
Okay, need a bit of a run up though
Ready
Oh, wait, that's not run. Why did I think that was wrong?
Oh, no, you turned out
I don't recall you at all and you come
Jacob boss
Oh, he's scaring
Well, you have a new nickname now. It's jacob boss
My bulldog
A ball crushing arpey
Elden cost me your feet honestly, it takes it takes a minute to show up. Hmm
There we think that thing does
There's a major refilling that thing that it was I'll take your name off the bottle
My bulldog
There's my connection kaka
Hold on. Oh, no, there we go
I'm a tease already fecking cold. We don't hold on
Pre-war
Oh
Jacob boss and you want to put yourself on the table for oh, they're all saying hi people
Although I've almost finished my tea
This is day four of an astronomical luffa bridge stuck in the oven
It's not looking good for me. That's all I'm saying. Oh major even dig it. Wait. I'm a dumbass major even got in it was
Who didn't get in?
Am I being pepega
I
Am being pepega
Huh
Is that a plane bread?
Oh my god, you're fisting me. Let's go
Okay, let's go, uh, right i'm doing crossbow vault to be nice and safe
What are you you look interesting? I can't even handle you
Okay, that happened if you do that pose that's an unknown. Okay, everything's right. Are any of you doing blessings?
Oh, no, I've already been slapped. Okay, well
Right ready someone's doing the spells. I hear it, but I think we're fine to go
This is the biggest luffa bread humanity will ever win honestly
a wee bit
Ah
Do you mind hold on did I even drop any soul?
Hold on I'm helping. I'm helping. Okay, I did drop some
See those things you never tell who they're gonna go to like until last
Why are you going for me? I'm literally the one doing the least amount of damage and she's like
You I want you
You are mine
I can't get over how much damage. Oh my god, I'm starting to understand why folks quit the game
So I'm I get why spoke her like I can't play this DLC is too hard because I literally am being carried and it's like a
Absolute nightmare. I'm still perishing in faith
I wonder if I really should maybe do magic and I could do magic from afar instead of the crossbow balls
Oh my god, I need to take aggro off of I need to take aggro like right now
Big wiener big wiener attack big wiener attack
That was an incredibly big wiener
I
This boss is crazy. What is she they let are not twin moon night
More like
Pieces
Well, you can bring night this lover. Sorry. I'm absolutely
spanking the
Hicks out of
The triggers to try and get the damage on her
I think I did get a bleak damage, you know that oh you gore
Oh you gore refling
Oh
Okay phase two show no mercy phase clearly
Oh my goodness, okay those flames aren't friendly
Hopefully she comes
She comes for me whilst the damage go against other refling. No, I don't trust it. I'm getting out of here
No, stop it
Oh, the only thing I didn't dodge was the magic right then. Yeah classic me
Dodge everything else for the fricking
Yeah
Oh
She can beat real nally you'll be fine for the rest of the dlc really
All right reflings you heard the man get to work get in this game right now get in this lobby right now
Get to work because everyone's easy from after this point
Right i'm just gonna check there's uh jess is in your name. Don't recognize jess
Welcome aboard jess
The funny I think I told you this piece of paper
I'm using was my old notes piece of paper for when I started writing scripts
So I've literally got like all of your names right next to
um the word good boy
h j
lube
I've got um a torch light wink wink
Um a bash light wink wink. I've got skin touching
Uh, I've got clapping of an uh other a chord like this is so previously inappropriate
H j like j or jai jai wait what wait what did that say?
Wait, what did that say?
I
Inappropriate active wait what
My pre-war ritual got me banned
What do you mean I can't hump them before they send them off to war
What do you mean I can't do that just restart, okay
Uh, that's new not had that one before
The game trying to gatekeep the reeflings from me
Banned for jumping
Banned for jumping. Oh that that an error occurred while launching the game. What?
How can it is it not close at all?
Sorry give me one second
Come on mr. PC, you know what to do
If anything they're fanfiles
Unbase, I don't know how I got there to open initializing initializing
Some lovely cool teeth
Hope this works are we're this isn't part of the plan, man
Game can't handle the maidens I the game's all about maidens as soon as the maidens shows up in desert duty
Oh, oh, that's too far. Oh, can't he can't behave in that? All right. All right, may I?
Leave relaunch better work
That made myself clear software the only thing soft around here the reeflings is what you've just done to us. How dare you?
Logging into Elden Ring game server
Yeah, continue
Wait, why is it not displaying on screen there?
Huh what's going on here beam capture
It doesn't see Elden Ring
Oh, no, why do you not see Elden Ring? Oh, no this can't be
Well
Oh
You can't see Elden Ring. Why not?
You do see Elden Ring you mean liar. Okay. Oh
Impromptu belt I was gonna say the only like thing I have on standby that I'm down for is belt rule
Okay, let's try that again. Let's see if we can get it right Jess. You wear like come in and you come
I'll see if there's anyone's name. Moogie. I don't recognize you joining the boss like that. I thought they'd get you in
Wow, we're back. Yes, you can see again. Oh my god
I thought I got banned for some reason like because you guys were helping me and the dev team were like
Not out here
Like oh
Oh my god, my my french pedicure is starting to really grow out now. You can see my natural nail under it
So I don't know when is a good time to start cutting it. It's not quite in the cuttable
I need to do my tap and ASMR first. Hi
America, hi y'all. Sorry, I got me itchy. I got you eyelash in my eye
Helping isn't against rules. It's just a bug like with the servers. It's probably just a mess up fail
Okay, we're back
I like how she does it. Oh, no, this can't be
Okay, we do a little kissy ceremony
And then we beat some ass we're gonna beat them up
And by we I mean you guys do all the work and I do a little tiny bit of poison damage, okay
ready
Let's what the heck did you just self-flash or whatever?
Thank you
What's it called when you punish yourself in the name of religion?
I forget the word
It's not fallacious. Nope. That's absolutely not the word flag elation
Flag elation
You fully will fish yourself
Okay, I'm missing all my shots
Hold on. Here you go. Now you know I'm gonna hit my shot. Whoa, someone got bleed damage in
Whoa
These reeflings aren't messing around
Okay, let's see if I can get a bleed as well if I can get a cheeky cross bloat cross
bleed
I want to try and take yeah, I was gonna say I'd rather I take that than the reeflings take that
Because that's not fair
Big wiener big wiener challenge big wiener challenge
Did she heal when she does that
Am I going great? No, no, sorry face who hasn't been achieved yet. I'm mistaken
Oh, we got stagger
We got oh, we've got freaking sardar online with all the blood
Oh my god, we're in phase two officially in phase two
We're in phase two. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I didn't expect her to keep doing me
Okay, successfully in phase two
I have faith
Holy crap. Does she jump around though jump up jump up and get down
She jumps man
Oh my god that sword blood of wherever the ultimate you're doing is like knocking
Knocking her on her arse. Sorry. I'm missing all my shots because she keeps moving around so much
I'm helping. I'm helping by missing. I'm the per delivery
No, no, no, no, no like this. No like this. No like this. Not like this. Hold on
Oh, oh, oh, hold on. Hold on. There should be one more one more one more. Hey
Let's go. She has five swipes of her magic attack
Her fire at the end of her attack as well counts as
Oh, you did fantastic reflins. That was fantastic. Great. I'm not going to waste any more ammo
I'm not going to waste any more ammo. That was a fantastic attempt. Holy moly. Holy moly
I can't wait to watch 10 hours of lore Alanis. I need a list. Sorry
Analysis for the DLC. Heck yeah
That was a fantastic attempt. Do not be upset. That was great. All you guys feel great. You really do. That was fantastic
um
Clarissa, you've not had a shot
At this boss
Is there any new refling names that haven't had a go
mage starlin you've been in russian you've been in perfume larn you've been in dresses new
Ty lord, have you taken a walk at this all? I don't think so
um
Wait, i'm going to put boss lion for this one and then
Wait, what's the current name of the boss like the twin moon or something twin
Twin moon night or something
I'm going to like put your names under the different bosses because i'm getting i'm getting a bit confuzzled
Because i'm not doing it right and i'm spelling all your names like terribly wrong after my name's pretend and otherwise like everyone's names in
I've got boss lion. I've got renala yesterday's boss. What was it?
I don't know. Yesterday's boss fight was
I had
Oh, what was yesterday's boss
That took us so long to do you guys know margot. Oh moog. It was moog. Let me put his name down
There i've like separated it now
the so if you
Once we're finished and i actually upload this you can kind of make heads or tails of what like the way i was making the note
Oh, i'm getting more thingies
Oh my god
Oh, don't mind the buzzes. Thank you. Thank you. Are you ready?
Are you ready steady getting ready for friday? He said take all of them
right we seem to have
Melee and maybe a mage
Okay, we got a boon. Is that it right? Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go
Okay, hold on that wasn't supposed to happen. That was a bit early
Wait, can i pick up my souls?
Oh, no, this is so real
Oh, I'm setting up for this one. I'm setting up for this one
I'm setting up. I'm spamming. Don't you think i'm not spamming?
You can hear them crossbow bolts go past
Oh, we've got the rotisserie. Wait, was that me that got the rotisserie? One two
She's actually quite slow in this phase, which i'm quite happy about
Oh bleed bleed phase two phase two warning
Phase two is coming. Holy shit. She's getting eaten alive
Careful of the big swathe heal up heal up. I'll take aggro. I'll try and take aggro
It's one two three four delay five on that one two three four delay five on that big swathe
No, no, no like this replay. No, I don't have my sword
I don't have my sword. I don't have my sword
Oh, but I kind of want to. Oh, okay. Well, uh, oh
No, she has wrought damage. All I had to do was keep running away
All I had to do was keep running and dodging because she has wrought damage. No
Oh, well another excuse to summon you guys in
Don't have to ask me like didn't have to fucking tell me
The sword does have bleed poison and raw
Damn
I was such a good attempt. Okay
Uh perfume boy, you've got how to try perfume
You've not had to try this one. Have you had to try this one?
Russian hasn't had an attempt at this one
Um, oh rushin, sorry. I'm calling you russian. You need some russian
I think this is it for me tonight. I'll watch it in a bit and then it's for good night
Yes, please rest well. Don't worry. We're playing this tomorrow as well
I don't know if tomorrow is going to be the full 12 hours. I actually don't know. Hi America. Hi
Um, I don't know if this will be a full 12 hour endurance
Um, unfortunately my
I'm taking a bit of hp damage at the moment because I can't sleep and I can't
Freakin do basic bodily functions and go go to the bathroom. So I don't know what's going on
I'm just happy to be here
Yeah, please feel free to uh, you do not have to stick around as for who else is streaming today
Hey, I don't know. I don't know
You
Hey, just a zero unless there's uh
Uh, who did not come in so perfume or you came in russia you think though
Alistair andrew you've not had a shot. I'll take your new waffle show. Don't worry
Um
Uh
So
Sorry, sorry, haven't uh
Ha, honestly
Wait, is everyone timing out? Is it my connection changeling you've not had a shot
Everyone's timing out. I'm so sorry
Sorry, this is uh, this is the part where uh
I
I might need to go for a loaf of bread like in the oven right now. I don't know. I'm gonna hydrate
I may have time I don't know
Oh
A little king Kong fingers knocking imagine if this is the time I can finally be here
I need a little summon. Okay, I think it's everybody down or some shit. Hold on
I mean get someone in I'm gonna very quickly see if I can squeeze this out. Sorry. I'm not very well right now
So
Hey, hey, are you squidding me right now?
You
Are you squidding me right now
Thanks the fucking heavens I produced a singular nugget
Okay, at least I know I'm not like completely dying off if I if nothing was produced
It's very nerve-racking. Oh, yeah, I think we did it
Oh
Oh my god, just one look. I'm happy. I passed anything holy crap. Okay, right. Let me let me bless you
Oh my god, I am not well. Holy crap. I
I don't know what the plan of action is. Thank you so much to
I poor sorry and a nebulosity
Um, sorry. Wait. No, no, no, no. I messed it up. I pressed the wrong one. Oh, I'm sorry
Oh, mommy's not very well. I apologize
Right. Let me let's I'm sorry. Okay. That'll do. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I need to kiss the other one as in kiss the other one
Oh
Sorry, sorry
Uh, actually from that good job. Who's my big girl?
Oh, literally I am not very well in health right now
And I want to just
I don't know what to do
I don't want to take a break because I'm just gonna rot in bed like it seems like such a way
If I'm like, oh go offline because I'm just gonna rot in bed to try and feel better at least like when we're playing we can have fun and stuff
But mom but
I don't know what it means
Oh, shit. Sorry. I wasn't paying attention. Oh, I had a blessing though. It was good, man
Feels good. I had a blessing. Yeah, you're right. I'm learning that attack pattern. Don't think I'm not
Oh
Those might
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa
Sorry, don't learn that attack pattern. No, no
So you're to focus on another reason for but
Okay
Oh
I'm spraying. Oh, I was in a freaking game
The crossbow bolt there, but she is on me
There
And whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, baby
Mmm
What time is it 7 a.m. I'm like I could go get a juice
A fruit juice and it was like basically I mean in theory it should reset me
I think I just
I
Oh, I wasn't paying attention. Thank you for the bubble though. Oh, this is it. Okay. Hold on. Hold on. Let's reset. Let's reset
Take a break if you're not feeling like I feel okay very no mom
Oh
The backswing got you
I think you need to take some time to focus on some back on work. Well, that's what that script writing is
Unfortunately, I can't really do like the editing
The editing's just straight up editing
Um
Oh wait, hold on hold on for it
I
Sorry, we've been sorry. It's about f and time wait what that you showed up about f and time
Uh anyone that's not
You couldn't connect we're gonna try you
Um
Where's the summoning pool thingy does anyone know the summoning pool is called castle lords chamber
It's very early into the map. I don't know how big the map goes
But uh everything is boxed out at the moment because i've not been there yet
So it's called castle. Sorry. It's called castle lords chambery
Sorry you're starting to make me worry. No, no, no, no, no, it's fine. I'm just
Look, we can't all be 10 out of 10 days. We can't all be 10 out of 10 streams. Okay. Oh, no, are you covering?
Oh my god, he's spitting me. Let's go
I just need my help you want to get in position
Okay, that's your position
Yeah, perfect
And
Just because i'm a soldier wait what do i need my crossbow give me my crossbow back
Yanker right we're ready
Daddy go down refills go down
Don't worry. I got the first hit. No, don't don't worry. I got the first hit. Yeah, dude
Wow, let's see
Oh, you can just run away from that one
I'm spamming I'm spamming they didn't see a bigger performer like me
You have a problem with streaming edition good thing the only thing that can take me off playing as youtube servers
Hey
Oh
I'm missing but i'm getting that beat
I'm only doing like 25 fucking points
Oh
Reeflings are going for it. Holy crap. They got a downing corner
Health check health check on a replaying your 50% just be careful
Weiner attack big wiener swipe big wiener swipe
Wow
You don't have any heels. Oh you do. You're just pranking me clearly. You're trying to make mommy worry
Oh, where's it gonna go?
Enemy again
I mean if she's stuck in this corner, I might actually be able to get some bleed damage wax in
I think I just saw a bleed damage go off there. Oh, hold on. Hold on. That's for me
Is it for me again?
Bruh, there's such trolls the way this freaking nice for it. Oh my god. You guys are absolutely going for it on our in the corner
Um, I'll just keep increasing bleed over here
Okay phase two I repeat phase two has been achieved. Wow. That's so beautifully orange. It's putting me to sleep. I'm not even kidding
That's fine. I'd rather take the
There we go. There we go
See if I can take the aggro like that so the the two reflings can just straight up go behind her and
Do the rest of the attack
Oh, that's why I recommended over 50 health one one question mark. She does a one and done
I'm spraying I'm spraying
I'm spraying
What is this? Hello?
What was that
I
I literally thought we were about to get ASMR'd by ace globes
Like the bloop bloop literally this
I don't know if it's gonna show up in the mic, but
like
That's what it looked like in the freaking sky
Need to jump the blast waves
Holy moly
That's the first time we've achieved that so do you've know how to shot?
Wow
What we're doing? Sorry, I didn't just say your name
I love strong ease. Oh, okay. It's supposed to probably
Oh
Rushi, did you have a we
Oh, did you time out?
I think you tamed out hold on you tamed out
Rushin sorry, it's Rushin
Okay, there we go
You can roll the attack as well
Jump
Okay, make sure jump jump. Okay. We know how to jump. That's good
It just requires good timing. So do you looks promising someone says because of the design?
Oh, no, they're covering. Are you sure it's promising as they're covering?
Yeah, let's see. Now put my we sword on this one
If I press y and get my we sword out wait
Now do more
No, I can't do my ultimate. Wait, hold on. Put that away
Yeah, put it oh no
Sorry, I don't really understand how the equipment shit works in this game
It's a it's rather confusing. Are you wanting to lie down Rushin for your pre-war?
Uh
For you oh, you're dropping me something oh more balls a speared crossbow level nine
Uh don't mind if I do hello
Level nine crossbow
Hold on might actually be able to do some damage
Hold the phone might be able to do something. Are you ready?
Are we ready is then we got any blessings or we just going for it
We've got a thingy. We're baiting. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. We can do it. How's the DLC going so far?
We're getting rolled but we are enjoying it
Fuck you
Oh my god, it sprays everywhere
Danny to
Sorry, sorry. We got caught up. I'm sorry. We got caught up. I'm sorry
But she likes her aggro on me wait Danny to aim
No, hold on
No way
Who the fuck uses this board? No way. This is literally call a jay. How are you supposed to
Oh, you held it so long
Oh my god, I actually like this because it's like oh, there's like a one in five chance one of them are gonna hit, you know
It's a big chance
I'm getting nervous for the ace globes the ace of our ace globes attack is making me nervous
She got cross damage or something. Oh, I wasn't paying attention
Oh big cop big swing big swing big swing. Oh, get right
Hold on
Oh my god, I'm like using so much on it. Okay phase two
I'll do an ace globe warning. Hold on. I need to change my arrows out. I've freaking burned through them. My apologies
Oh, we're fine. We're fine. It's okay. Mommy save mommy says mommy says
Oh, don't get right close now. Don't get right close now
Take your time
Take her time
Oh, can someone get this
Okay, careful ice globe warning coming up ice globe warning. I don't know when she does it. Maybe when she's 25
Up to all HP
One oh just just the one
Yep, just the one take that
Oh take that
Take that and this and one more for the raid. Let's go
One big swing
Careful for ice wolves ice wolves are coming up soon. They should be coming up real soon
Hold on
You can do it
One two
Okay, okay, okay
Take your time
This is every flings
I was here. I was here
Whoa, hold on. I'm reloading
Third swipe on the fourth back off. There we go
Now I've got a fifth pattern onto that. So don't don't give up until it's 10 to give up
I was here
Five swings there's a fifth swing now on that. Hold on. I'm a fucking crossbow ball
Hold on hold on
Careful the ice globe if it comes out
Hold on I need to fucking add in for the arm. I'm burning through these bolts like nothing on there
Is that ice? No, that's ours. Holy crap. What's that?
Okay, hold on. We're gripped up. We're gripped up. Hold on careful steady steady
I'm trying to take aggro so you guys can breathe. I'm trying to take aggro. It's not really working
My taunts on cooldown my taunts on cooldown for aggro dps slow down dps slow down
You're taking aggro
Okay
Jump jump jump jump jump. Oh, fuck. I was too late. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no link this
Not like this
Not like this. No, you guys did fantastic
Oh, you did fantastic
I didn't know when it was gonna drop. I thought I could react in time for the drop
But as soon as I see it, I'm just gonna start doing jumping jacks. Okay
Oh, that was a fantastic attempt
Rishan, were you not just in that? How do you think you're signed down? About time, right? You too had your sign down
Major Evelyn can't get a shot
Oh, that was such a fantastic
Go that was so good. I know you guys can do it like because we got down to there
I know
For a fact you guys can do it. Phoenix, have you had a shot?
I don't think so
Jess, did you get a shot?
I don't think Phoenix had a shot
Let's try it
I'm so sorry if you have had a shot and I'm like doing it wrong. I cannot tell you her unbelievably scribbly
Where where is the summoning pool?
It's not a summoning pool. It's it's this
This is where I pick you up from
The rest site
You put down your marker on the rest site at castle lords chamber
And then multiplayer password is reef
And then I can see your summoning sign because we share the same multiplayer thing
There is none we rate it at the grace yet the mark of grace
As long as you're on pc and you have the dlc
It cast the lords chambers the enemy
Okay, uh, do you want kisses?
What kind of oh you no way you both perfectly. Oh, I thought you both perfectly amoted to sit down together. That's funny
Are you sitting down?
Oh, yeah
Oh, yeah, okay. Let's see. Oh, you just want to fit
Okay, you have to be blessed
To war we go my reef flings. We still have this so I refuse to leave. I know we have this I refuse I refuse
But I'm stealing me moves not to drink but down straight
Okay, you ready? Okay, no one needs a blessing. We're not blessing
Hey, oh, that's nice. That's nice
One two third strike, which is delayed, but that's only in phase one
Wait, where the fuck are my arrows? Oh, sorry. I suck
Oh, no
Oh, no, hold on
Uh, I am burning through these like nothing on air. Oh crap
That's my fire. That's my fire. Don't worry. That's my fire. It's me me doing it
Hold on. I'm trying not to get us too close
Like I'm trying to give an angle that's opposite of her coming like if she becomes aggro
I want her to back away from the reef flings to give them breathing space to heal or to swallow a potion or something
But she is not having it. I actually can't I'm covering up her attacks. I think
I think I'm stopping you guys from being able to see her
Big swing one swing and then a swish
Oh, and I jumped right into
Of course, I jumped right into it. That'd be too easy
I'm wondering should I swap to the other crossbow ball? I feel like I'm like
I feel like I'm missing so many I need to be this close to her to do it
Okay, that was funny as fuck. Okay phase two phase two jump when you see the snow blue
Oh
No reef laying
Wait, am I empty? Oh my god. I'm empty. Oh my god. I'm empty. Hold on
Oh my god, I'm empty
I'm freaking burning through everything so quickly
I'm trying I'm trying I really am
Oh god, no
Okay, she's not in her
Fuck
Hold on give me aggro
Fuck you
Jump fuck fuck fuck
No, my baby reef link didn't make it. No my poor baby
Okay, I'm just gonna let her kill me. I don't want to do it without my reef links
But we did successfully avoid the ace globes for once
I thought I did it way too early, but I guess just jump and go for it
Oh my god, we are so gonna do it. I'm sorry. We're like getting so close
We're so close we're getting so close but no more arrows
Good try. Yeah, listen to the jump smile has everyone who's here had one attempt
I don't even see
What are you saying?
I don't know. I'm just gonna call you say I don't think says had a shot. How are we looking over here?
I don't think you've had a shot of this one
I mean, I don't think in general what face and what a name
I'm wondering I don't want to go to heavy
Without
Wait, how is that better for me than what I'm wearing?
what
Am I wearing like absolutely terrible ropes?
I'll oh it's turning my poise down. Wait, that puts my poise up
But my immunity goes down
Wait, hold on. I don't know how clothes work in this game. Okay, that's the best gloves over the best trousers I can have
I'm still a medium loads putting these on
Point up but look at the weight. Yeah
What was the negative thing this beast head did? I can't remember I can't recall
I mean everything I have is better than that
It's sorry the beast head is the best but I can still I'm still medium and stuff
Yeah, I've got you posing
That's what my whole looks like after the convention
Freel quick. Oh you you have items for me
Oh
Okay, I'll use my other crossbow this time. Are you ready? Three two one
Yeah
All right, let's see about using these more
Uh crazier
Ballista, let's try a ballista
I have 99 bird causes
Bird fair bar
Okay, that causes a loss of blood. Oh wait, is it this one I want to do with it?
Uh
Huh
I mean I'll try it. Well, give her a light one. Give her a bone. You're my bone
I already did it. Yeah, goober. I'll already uh
You can get kissing sit and you kiss it. Are you ready?
Uh the ballista needs great bolts. Okay. I have great bolts one surely surely. That's why I just go on. Yeah
Are they both these great bolts?
Why do video games give you items that are scarce if you never want to use them?
Because they are so scarce
Oh
I missed aha take that I missed. Hold on. Let me grab my tools
Uh
Okay, I am very tempted to go back to me crossbow
Okay, there we go. Did they even do any damage?
I don't even think they did anything
This is doing nothing
Am I going mental?
Hold on. Well, let me try to look at the HP bar
That's 400 it does
Sorry. Yeah, I'm like losing all mobility trying to use this ballista. I'm sorry. I'm losing all my mobility
Hold on. Let me swap out. You're doing great sweetie. Keep it up
Keep going darlin
Um, I don't want to use the rapid fire, but I have so much more damage. I'm not going arrow. It's actual bow and arrow
How do I use this?
No, I don't have bows. Hold on. I do have bows like one of these
Some of these that one
No
Oh, it's fucking purple
It's why did it you aim for her head? Oh, come on
Does that even do anything?
Uh, I'm definitely getting off of her
I feel like this is just the best way to go
Oh
I'm like not I'm not wasting as much ammo as well because if I miss I'm into
I rolled into it
He rolled twice
Right here, and I'm like not taking any aggro right now if I'm not fucking them. Yeah, sorry. I just completely
I was experimenting. I didn't experiment very well
Okay
I was far too early on that one. I knew exactly what I did wrong
Ah, are you dead? No, you're alive
How did that hit me?
Oh
I've used my wonders to beat
Oh, whoa, whoa, see that aggro swap is what I can't keep up with one hold on let me heal
Oh
Ah, okay, okay, okay about the souls are gotten that up
I think the shotgun
Crossbow the one that goes like it does a lot
Finally gets attached around you
Let's go
Solid fight not bad
They aren't that scarce. You just can't carry a lot at once. There's a lot less than your bleed though
So just focus on
Right spray bleed. That's all I need to do spray bleed
I'm still very um
Leap, leap, leap. The replant has given me tons of bleed. Literally all the bleed
Oh wait, I'm using a bow aren't I not an arrow?
That's an arrow. I need
I need what barbed bolts
Yeah
Uh, I'm not poison as well. You guys have oh that one has it
Okay, I'll do I'll do
This is really cool boss. I look forward to hating
Facing her. Wow. Oh good. The reinforcements are here
Uh, you is there anyone here who hasn't had a show?
Barrette?
Barrette hasn't had a show. I don't think I can't see
Suru you did have a show. Phoenix he says
Taku? You've not had a show
Oh
We'll drop you bolts. Don't you worry. Okay
Not only do I get in-game currency and game this and game that I also get in-game bulk
Are you a dom?
Something domey somethings mommy
Look at their tables
I don't like that. No kings. All weaklings are easy
Okay, we do kisses
Oh, oh, that's exactly what I needed. Let's go. All right. We're ready to do the boss
Oh, okay, that's exactly what I needed not even telling me. Okay. Let's do it. Let's go. Do you guys need to do any spells or incantations?
I don't think so you guys look like melee boys
Okay. Oh, no. Wait. We're getting praised. I missed it. Oh, wait. Did that hit me? It hit me. I still got it
Is there no way to zoom in on that?
Well, I guess it's closer I get and the more I can spray into her
But the more she can also do such a thing like that
Right into right into I seem to always go into that sword now
Oh
This is a bit like it's scary
When she can just do that
Phase two warning phase two warning. I can't take aggro without
Okay, phase two warning achieved
I
I'm trying to take aggro. I'm I'm
Oh, shit. I'm taking too much aggro. I took too much aggro
I wasn't prepared for that like left off there
Ah
That's so much bleed it's working though
Shotgun cross will burn both so fast. I think I should just do the singular one
I think you're right
But it's doing so much like we're getting so close
I don't know. Let me go again
Let me go again. Let me go again. All right, hold on
Can you feel like you had a shot of this by four?
Now don't think you had a shot of her
Anyone here who hasn't had a shot about fucking time
Hi lords, did you get a shot of this guy?
I'll read your name
I
Think
Watching you play the cross will makes me want to play a cross will build the cross will hardly does any damage at all
Oh, do you want to princess carry me through the game? Sure? You can
Yeah, the hit probability is higher which is causing the bleed if bleed does 10% full health damage
It just seems so worth it. You know
Are you guys ready?
up
Well, we get to it
Wait, I am convinced
With my reeflings anything is possible and I know for a fact we can do this
You're running out of bolts and landing
10% of them and that's 10% more damage then
I'm not really and then am I allowed to be cheeky and see I'm not really running out of bolts because the reeflings are giving me so many
Oh
My god, we're bleeding out a day. Oh big swipe
Actually did it for
Fire magic phase two look out for the ice tricking balls
Well, that's not me doing that hold on
Hold on mommy's gonna reload. Oh, you guys are doing fantastic darling
Oh, you're doing fantastic darling
Absolutely yummy delicious scrumptious darling
Delicious delicious delicious. Hold on
Uh
Uh, I'm gonna just accept it
Oh
My first reeflings that was a good attempt again that bleed damage is crazy. Does anyone have any more bleed damage boat anyone anyone?
It's okay. I can use the wreck the usual
Uh, what was that for those
What is this scarlet rock, you know blood loss as well?
And then what are you hair fumer's ball?
How is this danger? Oh, how is this damage done with the fire?
And then
Saru, did you come in really early? I think you might have
Again, I'm sorry if I'm kind of thinking over you. Please please give me patience
I'm trying to let everyone get a chance to to be the victor to be the one to win the boss with me
Wow, let me recalibrate my mouth. It's hardly moving. Oh, wow. I just hit my funny bone on the freaking
Oh shit calibrate my eyes wrong
Wait a minute
I think I lost my conscious
Okay, let's do
You can do this mom is doing her best. Um, I'm spraying and praying. Okay. Mwah. Mwah. Are you guys ready?
Do you need to do any special spells and incantations or anything for the win? I never actually know
I was just like pushed through the thing
I don't know. Okay. No. Oh shit. I missed it. Oh, no, you guys did it. Okay, fine
Uh, I'd like
I don't mind taking aggro
As if that's three fucking bastard of a
Uh
Like magical sword. Let me hold on you get closer. I'm like destroying all the back
And we take aggro when we do like
Yeah
I'm feeling very risky and very cocky this time. Like I'm wanting to go all in. I want to get close
I think she's taking frost damage, which needs to take 90 percent more damage
We're gonna need to do bleep bill
Oh, I'm out. Hold on. I'm out. Mommy's out. Hold on. Mommy's just
Uh, change her bolts
She's looking at me. I know she's not. I was fine. I can keep going
It's like some bolts here. I mean, it's the scarlet has been applied and she's just slowly working in
Okay, what's that normal
Okay, phase two has been achieved reef link
Completely balls that one up fully. Oh, oh my reef ones. No
You know, the only band with fire
Hold on
She has scarlet raw. So can I just run around like a maniac?
Get aggro
One two three shit far too, right I need calls in between that one
I've only got normal left hold on I'm helping though. That's an unhit
One hit. How is one hit taken out of my weak link?
I just made it no more. Rot won't last long enough without a sword
Is this thing from something better than anyone?
It's a race of learning and challenges that feel intimate
I
Double attacking faces
You're telling me
About time you've not been in for a hot
But
Hold on
You want him
You
So just gemos hydration check, okay hydration check
So
Right I think all of this I was good in the hood
Okay
Oh, you give me eyes in. Thank you. I got some balls. Oh, hold on. Let's do the blessings the ritual if you will
Who are you?
Are you a are you a blessing on to shield you from the blessing itself? Right? Are we ready refund?
You're beautiful
You didn't do the whimpering one. You're supposed to go. Oh
Oh, we got blessing blessing blessing any blessers blessing
See if I can get my souls
I'll take it. Oh, I never put any more bolts on 15. I can only have normal bolts to help out
If I only have normal bolts, I feel like I should probably just do that
I can at least take some I grow I didn't mean like that. Oh, someone put like a necronomic effect on her. She was like
Oh
I have to admit my bleep damaged bolts were pretty much carrying I'm a
Boy, I'm not gonna lie. I think my balls were carrying a little
If someone's poisoned her that wasn't me
She's been poisoned. She's been poisoned. Hold on. I'm missing all my good shots
I'm gonna take some aggro off of them because they are
Not this kind of aggro
Oh
I'm missing all my good adults my crossbow bolts. I think I might just have to do bow and arrow
And because I've got like a billion bleep bow and arrow, so I think maybe hold on. Can I do that now?
Hold on a minute
Is this gonna do what I think it's gonna do
Is it doing what I think it's doing and it's gonna give her a bleed
Oh
Not with that. Oh, I was too. I need to it. It's dodge pause dodge for that the big arrow
It's just doing what I think
Face to cheese
Someone's poison spore and are like crazy and then fifth swipe. No little reflin
One just one
Okay, oh
Right, so am I taking some bleep damage doing this or no, I just like
Applying bleed, okay, so it is doing it is doing it
Ah, we can do it reflin. We can do it. I believe I believe I believe
Because someone said if we if we defeat her we're good to go
Like if we defeat her we are good to go. We are doing it. I just say full of a zero
Sweet name. You got this strong. Thank you for the five disciple of a zero. Oh, you gotta be bleeding heart
Mugi, have you had the thing shot yet? I don't think you have
Here's the accent
You may have been slightly recent. I'm not sure
Oh, I have to admit I'm starting to get a bit. I'm not sure who's been in and who's not
My brain is not very switched on. Thank you for the five disciple of a zero
Do the whimper do the whimper. I want the whimper one. Not your beautiful. Or do you not have the whimper one?
Hit to go and the other bosses are kind of just as hard
No, don't say that. No. No. No. I don't want to hear that
I don't want to hear such accusations against the other bosses of this game
And the in the wise words of ever came in is that you that came in and said if you do it, you uh, we win. Okay, so we're gonna win
You just need to level up Mugi. Mugi items
Uh, what was I doing? I was actually just straight up doing a bow and bow bow and arrow
There'll be no blowing arrows in this house
Oh
Enemy reefling you can't come in you silly bobo Billy. You can't come in. We're about to do a boss
I'm gonna just let you do what you need to do out here. Okay, we'll grab my soles
I'm going in
Let's get to work
Sorry, sorry, I wasn't paying attention that well
Wow
Sorry, my eyes are getting tired
I'm not paying attention
Right, I need a lock in I'm locking in I'm in I'm locked
The key
Okay, so if I cross this is taking what 20 percent more damage overall
Okay
We're all can share and I grow one sway and then oh
Wait, it's far too long to do that. I will get it. I will get it. I will get six
I'm I just like a hundred pair bull honestly a hundred pair bull. I'm doing a
I mean, it's all right
No, okay, I'm completely missing I need to get closer
Oh bleep bleep bleep I saw it I saw it we got a successful bleed phase two incoming phase two incoming
Oh
We got knocked down
We're doing it we're doing it don't get too cocky
We get too cocky
That's fine
Oh, she's so volatile she's so volatile
Yeah
Take it like a man. I'm coming at you
We're gonna do it. She is so hard
That's phase two how fast
The chip damage also results in 10 percent blasto bleed and those were two actually. Is that how she went down?
Oh god, I finally showed up used the red just to confirm. So you only show up in red
I don't see right or as in it shouldn't do that. I'm not sure why
Oh, wait, okay, hold on. I think we're going to bleed damage route. Let's get you in bleed
If we all do bleed because I've got bleed arrows
and
Have you been in for a bit? I don't think you have been
I don't know. I've not got a clue
I've no got a clue. Sorry. Nothing's getting more cruzier by the second. So you can only come in as an enemy that's
No
Oh, wait, someone timed out
Who couldn't come in?
Uh
Oh
Hey timed out. Oh bleeds timed out
Inappropriate activity nothing. That's strange bug. I wonder what the code means for that
Wait, the other one switched out as well
It's really not it's haven't oh there you go. And then you can have a shot. It's really having a hard time
Like I don't get me wrong. I know like literally everyone in their nan is on elven ring right now. Um
Yes, I'm in a hard time
Okay, I think our ritual is gonna have to be kisses because
Um, it's taking me a hot second
To get into the win this boss. I don't know how long we've been at this boss floor. We've been at them for like two hours
I think we might need to do bleed against her. Are you two ready to do bleed?
I'm gonna do a figure eight around you. Oh
items here
I can pull my crossbow ball again
I'll burn through it unless I do that one instead
Yeah, thank you
Right, okay. We're ready. We're not ready going to battle. Uh, I think if we lose this one
I think it may this just seems like a bleed one
And we should just bleed out the wazoo
Um, oh my swords are literally mid map. Lovely
Haha, you were casting. Thank you. You got hit by my spell
I'm sorry. Other people never thought you hurt there. Yeah. Dang. What was that?
Hold on. Let me grab my sword real quick
That's just a reactive model on just so you know how absolutely crazy I love the screen
Okay
We're taking our time
Fucking I
Okay
Oh
Oh no
What does that do? Oh, it rains thunder from above
There we go, I didn't say I was like this when I hit that button
I'm gonna try and keep too early too early far too early, but it still works out
Okay
I can't even dodge that third one. She just did there that was impossible to dodge with it. It's not, can he be?
The game's still like that
Okay, we're entering phase two. We're entering phase two soon, soon p.m
We are
Okay, phase two has been entered careful snow globes or ice globes are
Wow, that's so beautiful. Let me see if I want to go to sleep
Don't do that move again. Let me see if I want to go to sleep one. Wait, that hit me
I thought I dodged that to be honest. I must be my reaction time must be absolutely garbage
Wait, the other reefling perished
Oh, no, sorry. I didn't even know it
Oh, I'm trying to like counter
Oh
Sorry, I'm actually trying to focus, but I can't, oh my god, I'm actually focusing on my crystal
I'm trying I'm trying
I'm trying
Sen, you're fucking Sen, are you killed her? I'm actually focusing up. Literally. I stopped talking focus up instantly gets
a too shorted
Sen, have you killed her? She's at
a castle lord chamber. I'm going absolutely fucking gold
Okay bleed we're gonna try and get you in this time
If we're I think bleed is the way to get her
I think I had you in the end, but we seem to be in norm. You've not been in a hotspot
I've not been there yet. Oh my god, so except for what's to come brah. It's so fucking out. Are you doing it solo?
Are you playing with the imps?
Get the imps to carry you so you can actually enjoy the the story more than anything else
Even though the story is so arbitrary
We're turning the music off hell. I mean, I'm happy to turn it down
No
We'll put the music down by two
Just to see if we can maybe hear cues a bit more
She summons imps only for the scorpions. I believe that because
Sen cannot stand like bugs, insects, all that kind of thing
Yeah, and we're doing a gluck gluck circle
I'm doing solo, but oh my god, the scorpions in that castle tried to get imps to clear them out because it wouldn't work because the lion boss was dead. Oh
What we're doing and we kissing and we got a lot kissing going on. All right, you ready?
Okay, let's go. Let's do it
Yeah, literally Sen cannot stand bugs. It's actually uh, such a wee shame because it really gets her hard
Okay
The no bug girls in viola as well while we're at it
Let's
Let's get her bowl bear. I said, let's get her bowl bearings. Right. Hold on. Let's just
I say what's going on and then we can start firing
Okay
Okay, bleach seems to be the way to kill this night
Oh, wait, sorry, I was freaking loading
The acres on me
We're gonna go for the cheeky bleeds. Oh, we got bleeds. We got bleeds. We got big bleeds there
Oh fantastic
Okay, bleeds is the way to go against this character. There's um, I cannot be
Why are you getting so full right jump wait in odd? Why did I jump?
I don't know why I jumped I meant dodge and then wait and then jump
And if we know
I know what I mean. I can't say it right right now
Who's she looking at?
She's looking at me
And one more for luck
Okay, let's see if we can get another bleach soon tm. Oh, not on me though
Oh, not on me though
Yeah, see that change it's so volatile that change in aggro is just
It's almost unpredictable because it looks like she's not even gonna charge off or dude
How does that always hit? Do I need to roll into it or like roll directly forward into it possibly?
Or roll directly backwards
I'm gonna feel like he oh
Okay, okay. Okay. We're cooking
We're cooking
Let's see if I can get a bleed for these fucking bow and arrows
So I'm not the useless
Well, I'm pretty useless, but you know what I mean, you know what I mean
That was it that was the fucking run and all I had to do was dodge some blue lights
Man, all I had to do was dodge some blood and legs
I like bugs in real life, but the ones in gains are overkill. The scuttle says bro. I ran past that entire section
I missed off a stat. I was to pick up something out of statue and I completely like ignored it
Uh, Jess did I get you Henry? I don't think I get Jess back in again
Uh, Taku and Jess you're gonna be my joy this time
I
Hope everyone's got a bleed build brought back the images of how those baby scurfs playing to their mama and whores
It's kind of weird that you wouldn't think instinct
Like instincts and bugs kind of have that thing going for them, but uh
That is good gotta roll through it anything else you just don't clear
Yeah, it's like I got a roll like right forward into that big swipe. She does
So we know we now know her biggest weakness
buzz
with our bug
Okay, hopefully you two are on
bleed
Uh
What's he doing? He's gonna be crying chan. What does this say?
Freeze the pincer attack
Over again blast. We have been blessed. Let's go
Let's do it. Let's do it 20 minute adventure reeflings
Right, I'm fucking falling asleep clearly. I've had enough clearly. I've had enough because I'm falling asleep getting attacked by the easy
I take aggro to give that reefing some space
Yeah, they get locked into that attack which is fine with me
Right heel heel mother
You know
Oh, we got a hit we got a hit that was a big chunk whatever that was
I don't know if that was a bleed or not. I see frost damage though
My game crashed
My game crashed. Hello
My game literally just crashed
I'm back though. I like just pause
Did you guys see that?
Are you teabagging?
Oh my god, did you see that though?
I'm surprised we're even still here. I thought that the thing was gonna explode. Sorry. I'm not paying attention
die
Oh god, I the one I would have died if I didn't dodge that. I'm not gonna lie. I think I would have been born
Oh, yeah, oh, sorry, I was uh, I never pay attention to that attack. Honestly. Sorry, my dumb ass fall asleep
I am I may as well be asleep right now
I'm gonna feel health. I just don't like having more health
Considering how easy it is to get one shot if I am
well
Two in a wee bit of short
Oh
See when I can take aggro like that, it's fantastic for the reason we need to like move in and just have our ease
If I can keep aggro
Okay, one swing wait swing again. Oh, we finally did it
Finally
Oh, no, no, no, no, no
Are you both dead? Oh, don't be so selfish
Don't be so selfish
You haven't managed to live long enough to run out of healing
So you're good to keep going
It's a ration healing when the problem is restrained easy
Did you know that performance drops after the four hour mark? It doesn't matter if it's physical or mental
I am
But if I don't have to perform when the reef links are carrying man, it doesn't count
And we go again, right? How about that? I'm not allowed to go to sleep until we went against this boss
That seems like a fair go. I'm trying to remember who I've not had in the longest
I'm trying I'm trying
I think you and you haven't been in the longest
It's all our fault no
The internet killed me. Literally my fucking thing
So today was the first time I got summoned in this game ever
I didn't know I would have
Half my heels and I guess it kind of scales the damage of the boss. It's also kind of hard even missing it. Oh, no, it is like
I suck at the game and I basically have two reef links that are nerfed into the ground to help me
Okay, if there is a big gigger Chad Elton player come now so she can go to sleep. Oh, you send me a bed
Are you ready? Are you ready? Oh, you're here to carry me like literally and figuratively in the game
Boss gains 20 damage and 50 health per extra player. Wait, am I really nervous am I making a words for myself?
Someone get let me solo her
Okay, just felt
Wait, why did that go through me? Am I going crazy? I did nothing to dodge that and it didn't hurt me
I think I'm losing it
unless
sorry
My performance is going down. I repeat my performance is going down
We have hit the performance mark
Holy crap, just throwing knives. Is that throwing knives?
You're making me want to use throwing knives
Okay, avoid wait avoid. Okay. Avoid wait avoid. That's all I have to do. I'll start start
Oh
Again they go for me. I didn't expect that
That's how to get you don't expect that. Oh, we need to help her. Give me aggro. Give me aggro
Wow
Give me aggro. I know like this
I
Was just one
It wasn't a five-phase swing. No refling
I can't take aggro
It's not giving me aggro. I ain't go aggro. Successfully. It's exactly
Oh
The bluetooth device as uh
Oh piss I didn't expect that
Oh
You guys are doing so well though, you guys are getting so close
You guys are doing so well
Every time she slips behind me and trashes me
Just not just in game, but also out of the carriage into her farm
She hits like a truck. Oh, she does like
The buffs and the the combo in the second phase is just unforgiving. It really is
Mushroom man not had you about
Uh russian
No, I'm not writing down names anymore. I'm just trying to guess on my head
Which is a probably a terrible way to do it
Right you two have not seen any of me that edge and ring would fuck. Please. Let me have it this sweet release
Honestly though
There's no need for this guy for half of your carry story on the farm
With all the chickens and the ducks that eat the piss and all the plants that we have
The amazing
Meanwhile me parrying the black knight downstairs for an hour on y'all
Right. Are you ready? Mwah. Mwah
We'll see if we get all you carry you offer to carry me
Let's see if your actions speak louder than your words. No, no, let's see if your remote speaks louder than your
implications
Because either it's gonna happen. Are we getting blessed? Oh, we got blessed
Blessed to impress forget dressed to impress. We are blessed to prevent
Give me these souls
Wait, whoa
I lost aggro as soon as I came in
Oh
Oh my god that bleed though
Oh my god, I couldn't get her awful
Okay, so even though my crossbow doesn't do much damage if I get up leading it's almost like it makes up for the missing damage
Does that make any sense whatsoever?
We flings remove this woman right now from my game eliminate her
She's so hard for no reason
Is there anyone that's male?
I react far too late
The bleed is the prop where your damage is hidden. So you just got to build it up
You could also drop her could could this
The poison bills might do the trick
I haven't been in for a single time. What's your name?
In game
I'll try and get everyone in
Oh, sorry
Shadow realm blessing
Oh, I don't know why any of that pushes but he will
Uh
Partially I'm running out of effects. I just have like default bolts, which is fine. It's not problem
Upgrade it. Oh my apologies. Sorry
Shadow realm blessing sacred tree
Consume sacred tree fragments to bolster your blessings the blessing bolsters the acceptance ability to deal and negate damage
But has no influence outside of the realm
sure
For you
Reverend spirit the reverence fillet blessing bolsters both summon spirit and spectral speed ability to deal and negate damage
Wait, so they were like, okay, we know the game's too hard. So we're going to introduce this
That's quite humorous, honestly
Uh, it increases damage
My name in game is Bella. Hold on
Uh, there we go stream sniped you from across the room. I had you
Fennec's been in on the whole
Yes, you have had in the tent. I think fennec's is the one who's not had a shot in a wee while
Unset probably fennec set
Okay, fennec and then set next
He's not had a hot check and don't turn it back to everyone has had a chance
I might hop in and try and parry her
I don't know how you guys have the reaction time for a parry. I think the last time I did like a reaction time test
I was like 162
ms, which wasn't the worst
But it wasn't exactly like I'm an elite gamer. I'll need to see what it is now
I feel like it's probably going way down like I'm just a tired bean
Are you ready?
Are you steady?
Oh, no, fennec's is suck. Oh, no, he's giving me so
Poison
Because you're poison. Oh, you give me balls
You are giving me bolts. I can put these on bolts
bolts
and then
Poison so we're going to do blood loss and poison on her. Yeah
Hell yeah, thank you. Thank you very much. Oh, you got the design mouse for being my sugar daddy in game
Ready anyone doing a blessing? No, we look mainly players. So I don't think anyone's done any blessings out here
Okay, give me these first
Let's try poison
Okay, it's not working. That's kind of it
I'm going for maybe bleed dammit. No, no poison first
and bleed the brick out of her
Mate mods
Reflings make it to my tomato ketchup seeds inside this woman
Hold on. Why does it run flat out?
I was just
Okay, we've got frost right I'm going for bleed now if I see frost I'm going for bleed
I don't I don't know how to confirm. She's poisoned
And poison doesn't last neither just scarlet
Okay dodge wait dodge. Oh my god
I can't believe it. I'm actually getting good at the attack. Well. No, let's not jinx it now
I'm being wise enough to
Remember
The way the attack
Okay, I don't like that one
Okay, that's definitely poison I think so I'm doing blood now
I'm doing
Phase two activated look out for snow globes. That's all
Mummy is
Oh
No, we do get special on her that was a juicy bit of HP that was
I'm going for bleed
I don't know. She's gonna swap. I exactly what I thought she was gonna do. Hold on. I need to heal
She's gonna attack me
Okay, here we go I'm back in the fate I'm back in the fate
Who did I do that?
How did I do that?
Sorry my mouse is the gate trying to stay alive right now
Just a singular
It's not over until it's over
Oh, it's not over until it's over
I do not understand how some people can do no hit runs. I my mind jump
Fuck
Oh, wow, I actually survived that I didn't know I could survive that
That's why I was too early anyway
Oh my god, I didn't even know how to survive that
Um, that was fantastic
So but I had a few good dodges in there. Sorry, but like I need a few headhats for those dodges
Do you see some of them in there like a dodged a whole sequence?
I actually getting good
The upgrade works. So now I don't actually perish if I'm full health. I don't perish from the ASMR rifles
It's okay every field attempt is a lesson
Right. Say it. You've not been in
Who are you?
Jennifer yourself at once
I feel like I've let you in a few times now russian. Takun hasn't been in. I need
Bleed wherever he is. His breath did get a chance
His bleed away. I think bleed isn't here anymore
I can have plenty of arrows. Yeah, I do. I'll have like tons of poison and blood so
You did great good girls
Okay. Yeah
Those dodges are scary, but like when you have confidence
That you know, you can dodge it in time then it becomes like quite easy. Are you a bleed build?
Uh, that sword looks like a bleed to me
I think it'll work. Oh, oh wait. I am I am
What
What you got more balls. Thank you. Are you ready?
Oh, are you going to your inventory? We didn't my beloved
No, you need to whimper right. We're all gonna do we're gonna get the whimpering coconut soon
I promise you we're getting the whimpering coconut after we do this boss. We're gonna get the whimpering coconut
I don't know where it is, but everyone needs to get the whimpering coconut. Where's my
So you actually can just outrun that
You can outrun that. Oh god, we're all stacking. Sorry. I'm trying to get a different angle
In the plain field. Oh wait, that's oh no, I don't want poison build up. Sorry. Let's do poison first
Stop moving lady so I can hit you
I need to get you poisoned
Is
Is it like those twins in the original game? Oh, oh, we got poisoned. We got poisoned right. We're doing blood now
We're doing bleeding effect
If I notice the poison goes off, I will go back to poison
I wonder if poison and drop would be like even deadlier combo
Oh
Possibly
I knew that was coming from me had my damn name on it
Oh
Oh the poison's still like doing tick damage the poison's doing 50 tick damage
50 is gonna add up over time real quick holy crap
I think it is is this poison last the entire fight
If poison and rot together, I might be better put myself into poison and rot and then swap them back to bleed
Because it is going down face to face to
Oh
Shit delay. Yeah, sorry. I messed up a lot of them, but I knew I was doing
Another stagger
Please no, please no ASMR ice wolves. I'd appreciate it
Yeah, I knew it was still coming from me
I
Man doesn't make me scared when she gets close
Don't hold on
Dodge pause dodge too early, but it's okay. It's okay. Let him get up. Let him get up. Let him get up
No, I don't want to hear that uh jump jump jump. Oh, I missed it, but I think I can survive
Okay, okay, two of us have remained
She doesn't do the ice globe ASMR ice club attack again does she
Hold on hold on. I'm trying to take aggro. She's refusing to look at me. Ah
I'm trying to get bleed our aggro just to give you some breathing room
No
Seeing so
Oh my dear
I don't think I have enough time to even try and get my sword out
No
I want to I want to win with you guys
It's not the same winning on my eight on my own. I don't like it. I want to win with you guys
She caught me mid to drink. Why are you having a drink in the middle of a fight?
Uh
It's an attempt to end the fight. It seems you can only do it once. It's our it's her true ultimate. Okay
We are getting there. Sorry. We're getting so close like I legit have faith like I'm sorry if you're bored of this
I have so much faith
Um, so wrong though. You've not been in for this in a wee hot site
And
Can't read your name about f in time
Is that what you're saying because I take so long to come in
We're getting so close. No seriously. Um, oh for heel. Sorry. Sorry. I thought you meant you were like taking a
Swiggy your cola mid fight and I'm like right now. Now's when you're thirsty
Sorry, my apology
It's not boring. It's painful because I don't know how bad you feel
No, I'm I think we've got it
I want to go get the morning coconut after and then that's that's my reward for getting this the
getting this far
the morning coconut
my below
Is the other leafling gonna time out? I hope no
I'm having a swig in real life too. Yeah
Oh wait a minute
Any bleeding hearts a zero is t minus
one hour and 17 minutes to be exact
Are you ready?
Are you ready we go
We go we go we have prayed we have prayed I have faith I have faith
Anyone doing a prayer outside?
Okay, we've got a few prayers going off. Let's go. Oh, I'm traversing the midst of it awkwardly, but uh traversed it
Nonetheless through the heck of myself. Oh, they're there. I'm blind. I'm sorry
Oh, I should dodge that. Oh my god
Okay, let's try
What am I doing? Poison? Is she already poisoned or is that that's not rude to say
Oh
I saw that bleed
Okay
She's taking tick damage. Okay. She's got her to say so what I'll go back to poison. Can she have both?
Dodge and dodge. I did that far too early
Can I give her poison and to say is there any way to see it both?
No, they don't stack
Oh, what a silly game right hold the line. Hold the line reflins. You can do it. Hold on. Hold on mommy
Just use the swap right, okay
Phase two already
How does that miss she moved like a friend in here that bleed
Make sure you have to go health if she uses her ultimate
Oh my god, the rot's taking her down. No
The rot is ticking down. Oh shit. I'm not feeling well. Oh, no, I should have just jumped
I think I'll make it. I'm okay. I'm okay. We're all okay. We're all alive. Heal up. Heal up. Take your time
She's on me. Take your time
Take your time
Heal up what what you can
Let's go good, okay
Too cocky, no
Okay, I'm just missing everything that's fine. I didn't want to hit her anyway
I didn't want to hit her anyway
Okay, uh dodge wait dodge. Okay
Sorry, I have to like instruct myself out loud because like
The like scared part of my brain is like dodge dodge dodge and it's like no wait
Refling
What you did it?
Oh my god, I didn't know if we had that or not
Oh my god, no. Oh my god, you did it
He freaking did it. Oh my god. I knew you could do it. I knew you could do it. You did fantastic
Okay, I can do one level. Wait, why is this stuff yellow?
Yeah
Because of what I've got a weapon
I
Think this endurance really put my maximum equipment up. I don't really think there's anything else I can do
Are you squiddin me right now?
Thank you for the super job. I didn't even why are you why are you still bringing me money as a person in the corner?
Like
Thank you for the five disciple of aziria
Ripped to fallen it's because of the sacred blessing. How did you get to that level?
uh
A refling
many refling
I did a few favors under the table and reflings gave me all of these xp grants
Oh, yeah
The boss that boss sent me seven hours to be on my I refuse to change my build honestly that stubbornness is good
I can't wait to break it
Okay, I'll just do
I don't think dexterity even changes anything for me. This is
All right, I don't I assume because it's a boss fight. I can't summon. Yeah, okay. I can't summon you to our boss area
Where are we hidden?
The story
Scardus altus
Okay
That scary fire guy's ahead. I'm very curious
Is there something to talk to?
Hello again, hi, did you meet my compatriot something quite the congregation
From places as far and wide as you can imagine
Doubtless it have all come to blows at first glance. Uh-huh. Were it not for the charm kindly micula put upon us
This is what allows us to serve together the work of a living god
This is alive
I'm very confused. I mean it's not too bad
Me the best win
The tarnished
Can I just execute this man right now?
I won't do it, but
Right, this is for adventuring. So this isn't I'll add it to the adventure list
Barret has an adventure
And then
Stronger both of you have an adventure with me
Okay, but that doesn't count
And then enemy we fling
They're wrongly you haven't been adventuring so you're in the adventure can't you go
Some of the outfits are pure drip. He's just stricken by grief
What to be a racist towards me?
I'm all
I'm getting people cosy and I put my blanket over me. I'm getting cuddly. What do we
I know weapons if I go cuddly. What do we with my wee friends? Oh, yeah
Oh
Let us see
Witch Prattling. Oh, we never got the morning one
Does anyone know the location of the morning prattle thing? I think we need to go get the morning one
Uh
We'll carry you to bed and tuck you in it's found in a dungeon, but you can't remember which one come uh come we
Right, we'll explore and then whoever posts where the prattle and morning thing is we'll go to it
Okay, let's head off. I don't know where we're going. We're going on in this or I'm about to follow you
Are we just going on an adventure? I don't know
No, go a little bit
Uh
When
What one do you want again the one that whimpers, but I think it's maybe like crying coconut
But it sounds like a whimper. It sounds like oh
Did I tell you this fun fact, you know in shivy's lore we're the man that's getting whipped. That's me
It's my voice
Uh, but toned down
Where are you going rifling get down from there? That's dangerous. You're not supposed to play
You're not supposed to play in the air rifling. Where are you going?
rifling come back
Rifling
Rifling come back
Where are you?
Oh, shit. I've got my weapon tree out. Hold on
Hold on and get my speed to a pulp. Hold on. I have enough eggs to tank this thing
Wow, hold on
Put the weapon on
No, but I can't put it on it won't let me put it on
Oh my god, I'm so sorry. Oh my god. I'm so sorry. Hold on everyone. Let me swap weapon right now. I don't know why
Hold on
Fucking dogs. Sorry. I'm needing this rifling to save me. I can't swap right now
Me bringing the fucking trouble to to the rifling. Holy crap. I'm so sorry
Why isn't it letting me take it out? Is it because I'm in combat?
E fucking hell. How hard is that game? Gee
Oh, are you okay? No, hold on
Okay, these guys have no poise these guys have no poise so you can just break them
Stuck in a cross literally am I going crazy? I'm pretty sure I selected a to swap and I didn't
Oh, hello
church of the crusade
Crusade is such a satisfying word crusade. It's just a man. Can I burn?
Mmm. Call of mine
Why is it always done? It's not
Okay, we've got some more flesh of
The thingy mob over do you need to heal? I don't know if you have any hope though. Oh, there's another thing here
Got a rune art
I can hear something
Oh, it's you you're healing or something. You have an aura about you
Crusading intensifies. Oh, okay, let's perch
We get healed by the magical storm
We should grab some more
Wait, the tiger has a little nose print. Look, he has a little symbol on his nose
Oh
Okay, are we ready? No, we're not
I can't be just can drop a healing stone
My beloved he says thank you. You're welcome. I think my beloved can also be you're welcome
Like the pleasure is all mine. Whoa. That was like a church. That's actually not decimated up there
How curious how rare
Hmm
Yes, the boys. Oh no, they're ready to attack
I'm so mad
This is getting I'm needing
Anything to bring the guards the guards are to be rang
How are the
How are the walking NPCs?
Other than the stalking
fucking attack
Jeez Louise
The walking NPCs are giving me such a tough time, right? We're avoiding everything
Especially that bam on the horse. Don't go near that bam on the horse. I'm not attacking them
Don't go near him. I'm looking sweat by him
Let's go around
I didn't have enough. I didn't have enough nothing for the church. Look like a school
Oh, is it like a magic school again? Like a rail car. Yeah
I don't even know what we're going to do against that fire giant. He's terrifying. Oh, we have a map
Oh piece candy
The map
I'm not yawning. I'm not yawning. What do you mean? I was perfectly well rested
Although this is wait, did you activate him?
He activated him
Oh, he's ready to fight
I think can we avoid him?
Hold me refling. I'm scared
Okay, let's just keep running past. How about that? Wait, where did he come from? I'm just running. Bye. Bye. I'm running
I don't care. Don't look back. Just keep going refling. Just keep going. Don't turn back. Follow the purple refling
Follow the purple light. You can do it. You can do it. We don't need to fight
Not that we can't anyway. I suck
Oh god, they're everywhere
Uh
That big fire guys are gonna aggro to us, right? Surely surely he's an aggro dude
Surely that big massive guy that I'm totally have no weaponry or armor for
Is going to turn around and like spit flame all over. Surely not
Oh
We don't see the enemies and the enemies don't see us. We keep our eyes close
We do not see we do not see we are safe. We are not overrun at all
Oh
Somewhere a great ruin has broken and so too has a powerful charm
What does that mean so
What does that mean
That charm has broken
It's new so there's literally no wiki stuff. Oh
Shadow keep
And there's a space
And you're gonna love oh, there's like a temple of dibella
Okay, is our refling here
Oh, no, is there no refling here at all? Wow the map goes so much bigger
Whoa, there's the tree
That looks like a looky look we can go to the bottom right and we can go top left
We have kind of discovered the diagonal of this map
Is there no
You can talk with the npcs at the grace to understand what's happening. Don't go. Are you saying don't go?
I
Don't know what that means. I mean don't go
Should I wait for a refling to come help?
Tea bag if that means wait for a refling to come help
Please no, don't go wait for another refling
Please help
Uh, is there any refling at all at this area?
Checking in from work. How's it going? We progress
We're waiting on another refling to spawn but I think we might have a bit of a problem on our hands
Where we're all coming at the same bit. I'm at shadow keep main gate
Oh, here we go. Everything's are helping. Is there anyone who's not had a chance to be in?
Oh, pineapple. You were the one that was healing me and then it went terribly wrong because you were healing me
And I did hardly any damage. We'll give you a shot again
Um, don't did you ink on me? Are you inking me right now?
Are you telling me a couple inch of this fish?
Are you telling me
Give me like 10 minutes to get home. I'ma carry you right through that shit
Okay, trumpet pineapple, holy holy architect. Thank you
Okay, uh, can I go in now?
Am I allowed to go in now?
Oh, no, he's committing some
It doesn't have to be this way refling you can just use the pearl finger. It doesn't have to be so dramatic
You're so dramatic refling
Oh
Oh, no, this can't be
Literally why why you just had to use the pearl finger. Oh, I got some runes for that even though I didn't do anything
Infinite rune glitch just get reflings to come in all the same and then commit Senpai
Okay, are we ready? Are we steady? I'm not sure you guys seem to be stuck behind the door
It's a rhino
Okay, big launch
Um, I'm trying to analyze the attack pattern. Can I melee him is the question
I'm learning. I'm learning. I got healed. I'm trying to learn
I'm out of stamina
Oh
Oh, no, he just like
He's a porcupine rhino dog
He's a porcupine. Yeah that fucking crossbow. Really no, I don't even want to touch him
I might have ammo. Hold on. Hold on. I'm very small brain
Ah put me down put me down
Oh
No, this can't be
I don't do even I don't even know if we have we can do this
I
Colossal porcupine. Is that his name half porcupine half rhino half dug
It's a porcupine. It's head to Potomac
It's not only a hip or a golden missile. Wow
Hmm
Mm-hmm
Um not very confident
But you know what sometimes it's okay to say you're not confident
Right. No, I'm you didn't get a chance to do that one
I did just have you in
You guys really are quite far ahead if you're able to help me this far into the dlc
You haven't finished is anyone finished the dlc?
I
Don't know if you set the grace. You can pull more balls out of my storage
Because people gave you too many other in store. Actually his name is golden has a lot of potomace, but porcupine otomace is an interesting one
I had fun warning strontia that I'm going boss. Are you ready?
My lady. My sir. Mmm. My sir. Mmm. Are you ready?
Are you stay? I'm gonna wait till like oh, he's dropping me. So
Oh
Wait, what how is that crossbow better than a plus nine?
Huh or is it because it's spread that's why
Curious, okay
Accusations aren't true. Are you ready? Are you steady?
Okay, can I get a free hit and at the start let's find out
Instantly
Holy crap because he's such a long boy as well. He can go so far
I
Don't know right. We'll do poison damage first
Although he already looks like he's infected. So I see poisoning just to be honest
Oh my gosh. I'm not even successfully dodging a single thing from him
Oh
I don't
Oh, that's so beautiful. So that part isn't that was my freaking final column. I'm gonna heal or I'm down and out
Okay, we're fine. We're fine. I'm gonna take my wonders for last because she probably actually did something with it
I still don't know what it actually does
Okay, I don't think you take poison damage
I've been whacking them for a bit now
I like the warning that he's charging up. I don't like that
Oh
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I think we might have it. Oh, I say as the reefling gets chopped to pieces
Okay, okay
Please help is the closest part I could find
This area is torture. Do we need to go by?
We got 50 percent on the second attempt
I'll see if we can get below 75 percent
Then I think we might be on to something who's not had a thrombler. You've not had a shot on this ball
About f in time. You've not had a shot on this ball side there
Is this what this is
Uh, help me so to only if I had a friend of her buddy
Friends oh
That was so loud for no reason
Okay, one managed to make it in hopefully no DC. I guess it was easy
Oh, it's about time. I thought it was about f in time
Is that my swear word?
I didn't know Sam was a swear word. Okay kiss and kiss
Are you ready?
Are you starting?
Adrenaline is pumping
Killing machine
Over can you click on to the enemy for once?
We just go for bleeds
I feel like that man did not get any
I'll do bleeds
The poison I think he's poisoned in this one because of his he's already got like something going on on his wee back
Why is he going for me?
Oh
I
Why are you going for me? I'm literally doing the weakest damage on you. I'm not being funny
I literally what a hundred pair of freaking bull relaxed. I'm really not doing that much here. Oh some go crisp
Oh that bleeds that was a bleed
Okay
Less than 50. Uh, I'm ready to just go all in on bleep. Holy crap
This is insane. I think everyone just needs to spec bleep
Uh, I don't want to fuck up not to be honest
I
I'm trying
If I could get a bleed oh that would be grand
Don't get bored refling don't get bored
I
Need to fill hell because if he does that really fully into me
I'm fucking corner I fucking can't get out I can't get out I fast thankfully I'm allowed to get out
Oh
Too early far too early
I'm low. I'm low on fucking heels. I've got one more health. I just need to pop it if he does that really fully into me
I'm gone
No, I rolled into his freaking gob
Okay, we 100% have this look at that. That's less than 10%
100% have it
I literally needed one more bleed to pop off that would have been a
Lesson enemy is immune to bleed like bleed is super
Powerful it's what made the black tank wife is that the powerful woman
I
We can 100% do it. People just these same things over there much of misinformation. Oh about the game
Set you've not had a shot
Uh
Zanfil airborne walk I've never
You're definitely new
How are you naked and in the dlc section?
Whoever about about time is insane
You want me to use uh, I just don't want to waste on long bullets
Maybe if I just use it on the normal
Right, I'll help I'll use it on normal
Oh
I'll try the spread on them. I'm not gonna have any effect. Oh
Special delivery. What do you need to make?
I should maybe think about making myself. I forgot to get more
Uh, are we ready?
Oh, we got the health as well ready
Okay, okay, if you hold your nerve you can actually get over that. It's just a bit nerve-racking seeing the open mouth of your enemy
I only do 300
Uh
There's a lot going on right now
There's a lot going on right now. Oh someone got uh, oh my
Honest mistake
Okay, holy what? Oh no one's down. Every fling is down
I'm freaking out. Oh my god. I'm out of ammo. I'm useless
Fucking get on send it send it send it
Oh my god bleed please
Please oh my god replaying
Holy you must what how did you do that? Did you just shrug?
What these abilities you must have finished the dlc this is all new
Holy moan
This guy's I think he's finished the dlc at this rate
Whoa
Like bro, wait, can I just grab you guys from over here?
Yeah, I can okay. Okay exploring time
Uh, phoenix, did you get to explore with me yet? No you didn't
Okay, we're exploring
Okay, whoever said you won't be shuggling after killing that girl. They actually weren't kidding
Oh, no if the summons are working
Oh, no the summons are broken
Hydration check get some water on you from any bleeding heart is there in t-minus 4.40 50 minutes
Hmm
I think that we should make time out. Can you take any more for less?
Uh, I can't even interact I've like pinged out
We have broken the server the unable to summon. Okay. I'll take any more for this because you didn't finish the game
I don't know why sometimes this sometimes that sometimes are maybe good sometimes or maybe she uh, you have not explored with me
If your connection will allow it
Maybe I should wait until you guys get in the lobby and write your name down because this entire sheet just has so much like unwritten
Alessandro, you did explore with me pineapple. Did you explore with me at all? I don't think you've explored with me at all pineapple
Oh
Is there enemy refling any enemies got a lot of enemies
I've got into the boss room
Go into the boss room and take a right the door was broke. The door's closed
Phil's closed
Unless I mean not right. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. I got it. I got it. Any enemy refling
Any
arrivals
Oh, let me get my weapon out actually. I do not want to use a crossbow unless I'm actually in a fight like that
There is an enemy refling is it gonna be you've not explored with me and you have like for longest name ever
I'm excited to play um
The binding of eyes like I've been starting to plan my shorter streams when my dad gets here
He gave me the dates of him getting here
And I have to admit it is so weird of the concept of like cutting up a game
Like if a game is eight hours or less
It's really bizarre
Wait what
Huh
Did I miss something wait are we doing this fight again?
Did I miss something
Oh reflin, I'm so sorry invader refli- wait what? Oh, it's a new load area. I've just got you guys in for nothing
I'm so sorry. I'll take all your names off the list. That doesn't count
I'm so sorry reflin. I had no idea. I apologize
Hey, I'm gonna do Eden runs. Why why cruel wall? I know
I left it with a little present
Where did I miss it?
You left me a little doofy you left me a bomb. Oh no, Eden. Sorry. It's not a bomb
Should I
Should I pop them? I think I'll pop everything
And then I'll upgrade what I can't oh my god
What's this one do
Bruh
Is that everything you guys really oh my god, don't mind if I do
Don't mind the bad news
For you you're you're seen
Oh
Just a couple just a few weird more runes. Oh nothing more
I'm like how on earth are you that level after like less than 48 hours? No less than 24 hours of game time
Actually like actual in game time
I think the system tells you
Yeah, fond of law 15 hours in game time level 193 feels good man
Um, right, what was that a new one?
Yeah, you
Just a small little five million
Okay, that's everything I can do right now. Let's see what we can do with it. Um
Is there a point and putting anything
Uh, it is soft cap. That's like for what to gain 99
HP
and
fire
Resistance up to twit is terrible. That's maybe worth it
Um, the cap is 80
Check the shadow tree blessing as well like I was just gonna shove it all into endurance, to be honest
Um
Dexterity for crossbow hits
Okay
I didn't know the crossbow works like that. There's 40 and 50 and
more few more
I mean the HP actually gives me a weaver resistance
immunity and robust
Not to be confused with
I I do apologize if I'm like completely wasting souls and stuff
I'm sorry. I just like playing the game with you. Is that so hard? I don't want the super amazing
freaking thing
I want I want to just do
Arcane is best for bleeding stats though though our trap is a even self just like so you get the ammunition
Obviously, please you're here. How are you here?
Uh, okay, hold on
Uh, well, let's see if I can get those original ones like this
I've got your name on the explore list. Did I actually see you?
Where are you?
Right, wait, and you get the good ones in first. Mage hasn't explored with me
Pineapple didn't explore and then enemy we've been
And then okay, okay
Oh
Oh my god, but right now it's just getting more cryptic and as it tangles on oh wait someone didn't come in
Right pineapple did make it and
We're doing it. Thank you
I don't think it's someone
I was the one that has to leave
Oh, did you wait? I've not scored it your name. Hold on
score out
Are you don't turn into a candlestick stop it stop being a role-playing as a candlestick right now
You want to know?
Actually, I watched a really cursed video about candle someone using a candle. No, don't you become a candlestick as well
Right, what's he saying to us?
He says no such a thing is utterly inconceivable
We have not been abandoned
Mithmer is the son of queen mariaq. Her grace would never abandon her own flesh and blood
You know the guy that one shots that boss
Is he like a big soul player?
I was gonna say are they just gonna leave us alone?
Right don't fall off the map for these bamboos. Careful enemy replaying. We don't want to actually whack you
Wait whoa, what you flipped my camera around
You have a nice you just moved there. What way? Oh, he's got torch. He knows to go this way
Wait, there's a little fight. Wait. There's a fight going on. We must save refling
Refling it's okay
I'll save you. I'll save you
There see look all that work is
Wait, you're going up. We went up or are we doing that?
I mean we can always explore it's not like we're in a major rush
I mean I
Oh penumbra, thank you for the host
It
That redirect because we're on youtube.com
Thank you for the redirect. I'm so sorry to anyone who's interested in vtuber news. I have no vtuber news to offer you
um, uh, hello
We do an 80 20 split. There's some vtuber news for you other vtuber news. Um, um
quick vtuber news
Uh, all of veal are officially monetized. Woohoo. Yay veal are news. Let's go
What do you mean you are the vtuber news?
I provide the news by just telling everyone like this is actually how it works to operate a vtuber agency behind the scenes
omegalo
Hey, we love vtuber news. Wow, these ones guys are tiny
Oh, they're taking a wallop in and they're poised. They're not actually not getting broken that badly
No, no, she's the vtuber news
Now behave behave. Hello. Thank you for the redirect
I am strony cuttles. Um, I am the hypnotic cuttlefish of vealor and I also cannot stop yapping about any and all plans about vealor
Because I am a wee bit of the spring solar just a slight bit of it. But thankfully
All my jobs are
Getting less and less and I'm just gonna be a full-time streamer that gets to do the fun stuff
Um, and I don't have to plan a billion different things
I love it. I love losing my job and just getting one job and keeping it. You're the entire news
What in one episode
I did a veal or exposing stream which was really fun because I think people were like
How is it possible? And I got to like be like, um
Actually the reason why any of this is even possible
Is because uh, there's no
Fucking stop from the company. It's self-owned. It's been seated. There's no debt and also, uh, corporate grief bad
Like, um, actually like I was so into that line
Is this a back short door a shortcut door?
To the right. I think this might have been the shortcut door
Okay, that way wait
Huh?
I mean
Right, we've unlocked the shortcut. It must just be two different sections. We unlock the shortcut. It's fine. We're fine
Strongly going over through capitalism using her agency. Wait, what do you mean that?
That 60 percent of the housing market is owned by one company. What if we
What if we hear me out? What hear me out. Hear me out. Hear me out. Bear with me. Bear with me. I see he's in the room
What if we do that?
But then we don't we don't do the bad thing and artificially raise prices so people can actually just exist
Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. We can't be saying these things out live. We're gonna get in trouble
What if we become the billion dollar company?
so we
Can
You know make sure the world doesn't artificially inflate because it's not real inflation
That's the kicker. But anyway enough of the tinfoil hat. We need to we need to be respectful. We're all about the respect
She came from the scottish vlog
What do you mean this person is for the people? It reaches
months
Oh, what's going on here? Oh, oh no poison spores poison spores
Careful poison. Oh gosh, there's so many rooms here
What is this?
Wait, that looks like the antelope I killed in my mother life
Wait a minute let her speak
Did you know that the ceo fatso is a person did you know that the average person has a name in it? I stop replaying
stop
I'm gonna have views gone too far at the rate. I do my rent honestly
You don't need to protect the library from us. We're good. We are good explorers
We're not bad
Um
What other good feature bring you?
Yumi plus has five members. But Amy recently debuted
This is like feel good stuff
And she's already broke a thousand subscribers, which is fantastic
Uh, I think all of you me plus are actually very
If I'm not mistaken, all of you me plus are just about to break a thousand subscribers, which is great news
Uh, I'm really happy for them. I'm so glad
They're very hard-working beings. Please don't attack me. Please don't attack me
They're ow ow ow
ow
Stop it. Am I I don't think I have much magic
I see something it's glowing. It's healing. That's glowing
How dangerous is this area? It's like never ending my goodness
Every corner has like something new
What do you mean this DLC is actually worth it and it's like a whole new expansion and not just a cash grab
Hold on a minute. Did software? No form soft some for
Oh, I don't know what the name of the company is. I forget every time
Did they actually
Did they actually that's friendly, right?
They actually
Stranny, what's your secret to being so perfect? What is in your honor?
Nothing I'll humble you like working in a care home as well or working
On a public sector job. I see is my voice is about to start cracking. Oh
Uh
Oh, oh, okay. No, no, it's fine. The fire didn't do too much
Oh, no, they have high points. Oh, really? No, really? No
Oh
Don't leave it up to me. I'ma wait for I'm gonna suck at this game
I'm out of stamina. I'm out of stamina. I'm out of stamina
I'm out of stamina. I'm out of stamina. I'm out of stamina. I'm out of stamina. Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, oh
Wait, no, no, no, no, no
Uh, is there a load station nearby enemy refling?
I mean, is there? Show me
Show me we need to call in reinforcements now. I ain't gonna survive
Down here
What are you doing? You're being
Oh refling you give me such heart attack when you do that
Gentle gentle gentle easy
Oh
I'm gonna run back and call in reinforcements. Uh
I should have come back up refling what I do. Did I go back up? Wait, can I climb this?
Wait, I can just climb this. Hold on. Hold on refling. Oh, it's not lost. Oh, it's not lost. I'm just pepega
Wait, oh, no, maybe all is lost. Hold on
Oh, that scared me. Oh, that scared me
Oh
Reflings reflings. Oh, where's the crypt? Not this way is back this way. Sorry. There's a bad man
There's a bad man and he gave me such a scare. Oh, did you see the way he was lurking?
Oh, no, I can't handle that getting right now. Oh my god
Oh my god, I can't handle that
Oh
Did you see the way that guy was lurking?
Sorry, I'm trying to do the math in my head who's being here and who's not
Oh my god, did you see how menacing that was when he was coming around the corner like yeah, I'm coming to get you
I know you're alone
Oh my god
For from soft. Okay. It's called from soft. That made it. He was ropling as a refling lurker
That was horrifying. Wait, hold on. We item over here. Don't mind if I do the tv
Fireproof pickle. Okay. We're ready to go again. There is a red guy lurking around
I don't know where he is, but he's somewhere ready. It hurt you. Okay. Okay. We need to go all the way back, but that's okay
Uh, right. We went this way
I'll let you go first
Reflings so you can scout out if he's lurking
But he is there. Do not be filled. Reflings. There's a man in a red cloak and he's ready to take us
He's ready to take you from me and take us on just be careful. Okay
Careful
Easy
Is there I don't know where he is. He seems to have gone. Oh wait, and then we need to do the jump over here
Okay
Are we doing to the jump this time? Oh, are you just taking me back for safety?
Just trying to hold me going
Uh, oh that's not good
That's absolutely terrible. I just took a massive ball to the base doing that. Um, my apologies, what?
Oh, wait, I have a healing effect on me. I don't need to do that. You know what you'll be doing
Uh, like it literally gives you oh
There's like what the heck?
Oh
Wait, you need help
Ah, I missed
I missed but all that matters is I showed up. Okay. Sometimes all that matters is you show up and help
Uh, okay. We're going on the feet
Giant test
That squeak kills my soul. Well, because I'm so terrified to do anything without you
Literally me as soon as I saw that red guy don't even know where he is. He's probably lurking down there. Where is he?
I might be able to spot him from here
But actually lurking in the shadows can scare me
Uh, I think jump on that
He's like, did you just do what I think he did? I did the same. I did the same
He's like mother like refling
Okay, let's try that again. Let's try that again. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute
Oh, is everything gonna respawn now? I mean you start like attacking everything again
You tell me
Ah like mother like son
Like momay like refling
You were at the next grace. Why I'm dumb. Okay. Was that where the next grace was right over there?
I didn't even saw it. I was supposed to try to jump
Jump for joy
Okay, we have who is with us norm. Were you with us last time? Oh, can you remember?
Oh, we know I was supposed to bring in a good refling first
I'm so sorry if I double bring someone in my little brain's not working anymore
As you can see by my uh spectacular acrobatics and get myself erect on him. Wait
How are you supposed to get that item on his heat? It's on the bottom of his head
How are you supposed to get that item up there? Do you see it?
That's impossible
You'll get it later. Okay. Are you both healing me up? Okay, right? There's gonna be enemies ahead. Unfortunately. They've all reset, but
At least we know what okay something just went for me. I don't know
Okay, we're just absolutely gang violence, which is how I like it
So fireball fireball me
Wait, do the readers not actually
Or do the readers change their minds? Oh, wait, I think the readers don't hurt us
Okay
Why do I why my HP bar go off?
As if it all locks, I mean
Oh, there he is under the staircase. I think that was the guy that's
Hearing me
Friend now on every time we're using likes you die. We move a tentacle
What? That's like
Oh, this is the guy
Tell my reasons will you?
I don't think no no no no no this hoot
We actually I just I don't think we expected him to be so strong to follow
Do you want to do what are you sure are you doing? Is there is there a hidden item here?
Surely don't call me surely
Okay, right
Jump jump
Jump off just to know more
Just to know more
Oh, I'm getting his romp. What is it? What is it? Oh, it's to boost me to not take as much damage. Okay. I'm here for it
Okay, let's go
Oh, I miss that's okay. You don't have to hit everything
You miss 100% of the shots you don't take but it doesn't mean you're gonna hit 100% of the shots you take
That's not how probability works. Okay
Long as you try your best
I got a shadow militant iron man
Oh, there's missiles. Why are they at his feet?
Oh
There's three bands around the corner as well. I can see one looking at you. Oh my god
Okay, that was absolutely pathetic attempt, but it was an attempt on the left. The main thing
I need to watch how you guys did it
How do you do it? No
Did you just run and jump?
Run and big jump. Okay, and then you next run and big jump. Okay, run
Big jump. Okay
Shoo
What we got another thing to level up
Wow
We're doing it. We're doing it. We're getting mildly better at the game mildly better
Bro, that final boss had me watching for nine hours
When I was fighting the DLC boss after like 30 times I walked into the boss area and just started using the moon and cooking up
And you've given up. I've had enough mate
Uh, ain't that mean there's a boss ahead?
Where
Someone goes live someone goes right as we I am to the right that's why
I got stormhawk feathers
Okay
Let's see what's up
Fighting a bit of fighting mea
Fighting on a mage. Well, you know what we think about majors
Uh, please don't knock me off the map. That's my only request
Oh reflin. You're right in the middle of the fight darlin. Oh reflin. No
Oh reflin. You were right in the middle of the fight darlin
Oh, no, I didn't want you to perish
Smith what have we done? Forgive us refling
Forgive us. Wait, how do I
All right, hold on. There must be another one I can switch to that's like sad
The raptor why refling why we have forsaken you refling? No
I'm sorry
Okay, right. Okay. Okay, we get it. Okay, we get it. Geez. Take the same way don't you?
I'm sure there's not even hold them. I'm not even drill wheels and mobblies
Honestly sick. Well, if we're getting dated now by a non refling I can cry
Um, what is
What
Oh
Oh, oh you meant to do that holy crap. I was like what's what's hurting you?
Ah
No poise
No
Maley
No stamina perish
End of the corner of shame you bulls get shamed get shamed get shamed
God the smith's ones here are crazy
Label seven smithing
Get too bad these librarians don't really seem to mind this much. They're just chilling
What is this?
What the deer?
He died for the safety of my he shall be remembered as one of his mom's finest
for a reason
I'm sure if I get out you're being invaded. No, I'm going to be raging
Do we need to go for him? Are you sneaking up on a mage?
Wait, he's talking
He talks
No, something's talking I hear it
Oh, well
Something's talking that it said take it slow
By my lord
I ever make sense of his jumble. Are you?
What are you? Is there something here?
I
Think you need to pull a lever lever lever and in this room
Over here
I
Oh, they're above me. Okay, that means a lot more sense. I'm like
Okay
Yeah
When I have the chance so we're to go talk to a man
There is an mpc chilling at a grace that is very confused right now
Damn, I just got the inappropriate behavior detected glitch the whole area is literally I was like
Not gonna lie me hump and reef lens before fight. I was like, oh my god. They knew exactly what I'm doing the implication
they knew
Okay, it's fine the stairs are there the stairs are there
I'm nervous. I was like, where am I? I'm here. I'm here. I'm sorry. I just thought okay there. I can do it if I do it straight
I got a reverence for ash
Oh, we don't continue the thing. Sorry. Hey, where do we go now?
down
along
The reefland killing after
I'm sorry we wasn't moving
Are we
I'm looking at you. You have the torch. Wait. What are you doing? Are you teasing?
Down
Okay, down
Okay, we're doing down into the ray and
Yeah, there's nothing in here we killed our witch in here
Why do you get aggressive? You're just reading a book. My god. Why is everyone so mean to tarnished?
Like I could easily walk past you and none of that would have occurred
Just kind of help yourself
Heating on the tarnish like I'm lost
Oh, there you are
Who's an item here?
Who begins? Who begins?
Oh quite literally, uh pull the lever crunk
I
Something happened
Oh, I see it now
Whoa, this place is getting very big very tall very high up
Oh, why are you coming this way?
Oh, I was at the right bit
You guys want to go first? I was getting nervous. I'm gonna bump you off
Surely there's no enemies that will bump you off here
Like shoot you from afar type thing
You
Oh, I see him the enemy that's gonna bump us off
He's like no you're okay. All right, it can't be up there
Let's do that one
Who's the enemy above? We're not gonna get sniped by that little twat over there, aren't we?
Okay cleared that very thank you
By my
Okay, there's that looks scary don't really want to do that just yet wasn't here. This is safer. This looks safer in here
Are you guys fighting?
No, is there no safe safe point in here? Oh stop it. I'm just the tarnish making the way
Making my way through the library
Something something it's a library and I'm home then
Oh my god, they're going for it replays. I wasn't even in the fight with you
Hold on. I'm coming
Oh
Just trumpeted that man today
I didn't even need me. Okay. No. No alone
Alone
Yeah
Gravity strike
Why another one
We're gonna be so
Is it increases defense and attack or just defense?
Uh, this is like a boss fight if I've ever seen one I'm gonna be honest
I'm gonna be honest might need a break in a cup of tea if I've ever seen a boss fight. This is clearly one
Oh, let's see what we're up against
Let's see. I don't know what it is. What is it?
It's a crypt fight a crypt or small room medium
Oh my god, when your character makes the cutscene and it's actually you
Yeah
Mongrel intruder
That tarnished it seemed
Bossless
What's that truly lordship sanctioned in one so
Huh
Magista no my purpose stand if unchanged. Oh the elongated arms, please no
Those stripped of the grace of gold
Shall all meet death
Oh, no
In the embrace
Oh no, oh no
Um AOE fireball
Oh
Large melee strength
A reef fling
I do not
I'm not fucking after about it
Who stripped of the grace of gold channel death in the embrace of mess
Oh
Right are you guys looking about go make a cup of tea?
I think I'm gonna need a little cup of tea for this one. I'm not gonna lie
Okay for any beefland that wants to try and help me we're in the dark chamber entrance
I will make a new boss list because I don't know how long we're gonna be here. This is the snake boss
And I'll do I'll do a little bit of green to show that even though the snake was red. I'll make you
And then I'll put some red because he's actually
Sorry, just straight up doodling. I don't mind me. You should be making a cup of tea right now, but
Okay
I'll also start a boss list now whenever I do a boss list
It doesn't count as an adventure list it counts as a boss run russian
Ruchine for fuck me
Ruchine it's not boss in sorry that's scott's been applied to your name. I'm sorry if I pronounce your stuff terribly wrong
Uh our first duo ruchine and hyloid. I'm going to very quickly make a cup of tea. I highly recommend
Please get out. Please do stretch a zero for any bleeding heart watchers a zero is going up in five minutes
Um, please do give her a check. I can't remember what game she's playing
Um, I will make a cup of tea though. Okay, I don't know. I'm on course. I've got a dm
Oh
Yeah
Uh
Sorry, I zeroed with like are we supposed to play ads here in streams and I'm like, no
No, it ruins the viewer. She just doesn't know better, but um
And I said no interrupts the viewer experience far too much
And
We're learning out of here. We're getting better. She was doing leak rage as much
And no, and we are not going to play ads during spain some people like, you know, some agencies can I completely get it
It helps pay for yourself
I would rather value the viewer's experience now some don't get me wrong some folk are like, oh, I'm away for a pee
Like I'll go run and add but I feel like it's just too intrusive
Like I'd rather you sat and looked at my little snot bubble and my hypnotic hair than sit through like some ads
That you couldn't give less of a rat or something like I'm sorry the way the internet is going
It's like you can't even access an internet page other than wikipedia
Without being advertised to like you can't even search up mothers
I want a uh apple pie recipe without getting some fucking essay full of buzzwords to try and get higher up and like
So it's on to
I'd honestly consider dropping youtube if I couldn't block ads on it. Oh boy. Do I have an update for you?
Um, they're actually going to integrate ads into videos if that makes sense
So it will not register as an advertisement
It will register as a streamed part of the service of youtube when you click on a video
I don't know when that's gonna happen, but it has been announced
So I don't know what's going to be the result of that nonsense, but uh, yeah
I don't know. I don't know how they're going to do it because I
Unfortunately, I'm too uneducated and how like legal advertisements work and how
and how
People should have a right to not have advertisements shoved down their throat every two seconds
I don't know enough education about advertisements and all that jazz, but I very strongly feel like as
Give me the tinfoil hat before I borrow this cup of tea
If you go outside
Try and make a note of how many advertisements you see
Whether that has been normalized like having a car brand
Advertisement
You go shopping and you get a bag free advertisement the clothes you wear free advertisement because it's what'll be logo on it
like the bombardment of
Advertisement you experience when you go outside is batch and say hey look at your come look at your setup
Look at your computer right now
What do you see you can see the logo of your monitor right now?
Look on your keyboard. You can see the logo of your keyboard right now
Look at your mouse. You can see the logo of the mouse the heads that everything is like little
Little advertisements to just feel useless useless like I'm looking at my 3d. It's got a 3d. I'm looking at my focus right
It's got focus right on it. I'm looking at the bottom of the water. It's got like
um
Now don't get me wrong
I understand putting the company name or brand on something
But when you start to consider everything as an advertisement
Nothing is sacred
Nothing is sacred everything
Everything has their brand on it. Everything has their logo on it. There's like what who is it?
There's someone that just wear like plain white t-shirt knee tag on the back say and
But I all have to be done with that. This rant is sponsored by rage
I don't know what they pay you
I heard raid shadow legends like when streamers stream it
I don't know if they pay good for stream
Time to make our own flows the reefling way
exactly
Wait, it's all advertising always hasn't think of how normalized it is though. Imagine what 200 years back
the most advertisement you got
Have you I've actually got an
I've actually got an interest in old glass bottles
from like before before like
You know the big thing and like they it used to be like this is
um produced by
This family for this bottle type thing of medicine type thing and it was just fascinating because it wasn't like a faceless corporation
It was like no, this is a family lineage like, you know when a company's like, oh, let's celebrate
We've been in business for a hundred years. There's no soul to you. All you care about is the stock market
All you care about is your ceo getting his pockets fat or else he can get so type thing because of the way the system's set up
like it feels like no one
no
Entity that makes a stupendous amount of money has any soul to it
And like you shouldn't have any loyalty to like your workplace either
But who benefits when inflation goes up and you're forced to work or else you're homeless type thing who benefits?
And who suffers? Hmm. Yeah, again. That's the same. Sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry, right?
I'm gonna go make a cup of tea before I put a tinfoil hat on. I'm so sorry. I can't stop as soon as I get started
I genuinely can't stop right. I'm gonna make a cup of tea. Oh, I don't need the toilet running
I'm just making a cup of tea. I'll be a minute. I'll be a minute
You
Are you squidding me right now
Right, I'm not being funny
The kettle's still boiling so I can't make my tea yet
I'm currently having a fucking one-sided argument talking to myself looking at the kettle pointing my finger at the kettle being like
like
Because someone was like oh, she's a communist and I'm like actually communism can't work because a fucking greedy bastards in society
Always trying to get themselves up. I'm like fucking arguing with myself right now
I'm like no communism would work if there was nice members of society that all unanimously had the right thought process
It can't fucking work because it's some greedy fucking arse hat at the top
Like they can't even bloody help themselves
They can't help themselves trying to get a one-up trying to get better
So it can't work because there's members in society that do not belong in societies that create such utopian environments
Okay, it's not fucking possible. Okay. I'm actually going fucking mental on one, right?
So then what's the solution? Oh, strongy, strongy. Oh, you do this complain, but what's the solution?
I can't give you a solution. I'm not educated enough to give a solution
All I know is that I can point out the problems and make you aware of it to shift society's views
Even just slightly even if a few reeflings want to come along and just understand that if you're ever down and out in life
It's not your fault. The system is built up against you. I'm fucking raging. I'm
Anyway, right. I'm gonna make my cup of tea. I'll be back in a second. Just let you should know I'm having an argument with myself
You
Right, I'm back. I have tea and I have my raisins that opened up the other day because they're probably gonna get me
I have water
How did I do that? I have water inside my hoodie sleeve when I wash my hands. Oh my god, I'm gonna put the video off so I hold on
Oh, it's like freezing cold enough my sleeve
I don't know how I managed that. My elbow is no way. I have bruising on my arm. Why do I have bruising on my arm?
You can breathe as you see then take two
No more hoodie what's left? Oh, it's been put through frozen. I actually haven't even closed it yet
Oh, thank you. I poor in times to have to
You have to leave it
I'm not running anymore. I'm a well-adjusted streamer. I love society. I love how everything
works out in the end. Nope, it never does. Until the people rise up. I'm bruising a
whole lot. I have bruises on my arm, which I'm not used to. I get bruises on my leg when
I ride my bike because I always kick the back pedal off the back of my leg and all over
my knees I get bruises and stuff. Oh my controller's going to sleep. Wake up. I'm going to have
some reasons. It's my energy for this fight. I'm starting to feel like I love you so much.
Obviously. Yeah, do you like the thought of me waiting for a kettle to boil and pointing
at it and arguing with it? Like an absolute mad woman? How do you get rug bar in your
knees? Do you wear shorts? Yeah? Yes? Okay. I actually started arguing with the kettle
whilst I'm pulling the milk out of the fridge. Oh my god. I'm so used to my pedal hitting
my shin and all that. I'm doing the same thing. That's what I've always wanted. I love doing
abstract arguments in my head. Who dare opposes me? Fuck you. I'll slice you down. A snake
man mesmer? I know you're going to win this time. Oh yeah? Sorry, I'm just going to have
a few raisins and put it back in the fridge. I'm eating them, but I'm not hungry. I just
need a little bit more energy on. Mm-hmm. I thought it was normal to argue with your
kickwear. Oh no, reflingers get to me. Wait until you develop your nape personality disorder.
I'm going to put you through with him. You're going to run a mill. Oh, also, rain me. I let
you out. I'm swinging the door right now. I don't know if you can hear it, but I'm swinging
the door to get the fricking meat out of the room. It's just that piece of meat. It's
probably, I shouldn't actually hear that horn. How long until we remind you? An hour, 30 minutes?
I don't know. 30 minutes just to make sure I still have two cats. Right, who have we
gotten the line up to do? We have Ty Lord and we have Ruchin. I am going to shove on
my meat fucking crossbow. No, that's going to statically do much, but that ultimate from
the crossbow, if he stands still, honestly, might be the way to do it. Honestly. I'm going
to give it a try and see if I can rapid-fire ultimate on him. Are you guys ready? Are you
ready? Okay, you're moving closer. Edging. We're edging. We're edging. We're going. We're
going. He doesn't stand still. Fuck! Wait, what? Why is it not letting me do my ultimate?
I don't know. I don't know why it's not letting me do my ultimate. Is he poisoned already? No,
he can't be. Is that you guys? Oh my, oh my. Oh my gosh. I'm absolutely spamming trigger.
I'm so sorry if you can hear my little controller go off. You have to two-hand it. Wait, what?
I just put it away. Hold on. Wait, what am I doing? Sorry, am I having a stroke replant?
No. Oh my God. Is that even hit? I mean, it's alright. Does that work? God, that's too
easy. Hey, Lee. No. I mean, okay, reflings. Hold the four. Hold the four. Hold. I need
to put it back on this one. Yeah, I do. Okay, that's fine. Oh no, no, no, no, no, my refling.
Oh no. Oh no. I don't like this.
I don't like it. No, mother. Forgive me.
Darkness? He's going to darkness?
He's going to eat his own. No, okay, sorry. He's doing madness? Flame and madness?
I'm getting a bit nervous. I'm getting a bit shaky. I didn't like what I was doing.
Is he going to be a basilisk? Soon, tarnished.
Wilt thou be taken in the jaws of the abyssal serpent, Shorn of Light?
Refling.
Oh, I'm on show.
Oh, I can't even get a moment to respond.
Oh, my dear.
Why? Why are we supposed to defeat that?
Oh, my dear. Oh, my dear. Why are we supposed to defeat that?
I don't. That's the fun part you're doing. I think we're going to have to come back.
Oh, hope is lost when the French comes out. Literally the only time I can consistently
speak French is to ask why. Why am I forsaken? ASMR's littlest warrior versus a big snake.
This is the final boss of the DLC. He's a guy from the cover.
Grinding for runes? Are you joking? Grinding for runes? I'm level 210, boosted. And you want me
to go looking for weasels? The guy on the cover is never the final boss. There's some optional
stuff you can do right now. Oh, this isn't, I was going to say this can't be the final boss.
Everyone's like, oh, do you see massive, do you see massive? You need, you don't need runes,
you need the fragment. Okay, there is a scorpion rune I ignored because I couldn't spawn you guys
in. About two scared. I think I need to bring you back down. Okay, I need to bring you back
down these stairs because I missed one back here because I was too scared. But no, that
have you guys, I'm not scared anyway. Okay, do the gate before the lion. It's the one at the scorpion.
Okay, we're at seven for blessing and then the revered ash blessing. Okay, I need to take you
guys down the stairs here. This is just exploration. Okay, and come back briefly. God, you were quick
on that. You could also put more smithing stones in a way. I guess because I picked up so many,
right? I mean, mate, I feel like the crossbow's the only way that's keeping me alive. Azuridule
is most likely streaming live right now. I'm about to go best to look everyone
about damn time. Oh, you did amazing. Thank you for all the carries. We things we are at stage
front in the DLC. It's to the left stage front in front of the lion. You can't call up here.
Why do I hear boss music?
You can't summon after the boss back and summon an enemy. How am I supposed to get you guys to help me?
Who fucking wrote this book honestly? Right, wait, hold on. Okay, I guess we need to backtrack.
Refling, can I ask you to kindly leave pretty please? I'll take your name out because I didn't
realize. Thank you. No, no, you can't leave me. There's too many enemies. I need reflings to help me.
There's scorpions everywhere. I need to go, I need to go two thingies away and then the
refling is leaving. Are you sure? I'll trust your judgment, but if I die, it's up to you.
Okay, okay, okay. Thank you. Thank you. I need the reflings to help me through the scorpion pit.
Right, so do we, is it this one? The private altar. It may be the private altar.
We can go for the scream and coconut as well. Oh yeah, we need to do that. Yes, we'll do that.
Okay, I need to get this missing one by the scorpion.
Can I not fucking get anyone in? And all the castles doesn't work at all. All pieces. Right,
we're doing the coconut then. Where's the coconut? You can only do red tier though,
the boss of the Legacy Dungeon is dead. Whoa, that's so silly. I can't believe they saw my
gameplay from a year ago and then prevented it from happening again. Yeah, I already tried
all that. It's the white wall preventing from coming inside. Don't you dare leave Strone
alone. What is the name of the coconut? A pudimmi? No, that's all right.
That's me. Coconut is at the very bottom of the map. We're down here. We're here
at the fourth church of Mersa, the moaning one. Oh, there's a boss at the Black Gate. It's
walking like four or five. Actually, it's a few areas that we can travel. The moaning one is in
the DLC map. Wimpering coconut is in DLC map? No. No, this cannot be.
Say you're having a giggle. Oh, right. Okay, we're going to go to High Cross and we're going to take
a right down to whatever this is because there's something here, okay? So High Cross
and then we'll take a right down the path. We'll go north and then right. North and east.
Billy, game. Do you talk to me now? No, sorry. Hello. Hi. Did you feel it? But while my devotions
are chiming by my trust, I know it. I can wield my sword to call the undeserving,
those unfit to bask in tenderness. This is so cult, Prathen. Be careful. I should have thought of this
earlier. But me? I'm allowed to be your prophecy. Oh, prophecy. Prophecy.
What remedy do you presume us allies even now? Don't make an aspen is newly broken. I must profess
the spell mattered little. Uphold his covenant, make an ashell. Then America and vilest our tree,
both. And surely I contended I will be. No, I don't think so, bro. I think you're going to be upset.
There's only one exit. Okay, thank god I can get you guys in, right? Who's not being in?
You were my enemy. Well, I just reset the...
Wait, I can't... Oh, I can't be doing it. I'm doing this all in the wrong order,
so I can't tell if it's like being the last one that came in or not.
Hey, mage. And then you become my enemy, other refling.
Make sure you guys can actually connect first.
But not connect four in the classic. There's either an ash or fragment at the tip of the lake
directly north of the rims along the road. I'll put my ash on your tip.
Right. The north of the... like here?
At the loop? Or do you mean at this lake? I mean, that's...
Who made it in? Mage made it in. Mage Reef made it in. Jess made it in. And so did M.
Okay, why does that not...
Always get worried if it doesn't lay in automatically. Right, I'm trying to drink the thingy.
The road that goes south of your location.
I'm not smart enough to swallow your directions. Do you mean something like here?
I'm too much of a daft. Bam.
Okay. Okay, okay, okay, okay. Right, we're going to go north and then there's going to be a right
in the road, okay? Oh, wait. Oh, do you want me to follow you? Do you know what to do?
You have a light, so it means I follow you? If you don't, if you have a light on, I follow.
If you don't have a light on, I don't follow. Oh, wait. Oh, you also have it.
Okay, we're just going to explore in a bit. Oh, let me put my sword on again.
We're just going to be exploring because I...
I would like to. That's my sense. I'd like to explore. Go to the castle,
front side of the grace, and then head south on up to get the coconut.
This way is long and arduous. What do you mean? It's about the journey.
It's about the journey and how we did it. Where the heck are we going?
Never been here before. It's like another settlement. There's a naughty horse.
We're just ignoring everything, I think. Oh, there's two naughty horses.
Um...
Just trying to make sure... Well, I'd say we're going to be out of bounds, but we're not.
No such thing as bounds in this game.
I think you get... I'm just walking some enemies around the corner. I repeat,
I've just walking some enemies around the corner. Oh, dear lord.
I'm not going to make it. This fuck is the site. There's some enemies that have been activated.
Please look out, Reflings.
You don't talk much, do you?
Okay, we did it. We're now fucking out.
Holy crap. Like, frost magic? That was cool.
I can't wait for the next deal seats coming, and then I'll do a full magic spec. I've never done magic before.
Uh, who am I following?
Okay, light on. I follow. Hold on, let me try and finish my tea when it's warm.
No, you can keep going. I've just fought... I'm playing one handed, so you need to protect me. That's the only thing.
Pass is going to pass me, because...
I see a horse. Have we aggroed him? We have. Okay, you absolutely walloped him with that magic.
I can dodge. Don't worry, I can dodge. I'm dodging. I'm dodging.
Oh, we had a critical hit. Is it critical hit or critical kill?
Okay, where are we heading?
Are we healing?
You look like a bird. You look like a puppy. Honestly, ready to yank that for Jen too?
Like a wings on the arms? I'm here for it.
But would she have human hands? Oh, would she have human hands? Or would she have, like...
We count. Would she just have, like, the wing end? Because I wonder what she would do.
Okay, I'm all healed up. I'm all healed.
Harpy, Jen too. I'm open for a fucking harpy. I don't care. I'm so open for a harpy.
Like, proper harpy with wings, knee hands. I'm down for it. I'm so down.
I don't know if she's gonna be in Jen too. I see. The Jen too concept, like, not concept art,
but the concept of their appeal has been created, if that makes sense. You know my little cringe
paragraph on the exposing stream where I was like, the paragraph about me was like, I don't
understand, like, that's where the rest of the story started from. If it's like, I don't understand
guys, sorry, but there, I don't understand guys. If only there was some way to, like,
truly know them, like, that cringe bit has been done. And if all the designs come out good, then...
Hmm. Then, uh, there's, there's no room at the end for a harp, for, for patting Jen too,
for harping. Where are we going this way? I'm late. I'm taking your guys' lead. Do we know where
we're going? Are we all confused? If we're just, if we're just going and venturing, I was just gonna
follow this path down to wherever this is over here. Uh, so we would need to go like south. Oh no,
we've got a torch. We have a torch. Boys, we have our heading. Then landing, then landing. Underground.
Fancy underground.
Harpy girl, do it. Yeah. No hands, just little wings, I think so.
For me, it's a harpy. That'd be dumb.
I like how we all agree the torch carrier leads the way. It's like the best way to do it. Just be
like, right, whoever gets the torch knows exactly where they're taking me. Whoever doesn't, like,
if you don't have one, then we're all just kind of following. I hear a cry.
That poor guy. Is he in torture? Oh, well, you put him out of his misery, didn't you?
Reefling, no! What did you do? I got a shattered stone talisman. Wait, so we're not to go that way.
Reefling, no! Did you just launch yourself off the map?
Make the harpy to chop it fly. Um, we've got a new body tape and...
Well, I've asked for it.
Are you done here?
Whoa. Oh. Oh. You went out of bounds so the game didn't let you.
All my ankles.
Huh? None of us can go down. Oh, I'm gonna have to ask you to leave to get me down.
And yeah, there's a new body tape in Gen 2 that you ain't really at.
Wait, so, does other refling have to leave as well? I think so.
Okay, other refling, sorry, you're gonna have to leave too.
Hmm.
Sorry, other refling. The game's a bit funny like that. I slipped. Okay, now I can progress.
Any problem? Let's see.
I feel like human, whatever that is. I'm not touching a dime is not worth it. I need to think.
I hear it.
I hear something looking. I'm just trying to figure out where to go. Have fun. It's a long way down.
Well, I hope you're ready for a freaking marathon.
I'm just trying to see if I can find a save station before we go down.
Are you squidding me right now? I...
Doctor just diagnosed me with a terminal case of strontism. There's no cure,
but I was told watching your streams will ease the pain in the meantime.
So really, it all works out for me. Thank you, tiny, tiny. Thank you for the tip as well.
First off, east, then west.
Enemy ahead.
Enemy ahead. No enemy ahead.
You get appraised. You are good. No enemy ahead. Good. Thank you for telling me.
Yeah? You get appraised. Good. What do you say? Yes, good, good, good. Everyone be nice.
Good, good, good. Seek behind, so to speak.
It's so interesting how cryptic we have to be. Oh, you can raid Torrent here.
We have to be quiet. No cure, but why would we want one?
I don't need no cure. I should stay a flicker if I can't for sure.
Don't you dare.
Oh, the good.
I am there, so I actually don't want to go there. I want to drop down
and run away like mad, and then come back.
Okay, I can do this. I can...
Yeah, talk about the AI knowing where you are.
If you're coming over, poke me. They look really tall as well.
Okay. Okay, let's do it. Whoa, whoa, whoa. At least let me go. At least let me go.
At least let me go off. It wasn't even off. My Pintas. My Pintas. My Pintas has been jorking.
My Pintas is jorking. Oh, please, a safe site.
No. No safe site. No safe site. No safe site. Where is the safe site?
Oh my god, something's going to bite my ass. She's climbing up this. Oh my god.
Moeheart's pumping. I honestly can't play. This is literally a horror game without
Refling. I'm sorry. This is like, oh, why don't you play horror games? This is a horror game.
Whenever a Refling has to get like, freaking despawned out. Sorry, this is a horror game.
I can't do it on my own. I'm too scared. Oh, thank god. That's what I want to see, baby.
Bonnie Village. I mean, let's see, look at that Bonnie. It's a bit rundown if you ask me.
Poke me. Wait. I can't summon. I can't summon. I genuinely won't let me summon you.
Of course, I can't summon here. There must be a fucking boss fight or some fish.
There's gonna, there's a lot of death here. You? Is that why there's a lot of death? Because of you?
Yeah, you're like an actual NPC. You've been named into- The bridge is a lie. The bridge is a lie.
Why is the bridge a lie? Poke me. Okay, this bridge isn't a lie. Get me out here. I'm gone.
Then you have to ask me twice. I'm outie. I'm outie 5000 or whatever.
Not the clock fluff and the wood of the bridge. Then you have to ask me twice. I'm no hanging
a boot. I've got no business around these parts when I've no got my refunds with me. I've got
a knee business all. Please tell me. No, I don't want to go back in a cave. Please tell me. Please tell
me. Oh, please. Why would it be a cave? Because Torrent can't be in caves. Why would it be a cave?
Oh, for goodness' gravy. Oh, I'm sitting the fuck down so Scorpion's gonna come back. Like,
are they literally gonna come flying down that entrance? I see. We bam. No. Get away. Get away.
Let me sit down. Let me sit down. Let me reset them. Oh, the coconut's in here. Wait, I accidentally
came to the coconut cave? Honestly? Yeah.
Isn't that one footsteps right here and I keep thinking it's an enemy? Okay,
we flings. We're in a cave called Bonnie Goal. If you accidentally stumble upon it,
you do it by accidentally being in Bonnie Village and then panicking and going across the bridge.
And then go past the two scorpions and you get to go. Oh, the map's getting bigger.
Okay, I got one refling to come help me.
I put you on the explode. Oh, I heard a new one. Oh, wait, I didn't come. I got set. Oh,
no, I didn't come in there. I'm gonna sneeze. Mom, if you're gonna have to ask
you to fill, well, fill this. Is that? Wait, I think I'm gonna sneeze.
Oh, she can sleep in the garden where she can come in there and listen to me ramble
with a magazine. She cries and then she doesn't come in the room. Hold on.
Are you lying down? Are we doing the blessing even in the covering?
Ah.
I need that coconut. Wait, let me do my little ritual. Not the nine and a half second.
Got you whimpering. Got you quivering. Oh, did you get the pull back?
What? Okay, who's in? Set us in and slump and go in. And then pineapples and add...
Is that your, you know, your firework? And then pineapples and adversary.
It doesn't really count if you're an adversary.
Okay, let's just go exploring though. We're not gonna stop us exploring the world together again.
Oh, have I got my light on the hip? I do have my light on the hip. Okay, let's go. What is in here?
Danny across will bolt those guys so they like explode.
They look like exploders. Are you gonna blow off the map?
Holy moley. Whose item?
Is it too much whimpering? There's an item up there. Read message. If only I had a horse.
So I've just been through it. Well, Gimli's inside. That's all the mouse. I'll let her go
back outside again. Come push me to change the line. I spank you. Oh no, I'm sorry I let you
get hurt. Oh no, my replaying. Get away, you weirdo. Only I'm allowed to kiss them like that.
Sheesh. Open this door. I'll open this door. Oh, I got bolts though. Opening.
What? Oh my god, I'm getting freaking grabbed. Oh my god, they did some mad damage.
Oh, let me heal. Let me heal. I need to heal up a little bit. I need whimpering all through the cavern.
Hmm.
Oh, I was gonna say, I can hear that guy whimpering.
Here are whimpers. What's down here?
Hi!
Hey, you guys are taking me this way. I can't do anything about it.
I was gonna say, something's gonna drop. It just feels like a drop. Whoa, their health, they're so big.
Is there even a point of whack in these guys?
Will we just move on? Oh, sorry, replaying. Bruh, these guys are so strong. I need to put
bleed damage on my bleed, I think. I can't believe it. I need to level up. My weapons have been
proven right.
These things are weird looking. What are they called?
Will we just move on? This is terrible. Right, move on. This is taking too long. I give up.
I give up. They're taking too long. Oh, there's more of them. Right, turn back, turn back. Oh no!
Oh my god. Are you gonna make it? Are you alive? Hold on. Don't let them grab you. Whatever you do.
We must go back. Oh god, was it this way we came? I can't. I don't know. Oh, there's more. There's more.
Watch out, replaying. Watch out.
Uh, whoa, whoa, slow, slow, slow, slow, slow. What's this? Is this a boss fight?
Oh, we've lost our other two, refling. Hold on, we need them to come. There you are.
Oh, there's an item back there. Oh, that was the item.
Right, right, we're jumping down the waterfall, I think.
Ready, steady, uh, oh wait, am I not to go there? You're blocking me.
Is that a no? I don't know if it's no. If you jump down, I'll jump down.
All right, you moan one more time. I'm taking that coconut off you.
Hey, give me that coconut. I'll be careful of the things from the ceiling, I guess.
I don't know. I'm looking around. Okay, there's Alexander, Alexander's cousin.
Do we need to? Oh, they break quite easily. Low poise. There's a lot of Alexander's in this room right now.
There's a little baby Alexander's too.
Take that, you aggressive stinky.
Oh, we're just absolutely obliterating them, to be honest. Oh my god, I love when they have
little poise so I can just keep planting them. My people. What, the paw? You're a paw? Are you
trying to tell me you're a pottery paw? A living jar-tard. He's just really emotional around you.
I kind of get it though. Yeah, I kind of feel that. Okay, let me grab this. I lost Ash of War. I know what
that does. I don't.
Okay. Look in their mind. I see an I am here. I'm, oh, it's those guys. What do they do? Oh,
what does he do? Oh, there's a light come. There's a guy over there.
Is he, so he doesn't explode? He just runs at you? Oh, like, there he is there in that paw.
There's something in it. Well, if he's asleep, we'll leave him.
This is a tough day for a pension. It's a jar warrior without his jar.
Oh, that's what Alexander looks like on the In-Saint. That is strange. I won't kill him. He's not aggressive.
Oh, they torch her dumb in here. Oh, that's not very nice. He's locked up. The jar lord now gets
kind of gross. Yeah, there's like an actual human inside it. Wait, is that harvestable? It is.
Yeah. Oh, you got spanked as well. Okay. I think Alexander has a handsome, powerful warrior inside
him. Hey, strange. I don't get it. Oh, honestly, the lore goes so deep in Elden Ring, but it's like
so nice that they made the thing, like, it's just so nice to get involved in such a strange lore.
I would say it's probably the strangest lore I can wrap my, like, try to wrap my head around.
Dianne?
Uh, we'll take the next one. You guys go on with that one.
All right, are you ready to read every one?
Wait.
Uh...
Oh.
Okay. I was like, oh, we done messed up. We done...
I think there's three different types of jars, prisoners, warriors, and like an actual jar.
Hello.
Mr. Jar?
Is it the weight of jumping on it?
Huh? You want to jump down on it?
Maybe like, we as bones?
What?
Huh.
Let's try that again.
Oh, no! Reefling! I'm sorry! Okay, you need to do a big jump on it, uh, Raider Reefling, and then it'll let you on.
Oh, god, it goes so high when it does. I can't even see it when it goes that high.
I need to like, back off and like, look up.
Okay, Raider Reefling. Okay, it's coming back down.
Just do like, a big jump on it, and then your weight should carry it down. Oh, you're already on it!
Reefling?
Invader Reefling, did?
Did you mean that, or...
it forward jumped me?
I wonder if because your instance is an anime.
Oh!
What would be my version if I had a coconut? What would I make my coconut say?
If I could get one in-game?
I'd just look ink on me.
Ink for me, and everyone's like, what?
Wow! I'm beating them up! I'm beating them up!
Good, Reefling.
Like this?
Wait, we were gonna have to do this whole dungeon if we mess this up?
It's not exactly a fast dungeon to get back. Oh, there is. Sorry, here is. Okay, we're gonna be using this a lot.
Are you ready?
Are you steady? Do you need a kiss of courage?
Kiss of courage. Kiss of courage, right? I don't know what's behind us. Let's find out.
Okay, okay, okay.
Huh?
My auto lock doesn't auto lock onto the enemy.
I'm gonna start swinging. I'm gonna start swinging off in this bitch. I'm gonna start swinging! I'm swinging!
I'm doing it!
How the fuck can you see them?
Oh, I...
Am I going crazy or is it just my screen? I'm losing it. What the fuck?
Oh, I hit it! I actually got hit! Oh, I'm dead! I'm dead! Hold on. Sorry, I'm getting overzealous.
Uh, how are you guys doing this? Are you just guessing? They must be guessing.
They go in this... Okay, right. As long as I wasn't absolutely losing it, I was like,
how do you guys know where to swing? Because they were just hitting, hitting, hitting, constantly.
We did it! We did it! So, is there like any secret for them? Or is this just one of them bosses to do?
I remember some sister actually did a series where she kills all the Elden Ring bosses.
I'm curious if she'll do the DLC run as well. I don't know if she'll do it anytime soon, but
uh, that was the lamest boss, which I can even see her!
I'm gonna start swinging my sword around like, I can swing my sword, son! You cannot afford sword!
I can't call you the not Bonnie Village.
Did I need to kill that red NPC? Or was there something I could do?
Right, so that's where I've been. Let's run.
I do like how Torrent is so down. He's like, what? You want me to ride this house? Sure.
Like Torrent, you're actually like, listen to me so well.
Me keeping myself safe from enemies like, right. Oh, well, close enough. And of course they all get
activated. Wait, so can I not, is that bridge open for business or not?
Oh.
There we go. Right, now what? Oh, I'm still not over. Wait, what? Am I just taking a really obtuse
way to try and get Kroa? Wait, I was a little too right in there.
Oh, it's a dead snip.
Sick. There's something here. Oh, mother. Sweet mother, sweet mother, send your child
unto me. The sins of being worthy must be cut. I look like the bridge was broken. I might be
fucking right. See, the bridge isn't broken and I'm just blind. Why did I think it was broken?
I don't know. For some reason I thought the bridge was broken. No, it's not. Wait,
I think I might have just like completely had a, I don't know, loss of focus then because I
could have sworn this was like both. Silence, my brother. Hello. I can't tell you.
For pity's sake, your place is in the jar. Night, sainthood itself awaits you within.
For shamans like you, this is your lot, life where you accorded for this alone.
The whipping. I can whip my refunds.
Which, I'm curious. It's still not a save station. Is that one over there though?
Oh, cheeky little summoning. The jar was made for me. You're going in the jar.
Oh, my freaking every market stuff is on the way. I'm so excited. I can't wait.
I can wait. Safety, yes.
Heard her getting the draw refund. Is there anything I can do to level up the line?
No.
Uh, no. Okay. There is one thing important. Again, I can't summon.
I'm not going to fucking make it. I'm not going to make it. Actually, not going to make it unironically.
Freaking plain horror game simulator out here. Okay, there's an enemy there. That's fine.
Keep her going. Keep her going. Hey, thank you. Great. Selfish.
Okay, just follow the road and I will do a natural.
Why? Why did it make that noise? What was that noise? Am I going crazier? Did I just hear like a squeal?
No, I grew. No, I grew. No, I grew. No, I grew. No, I grew. Get up, Torrin. Get up right now.
Torrin, what are you doing? This is just a cliff. This cliff doesn't provide safety, Torrin.
Torrin, you lied to me. Torrin, please. No. Oh, well, you know that's good enough.
Good enough. Good enough. Get up by hell. Get up by hell.
And heal. And get up by hell.
Oh, Torrin. Oh, Torrin. Oh, Torrin. Oh, you came and you gave me a ride.
Away from the fire demon. Oh, Torrin. Oh, please tell me I can summon you here.
My heart can't take much more of this. Okay, sit down, sit down, sit down, sit down,
sit down, sit down, sit down, sit down, sit down, not the fire. No, do not heal.
Sit down at the fire. I can see them literally in the distance approaching. Everyone reset.
Everyone reset. Again, no fucking summon. Okay, if I take a left, I come to this area.
Um, sure. If I take a left in this arch, I come to a house. Surely I can spawn the
reeflings in a fucking house. Why are you blue? What is wrong with you? Oh, it's gravestones.
Okay. Oh, no, those are those guys that do those rapid succession attacks.
Oh my god, it's like an actual church.
Why did you please for the love of god do not spawn a boss like right now? Please just let me
get the grace. Please just let me get the grace. Please. Okay, I don't think anything's attacking me.
The church doesn't allow summon again. I'm not going to make it my heart.
Literally not going to make it right. So what's so important about this church if there's no enemies
here? Is it lower? Please be a lower church. So I don't actually have to think.
A resource gathering church?
I hear an enemy that's something.
Put marker on the black castello. This? No. Oh, this? I'm about to do like a massive underground
right turn to this.
To the left.
I'm not being fucking dumb. This thing down here, you want me to go down?
Me listening to the enemy get closer to me.
Don't go right. Just go down and take a left and then whatever happens in here happens.
I assume just go dead ahead then.
No reefing for five minutes and she's Parisian.
I can literally hear an enemy stalking this type of thing.
I'm just going to go north and let the wind take me.
What's patrolling the church is my question.
Is it a turtle? Did I get scared by a turtle?
Honestly, probably. Dog. Behold the dog.
Oh, it's frogs in the water.
Oh, something perished. I don't know what, but no problem there.
Wow. Is it a downward path and everything? Oh, is it that I'm supposed to take? Like all the
way down here and then get up to here? I'm so dumb.
I am so dumb.
Okay, don't go down there. Okay, just go straight ahead. I go north and let the path take me.
Take me path. Take me.
Oh, Tarn, you're such a brave boy.
You are. You are my noble goat.
Turn left once you hit a wall. Hard to hit the wall, I'm afraid.
I'm going for it. Like a wall down here? Take a lift.
This buddy looks like it.
I'm fucking terrified.
I'm not going to lie. I'm shitting myself.
The fact that I'm actually allowed to raid Torn and then inside. Oh, it's happening.
Oh, thank God. Oh, please, please let this be the one.
Oh, thank the maker. I can't do that anymore. It's called Church District Entrance.
God, I feel like I need to pee myself in fear.
Jace, Louise, what are we looking at? I'll show you guys come in.
There's crabs on the roof. It's flooded.
I hope it's all. Oh, refunds. I've never been happier to see you in a nightmare.
The peeler allegations. Literally, I feel like peeing in fear. I cannot handle this game alone.
It's too scary. Everything coming at me at once. I can't handle it.
Okay, I've got my rival in already.
Wait, you got this? Okay, and then any con? I don't know how many reeflings are here.
I feel like we're getting caught with the DLC with each other.
I gave you a 24-hour head start. I won't hear any allegations. I didn't give you guys help.
She says that she has like a billion rinses her name.
It's not gonna be scared about except scary monsters.
Wait, strongy, join the peeler allegations.
No, the ball is in Azur's court.
The ball is in Azur's court. I'm actually going to go for a tenkel very quickly.
The toilet's right there. I'm literally going to be like a millisecond.
Are you squidding me right now?
Okay, good news is both babies are still in.
The bad news is I'm gonna have to leave the door open because...
Are you squidding me right now?
I think, oh my god, I tinkled all these kidney stones. It's not looking good for me.
Oh no, did someone time out?
Anya, what happened? Thank you, Dimsey Dan, and look...
Logo Dogo, I assume. Sorry, here's not being in.
Alessandro, you've just joined this area. I haven't, yeah.
I think Pineapple had two moments ago.
How did you guys disconnect? Did I do something wrong?
Yeah, I don't know what's gonna happen if they're gonna start screaming when they come in the room,
but don't be surprised if you hear some background yelling.
The AFG don't know who or just can't keep getting away with it.
I feel bad. I feel like I'm still getting exchanged.
I'd rather like an exchange of money and being like, ah, I've spent my money on this valuable
thing. Like, I get something out of it, and it's just like, oh, I went for a pee and I had to mute.
Like, I didn't do anything. What? I guess it was a disconnection.
Uh, right, what were the... Right, we've got Torchbearer, which is the good news.
Okay, big boy jump.
Big boy jump.
Riefling. We didn't even get started.
Riefling.
The amount of time gravity is... It's probably the lag, honestly.
Wait, what did I do? Jump off this bit.
Wow. Okay, uh, ignore enemies, I guess? Oh, do you need help? Oh, they just, like,
asked the load. Okay, it's fine. Wow.
Are they gonna explode? I'm pushing boost.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow. What are you doing?
I guess I can just ignore them. Right, I'm ignoring them. Don't grab me when I walk past you.
Don't make myself clear. If enemies don't get me, they just want to... Oh, God, it's one of these guys.
No! Enough!
Fuck your poise, you're a shit poise, honestly.
As if that hit me.
I'll stand here to heal very much, so here, here, here.
I like those enemies over there are active on us, and they're like,
what do we do, man? I can't reach them.
If the cats aren't coming in the room, I'm actually gonna force them to.
Okay.
Right, you can eat inside by cat the same.
Wow.
He looks really good, don't you look, you're moving all the way out there.
He looks like all the way out there, my odd-eaten.
Wow.
And if we're again, if you're still in this room and I have no idea not to get up again, you're being
perished. Right, gentlemen, we have our heading. Anyone been to the cat combs yet? No.
Uh, right, okay, we just run. There's no jump needed here.
There.
Why did the ground start shaking? We're supposed to make that jump.
I was gonna say, are you sure, but...
There's an item here. Hey, is that summoning thing?
It is. Wait, you guys can summon ahead like this?
I thought it had to be a summoning, am I being gummy?
I didn't know I did that. I thought it had to be like...
Well, I don't know.
The trees are shattering in the water. Why? Environmental things?
Is there something in the water?
Oh, god, am I gonna make it?
Oh, okay. I don't know if the leafling can spawn. I don't think you timed out.
What is making that noise? Is it just ambience and it just sends a bit? Oh, god. Oh, okay.
As long as the boss is in defeat, I can get you guys in. Man, who made the DLC? They literally,
whoever made that decision, made the wrong choice.
Wait. Oh, no, I can't get you in.
There is a symbol right here.
No head ahead. I mean, I guess. There is a symbol right here and it's gone.
Need you to... You need another summon thing to summon the red...
Oh, I keep forgetting that. Sorry. I keep going like, oh, I don't want invaded, so I'll just get
the invader in first, but I keep bringing out races, basically.
Oh, no.
That looks right, right? Okay, that looks right. And then jump.
I don't even know how we did that. I'm gonna go on a...
A little bit full damage. What are you? Oh, yo, we have crustacean.
I like how the crabs don't bother you, really. Yeah, do we want...
It's over there. I don't know. There's a door over there.
Whoa. Oh, it's one of these bams. Fuck you. Shit poise. Take that. Yeah, you ain't got no poise.
Me, when the enemy has absolutely no poise, I can't stand a chance against my
two-handed blade.
Me, fuck. What was that?
Wow. I even had jambon to light the way.
Okay. I almost didn't jump. I'm gonna be honest. I got so distracted.
I'm helping him.
Actually, give me them hefty bones. I think we're going up.
Well, not in the water, since we can't swim, apparently.
Oh, a lever. Do you want me... Do you want to both go on it, and then I can push it?
And then you can see a woman's lifted you. I'm so strong, I can lift you both.
You really don't want to go on it? That was a long word.
Okay, I had to use all my strength for that one.
Causing.
A temple rises up from the water? Oh, no, a dream. Sorry, a dream.
Okay.
Just happened in dark circles one. Kind of a draining
This happened in Dark Souls 1, kind of a draining burn in the city.
I like when it changes the environment, I have to admit.
The astronomical environmental changes are so good.
Wow!
Okay, so we can get this now?
We can go like down there.
Ah, it's drained, it's drained, okay.
It's gonna be funny if there's like a weight limit to these, and by the time the third reflin hit it, I would break and we're all like, uh...
It's charged!
Okay, we now have a church.
Here, yeah.
Yippee! We're safe, we're safe, we did it, we did it!
I don't know if anyone has unlocked this place.
Oh wait, I can't open up my menu because of the reflin, the radar reflin, hold on.
Ah, it really not letting me open up the menu.
Dude, I'm trying to show them where we are.
On the map.
Stop thinking I'm fighting, I'm not.
Ah, it won't let me open up the map to tell you what church I'm at.
Oh, but there's someone here that made it.
Shining!
It's because of Jewelfinger.
Had to drain a town to fight a boss called the Four Kings, and Dragonsouls won.
On it, Dragonsouls, Dark Souls won.
Honestly, I wouldn't mind watching like a lore, like someone playing the game.
It's definitely one of those games where I can't watch it.
Eh, sorry, I can't play it, but I can watch it.
Okay, I have two reflings now, so we're good to go again.
Where are we going?
Let's check another one.
Any secrets, like big secrets or items that we've been needing?
I'd love to join, but I've got to prepare for work tomorrow.
I think this is the last spot I can access to the group.
Yes, no one, please don't worry.
If you need to rest, if you guys need to catch up on some stuff to do, please.
Uh, please do, sorry.
Please do your best to look after yourself and make sure you get your business sorted out.
Very good to get your business sorted out.
I will be streaming this tomorrow again.
I don't know how enjoyably we're going to make it.
Um, I'm starting to feel alright though, like I didn't feel the sickness I was earlier.
Oh, I don't know what the plan is with me.
Honestly, I'm falling apart.
The scenes and reforms you're just going to have to put me together again.
Fire Nate, you know, let's see what it says.
Um, what are you?
What are you?
Raises potency of kicking and stomping.
I mean, considering it being shared, that's the one point.
Wait, what did I just do?
Did I not put?
Is it like a, like anything?
Sorry, I think it's gone.
Sorry, it's called a regression.
If you pitch yourself past a safe limit, your body is all, this must be life or death.
You start feeling better, but I'm totally damaging your health.
Are you sure?
I mean, I'm just like fucking, oh no.
Does that mean there's a boss fight ahead?
Fight ahead if you're giving me a bolt?
Thank you very much though.
I might feel a little better.
We'll put you back together as many times as you need to.
We break each other beyond our limits, but we patch each other up after.
Oh my God, the medic reach of her?
When?
I guess in that door is locked down there.
Or is it a fake door?
Ooh!
Battlefield priest cookbook.
How many gems do you have?
You're going to make a blinding.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Are you giving my mummy a heart attack?
This is literally what gave my mum a heart attack age for it.
Okay, well, I have incredibly good news about my age.
I know V-triple rule is not to reveal your age, but I have fantastic news about my age.
Um, and...
Yeah, I...
Oh no, is everyone on? Is everyone on?
Okay, okay, good, huddle up, huddle up, refling.
I'm glad we're all close.
What happens in the elevator stays in the elevator.
Or the lift, you see the lift.
She's a hag, it's so over.
I am not actually a hag age.
Um, I am...
I'm not, so...
I assume hag age is fairy.
When he's thin, she's not over the...
I can't believe she's not to that 300,000.
I mean, Azura is four...
Is Azura four billion years old? I can't remember.
Azura is like above four billion years old or something like that.
Because I'm a cuttlefish, I'm technically as young as I started,
because cuttlefish only lasts two years normally.
I don't know what in captivation...
Focus me, I don't know what the word is, cuttlefish live to.
I have a feeling because you guys look after me,
I'll be better than two years than the average cuttlefish.
I'll last a bit longer than the average.
In captivity, oh that's a word.
Iris of Grace?
Oh, I like that one.
As long as the woman is older than me, I'm okay with that.
Yeah, you like older women?
Okay, hags are in, got it.
I'll keep that in mind for gentle.
Hags are in.
Ooh, look how the graces were discovering.
Marica's rune.
Oh my god, one of you guys gave me two of those.
Oh no.
Oh no, this can't be.
This looks like a boss fight.
Getting my kisses out.
Oh, they're stuck.
I've not activated the cutscene, they're stuck.
I don't want to go that far away without them.
Is it the heart?
It looks like a witch's heart on the tree.
Is that what it is?
Touch the bloodstain.
Oh no, I'm getting scared.
Is it the heart, right?
It's a plant.
I'm stuck on a freaking vine.
I saw a deadly sunflower.
Oh my god, an Astartian beach over wind.
Purely made in my image.
Did that do it?
Not only did 200...
Oh my...
Hold on, hold on, pause the tunes, pause the tunes.
Pause the fight lads.
I've not got my wee cross, so pause it.
Alright, I'm holding it, I'm holding it.
Okay, he holds in place though.
That's the good news.
Oh, I did a sick damage.
Oh, sick damage.
Oh, 29 damage.
Oh, I'm really showing him right now.
Oh, I'm showing him.
I'm showing him right now.
Don't you think I'm...
I have fire bolts, be honest.
Fire?
Yeah.
Why are you looking at me?
Don't look at me.
I'm just a little...
Wait, was that fire or am I being dumb?
Oh no, I've got a crossbow on, not a fricking...
How big is the AOE?
What is this?
What the heck?
We're against the Elden Lord again?
You're a sunflower, relax.
You cannot harness the fricking power of the sun.
Oh no, I can't hold it.
Oh, fricking sick.
Can I do poison damage on a flower?
Oh my god, that couldn't have gone any worse.
I'm sorry, that couldn't have gone any worse.
I couldn't have fucked that up harder if I tried.
I'm so sorry.
If you hit the head, it does 7 times damage on the sunflower.
I thought it was a witch's hat, honestly.
It looks like a witch's hat on the tree.
Fire and spiral shard.
Wait, fire?
Do I have a fire crossbow?
I have cold.
Would cold fuck up a plant?
I think cold should absolutely destroy a plant, to be honest.
Can plants take blood loss?
I think scarlet rot.
Scarlet rot and ice would really hurt a plant.
Are you guys here?
Okay, I see one here.
I'm just a fellow.
I'm just a girl in the world.
But yes, Azur Deli should be live still, question mark.
I don't know what I scooby-doo.
I told them.
I told them I said I'm playing with my refund.
Okay, set.
Unable to summon cooperator.
I didn't even accept.
Are we changing order or something?
Oh, there's quite a few of you guys at this stage.
Holy moly.
Thanos and set for the boss?
Wait, what boss is this?
The sunflower?
Who we got with this?
We've got...
Set and we've got...
My brain just blanked there.
Who did I just summon in?
Oh, Thanos.
Okay, that's why my brain blanked.
Oh my god.
There's no way you're fighting the sunflower Nikki.
Hi.
Are you actually fighting the sunflower Nikki?
I mean, I am not going to judge it as long as you're happy.
Okay, Azur is live.
There you go.
They need a holy moly coconut.
Okay, he comes out instantly now.
I wasn't even in the playable fucking battle zone.
Look at the distance.
That is just beyond reasonable.
Okay, the head is definitely taking damage though.
Okay, I don't know how I dodged that, but I'll take that.
Right, I can't dodge this because he's going to do something.
Okay, he's dropped target.
I'm just going to aim at the head so he's quite slow.
He lets me and he's quite exposed.
Although he does absolutely...
Oh, for fuck's sake, I tried to walk out of that.
Why me?
You have all the wraithlings on the hut.
I mean, it's probably better that he goes for me.
I'll just attack from afar.
I'll keep it up.
No, no, go for the head, the head, the head.
I don't miss though.
Don't waste...
Ah, fuck it, I'm going for the big one.
Hold on.
Did the mate do his thorns?
AoE thorns, possibly?
I don't know how he does it.
Or how he chooses?
Yeah, okay, that is what I don't know.
Again, I can't get out in time.
Holy crap, the AoE.
There's so much distance on it.
I'm too busy trying to recover from the fey in order to fucking get his arse.
I will say I like that his thorns do bleed damage.
I like that detail.
Oh, no.
Okay, I don't think we're going to struggle too much.
I'm not going to waste any more ammo.
Take me, Mr. Sunflower, take me.
I want to win with my...
Oh shit, my souls!
Oh well.
You win some, you lose some.
I'm too scared to do the boss on that one.
I can't handle it.
My little heart can't handle it.
Okay, let's try that.
Time to wake up for your daily milking session.
Here we go.
We've got Shlumping, you're coming in.
And then we've got...
Okay, you have to tell me the reason.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Did I pick up anything else?
Right, I've not picked up anything that set our head where for what...
Other than if I wanted to like lighten myself.
Maybe...
Yeah, maybe this works.
What?
Tired of me?
Should be asleep right now.
What?
No, me?
No?
Okay, my reflings are ready.
Let's try it.
Can this Sunflower perish us?
Okay, no.
Bra, he is so...
Bra, he is so aggressive.
What do you mean this Elden Ring boss is hard and they didn't make him...
Oh, sorry, I just punched the mic with my headset.
I try to get comfy in my chair and I mess that up.
I'm doing a hip registration right now.
I'm trying to get frost damage on his head.
Okay, I'm actually just...
Excuse me, social distancing please.
I don't know how I avoided that.
Boom, headshot.
Oh wait, there's a talisman for my crossbow efficiency.
Whoa, someone did massive damage.
Can you go bleed on a freaking Sunflower?
Where is he going for me?
Oh my god, you did it!
Come on, come on.
You did it, you did it, you did it.
Yes!
You did it, refling, you did it.
You did it.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, refling!
Refling!
You didn't...
What?
Does he perish himself?
Hello?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh my god.
None of you told me I wasn't ogre.
Oh.
Oh, please let me heal.
Oh, I don't know if I got the right thing collected.
Why would I?
Oh.
Okay.
I'm hating behind the tree.
Oh no, not again.
It didn't go for me, so I'll take it.
As if you changed aggro last second, you're such a liar.
And the duty hit.
I'm actually starting to get a bit...
Bleed filled up.
Oh, you're like looking at me, don't you?
I'm trying to take aggro.
I know I'm hardly doing any damage,
but like the...
If I can take aggro, like...
Not like that, not like that.
What are these?
Demons!
Absolute demons!
Oh no.
Heavy attacking him to the head
does three times more damage than normal.
I need milk three times a day.
The absolute contrast with some of this.
It's still going.
I'm still getting walloped and getting carried the way I like it.
If I have fire, I might be better than born arrow.
You know that.
I'll try fire.
Right, who came in?
Pineapple, you've not had a shot.
Mage, you've not had a shot at this boss either.
I like this guy because he's more like a traditional boss
compared to all the other bosses who just spam attack.
They actually give you a second to think and be like...
Oh...
Oh!
Oh, thank you!
Okay, yes, we're trying to fire.
I assume burn damages is a fricking weakness considering
it's literally a plant that I could put in a pot
and put in my window edge, you know?
Yeah, fire...
Oh, well, I just got fire bolts.
Hold on a minute.
Wait.
One...
Two...
I'm wondering if I do the ultimate on that.
And then just fire bolt.
See what happens.
Boneball, any boners?
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Black key...
Oh, wow!
Okay, talk about delivery.
I think I'm going to have to send a need.
I think I'm going to have to go into my inventory
in the lightning thing.
Okay.
ATR bolt.
How many?
Are you just giving me everything?
To keep bone...
bolt.
I literally haven't even discovered that yet.
You've given me something...
that I've not even discovered.
Step boneball.
Is that a table?
Holy shit.
Thank you, refling.
Okay, I think we'll stop.
Are you guys ready?
I didn't even know the plant had a second phase.
That's what we were going to.
Okay.
Here goes.
Okay, it's going to swipe for me.
I need to dodge right away.
Dodge.
And then another swipe could be for me.
Okay, I know I'm learning though
that it does go for me twice, which is fine.
I'm going to lock onto the head, not the B.
The head.
Okay, close enough.
It's not really beef in the middle.
Oh wait, hold on, I'm fucked up.
I really fucked up there.
Thank you.
If I can get his head to look at me again,
I can spray it down.
What's this?
I'm out of mana, so I'll try and do that bonus thing.
I don't have an...
How are we supposed to be...
Oh god, he's going to do that run thing.
You need to be careful, okay?
Thank you.
He's going to come up again.
I don't know where.
I found where.
I don't know who he's going to run at.
You, it looks like.
He's not having it.
He's reaching.
Okay, well, I'm too slow to even react to that.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, you can't just change enemy.
Oh my...
Oh, but when I do blood loss on an enemy,
it's a tiddly wank.
I'm not going to make it.
I think we need...
I think we need to replant up
in order to do the second phase.
It's so aggressive.
It's so aggressive, I can't keep up.
The distance to close as well
is just astronomical.
I'm missing everything.
My first replant is getting annihilated.
Hey, look at me, buddy.
There we go.
Nice change already.
I don't know how I missed that first one.
Fuck, Nail.
Even the planet, like, the sun magic?
I don't know.
That's right, I'm doing 12 damage.
You're welcome.
Ah, I haven't got it.
That second phase is just crazy.
Strony, sorry, boys.
I don't suppose we should do the same thing, but...
Yeah.
I'm going to pull them out of my inventory on the fire
because someone said I'm supposed to do that.
That is a brutal plan.
Baruto.
Ran out of stamina.
No, don't worry about it.
I'm off for the night. Good luck, everyone.
And don't forget to drink, Strony.
Water?
Let me hide you. Hold on.
I did get a glass of Cuda.
A glass of Cuda.
Statistically, I'm going to sleep bloody well tonight.
Because exhaustion has to result in a coma at some point.
So I might as well just keep fucking going.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, my inventory.
My inventory.
Remember I spell...
Sort.
Chest.
Yes.
I would like to...
In my chest, I have rune.
I need vaults.
Can I only have 99 in a category?
Um...
Okay.
Store, know, the moon?
How do I access the chest?
Switch back. Switch to chest.
Why?
Take out...
It only took a thousand years.
Your inventory's full.
Like, if I put other shite in it, like this shite...
Like you, store.
You, store.
I can't even use you.
Like...
What's that?
You store all this to kind of use it?
Keep the whip.
And then go here.
And then I'll let me bring it out.
Ah, fuck off.
Right, whatever.
Nah, if you have 99 in both, you can't play any more music.
Man, that's it.
Rob, all the things this game lets you do, that's where they draw the line.
Like, yeah.
Say, have you had a shot of it?
And you have...
Slumping, you had a shot.
Just the fella...
Hasn't had a shot of the sunflower?
Alright, let me write that down.
Paying off what you did, have a wee shot.
Of net, you had a shot.
Can't you ever see if you've not had a shot of them?
Okay.
Mmm.
Netmer's ever seen collection coming to life.
Bro, literally.
I've never seen Little Shop of Horrors,
but apparently it's about a plant that can talk or something.
I've been recommended to watch it so many times.
They're like, oh, it's the classic, it's the classic.
You need to watch Little Shop of Horrors.
And I'm like...
I'm too tired.
Okay, are we ready?
Are you ready to carry me?
Please stay true to your emotes and carry me.
Carry me.
Oh wait, is that double-fisting?
Hold on, I'm here for it.
Hold on.
Hold on, I purposely put all my inventory away
so I can do this really quickly.
Alright, let me get my bow out.
I'll do the rapid fire, then I'll just swap
to the actual one that's there.
Are we ready?
I wanna help Mommy out and get a smith,
but I'm way too far behind.
Bro, I'm literally...
The only reason on my head is because
Reflins are carrying me.
Oh, he changed.
Normally he always goes through me.
That's the first time he has...
The trees are in the way.
Okay, let's see.
My ultimate, how do I move it?
That one, nope, that's just healing.
Okay, woo!
That happens every time.
Ouch.
Ouch, I missed both dodges.
Uh, I gotta do this again.
I keep healing by accident.
I'm wasting my heal, sorry.
You didn't even...
Pull it!
Bro, sorry, I'm getting very tired.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm getting baby brains.
I'm getting so tired.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Use manual.
Thank you, Apple and Vox for the set.
Manual, baby.
Uh...
Sorry, I'm definitely starting to lag a bit.
I'm like, not lag in game.
I mean, lag fall asleep, so I do apologize.
It's just making you cringe out your boots.
Phoenix, you've not had a shot at this boss yet.
Maino spelling mistake.
You'll be obliterated for such a thing.
Brian, I'll let you know.
Uh...
We had a shot.
Who's up next?
Come on.
If we do it in order of who's come...
Who's up here?
Oh.
Sorry, just our cure off it.
I completely forgot we came that way.
Your favorite edgy girl.
Oh, is that how you...
Can I bend over it?
Mm.
Okay, I'm done.
Are we ready?
Ready to carry me?
Okay, let him lock onto me and break some trees.
Oh, the tree stops it?
I can't see the other.
Whoa, I just missed that no more.
Oh, he didn't.
It's very hard to see where he's looking,
or I'm just dumb.
That's a very acceptable answer.
Oh, my God.
A whole 300 damage?
Oh, I'm out.
I completely missed that one, but...
When he licks at me, it's so scary.
Actually, you know what I've just been reminded of?
Hold on.
I'm pretty sure I need to do this.
Someone gave me a ranger's talisman.
Yeah, okay.
That might make a difference over time.
You never know.
Aw.
I mean, they're kind of burning him down.
I wish I could take aggro.
I don't like that, though.
Okay.
Okay, he's gonna come back.
Don't want to run over.
You can't equip at this time.
Oh, that would be too...
Let's just fucking shove any old arrow on it.
What?
Why would you come after me?
I did the least damage on you.
And you've done the most damage on me.
I'm way too drunk to play the boss.
Are you steaming right now?
Try to help me win this game.
Oh, what is this?
Can you aim for the head?
Oh, I can...
Oh, I just got out of a ranger no more.
I'm trying not to cross over on the path of leaflings
in case he does a long arm against me
and then I end up hurting the leaflings.
Oh, I'm getting really out of range.
I don't want to get close either.
Holy shit, we're like 50% though.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No.
Oh, you're...
No, no, no, like this.
No, like this.
No, I just did.
I just threw so badly.
I just said, oh, we got 50%.
I think we can do it.
If you guys are able to get 50%,
I think you can do it.
50% on phase two.
I believe, I believe in the leaflings.
No way.
Didn't expect Elden Ring
in the hit video game, Elden Ring.
Okay, fan up for income.
That was a really good attempt though.
I think we'll do...
We'll finish this boss.
Oh wait, does that not work?
We'll finish this boss
and then I think I might have to go
and try and get a focus boost.
So, I'm not going to do...
There's just a few in.
I'm having them.
I mean, there's only one other summon in that I can have.
Hmm.
We'll defeat this boss
and then I think I need to try and get a big focus boost.
I can't believe I'm taking HP damage
just from existing.
It's often.
I mean, what HP damage?
Are you kidding me?
Fucking 5% debuff?
Okay, good luck kisses.
Okay, let's go.
Just a brisk 8-hour stream today.
Yeah, casual stream, unfortunately.
I can't see the others coming in
but that tree just blocked them, so...
I'll take that.
Whoa, someone just cast Spell and worked them.
Whoa!
What are you casting?
Oh shit.
Okay.
Ipsies.
It's a little tired.
Ipsy pipsies.
This can be the tired.
Okay.
Origin.
Pretty good considering that was phase one.
Eight hours, I'm about to work.
You will be on your phone in bed
for two more hours, right?
I'm literally going to lie down
and put Binding of Isaac gameplay on
and go to sleep.
I'm not very well.
I can be...
Holy shit!
How are you doing that kind of damage?
I don't understand.
Oh, shit.
Ow!
It's spanked by a plant.
I want to keep my HP high.
I do not want to...
Thank you, thank you, sorry.
I want to keep it high.
Brats.
See, I didn't want to be in the path of another refling.
That's the problem.
We might end up accidentally hurting each other.
How the fuck is that Madden and Strike doing so much?
Oh my god, I'm doing like nothing to help at all.
Other than perishing, clearly.
Okay, that's fine.
I've got heals.
I've got plenty.
Okay.
Is it going to swipe?
What's he doing?
Okay.
Okay, I can get shot in.
And then he does cut in really big and annoying here.
That's exactly what I thought.
I've got a blast.
It's okay.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
I don't have blood loss just yet.
I've got a heal.
I've got one more heal in the tank.
One more heal.
I'm helping.
I'm losing.
I'm going to die.
I get hit again.
I think I'm dead because I've got blood loss.
Oh, by a bow here.
By a bow here.
Oh my god.
Refling.
I think I need you to kill him like right now.
I can't do anything.
I'm going to suffer from blood loss.
Oh, no.
But when the fucking aim is on you, it gets worse.
Oh my god, did you do it?
You did it.
Oh my god, you did it.
Fuck me, man.
Oh, no, it's dead.
Sorry.
I didn't have any HP remaining.
Oh my god, you did it.
You've vanquished the beast.
Wait, does that mean I have to go offline now?
What?
Ah!
Um
Um-um-um.
Um.
Um-um-um-um-um.
Em-imm-imm?
Ah.
Why is the music so sad for the sauce fight?
What's this?
Is he- is the music sad because he's killing himself to try and win this fight?
Is he getting weaker?
I'm shooting his weak fucking face.
Now?
Embrace the shadow sunflower.
What on earth was that?
Jeez, I don't know how you did that.
Was he getting weaker and weaker?
If the music is sad and the school's saying you're either the villain or the boss of fighting for the fight.
If the music is sad and the school's saying you're either the villain or the boss of fighting for the long reason.
Oh no.
Literally, I heard a violin.
Oh yeah, totally first try.
Yeah, it seems like he got weaker and weaker.
Double madness seal for-
Oh, tarnished well done.
Double madness seal for 50% damage increase.
Jeez, that was insane.
Oh fuck, I'm actually supposed to- is this just a dead end?
What?
I got a seal though?
Thank you for grabbing the aggro.
That strat won't work if I didn't go and get it.
It's my billions of gold, as I said.
No, it's fine, we won!
Where's the next boss?
Oh yeah.
Where's the next one?
Where do we go?
So I came all the way-
So I'm like underneath this section here.
Um, I don't think there's anything I can do back here.
So I need to sleep a little bit, but take her to Bale.
Dragon Mountain?
I thought the next boss was actually getting a good night's rest, honestly.
Got him.
We were going to bed after the boss.
How about- how about one more boss?
So...
I can't progress at the castle because I'm too rubbish.
I vote Bale.
Bale will humble us.
There's two boss- no, there's one boss, the snake boss we're stuck at.
But we did the sunflower.
Where?
Strony!
Re-flang!
You had 99 cookies, thank you Strony!
No, I'm 85, we're doing a two back-to-back endurance runescape stream, just to see if we'll get there.
Strony says one more boss, like it's easy peasy-
Oh, it's easy peasy because you guys are carrying me through it.
How do I get up here?
I don't know, I want it.
I don't know, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know.
How do I get up here?
I don't know, I want it.
Anyway, maybe this?
Hmm, doesn't really look like that though.
I think I could probably take a horse and take it down here to this area.
We've got this.
Right, where am I heading?
Someone says Bale.
I don't know where Bale is.
We're on Cathedral's morning.
I don't think I've ever walked the Blue Cove Bale.
And I'm stuck in this castle.
I did get this here as a divine beast, but I could go up here.
That looks like a dead end though.
Unless I can go down in the water.
Come back down into the water and go up the water.
Far so for Bale, far so.
I've got grief, like, fleeing.
There's a ghost over there.
I thought you were going to bed.
Oh, I just needed more.
Stony, some of these bosses can take hours to go to bed.
Well, at least let me know what we're up against tomorrow.
I let me know.
I just need to know.
Right, so what if I take a...
I keep going this way.
Whoa.
La.
It's red.
I can see enemies down there.
Whoa, I see a fire giant too.
Whoa.
How did we get there?
It must be a cavern.
Oh, it must be, because that's just the freaking bomb of the map.
The morning coconut is by the red flower.
Whoa, fuck me.
Oh my god, that made me jump.
They've left that in as a body dump too.
It's working.
What is that?
Oh my gosh.
We've hardly even explored a fraction of this one.
Right, scour.
Make your noise.
Oh, it's a dead dragon.
Oh, four dragons.
Oh my gosh.
I like how the enemies are like spawned in the area
and they're just waiting to interact with something.
I find that pretty cool.
All right.
Let's just follow this path and see what happens.
I'm not actually sure what happens,
but as long as Torrent can carry me through the wind,
I'll be okay.
She says with her crossbow bolt out.
Oh, there's definitely some sort of bridge thing going on over here.
Hold on.
See if I can get a marker along the way I'll call you guys in.
You can explore and foot in.
There's safety in numbers, I assure you.
Right, so I discovered that church,
but I didn't go right.
If there even is a right.
Very plausible and going the wrong way.
But that's never stopped me before.
Wait, is there a fire giant there?
No, but there's some sort of settlement.
If I was a settlement on the cliff edge.
Oh, whoa.
Okay.
I'm definitely not down there.
Huh.
Oh, I mean that is the bridge though.
Is this it?
I don't want to lose.
To get down there, you need to head south east along the path.
I don't think I've unlocked it then.
Really go down into this watery bit.
How would I get down there?
I'm possibly, it looks like there's a,
yeah, there's a road here.
How do I get there?
If I take a right, it looks like I,
if I take a right and stick to the left or the right,
then I think it'll be fine.
There's dragons in.
Wait, let's see how wrong I am.
Hold on.
If I take, if I go this way,
follow the path but hug the left.
Let's see.
If I get horribly wrong, at least we can have a giggle.
I'm already, wait, this path?
Okay, that path apparently leads me somewhere.
They're interested in fighting.
You growl at someone else, you bunch of furries.
No way you almost hit that.
If I hug the left or the right.
Oh, oh, oh, five head.
I'm so smart, you could call me a cartographer.
We did it, we did it.
Okay, this is where we're supposed to go.
That's it, that's it.
Dangerously.
Okay, to the vats, to the vats.
Careful, buddies, and then you hurt yourself.
Don't aggro them too much now.
Uh, yeah, okay, I see it, I see it.
Gentle, gentle.
There, there's a big old cross station down there,
but that's the thing.
Gentle.
Yeah, so gentle.
We're all friends here.
Okay, so.
See, is that cavern?
There used to be some sort of cavern.
But if I go up here, there might be a rest spot.
Whoa, whoa, careful, baby, don't get poisoned.
Wow, I see them.
Wow, this is Poison Avenue.
Oh, dear.
Torrent, can you claim this?
Torrent, claim this cliff right now.
Oh, God, Torrent, you're so smart.
You're like a wreathling.
Okay, I don't see any implication of a safe site.
And that's how something is there.
Huh.
Ah, wait, if I keep going this way,
there'll be something ahead.
Just need to try and avoid the poison.
But there also is, like, there's something over here.
But not a safe site?
Maybe a cavern?
Okay, well, yes, we're just looking for one safe site.
Uh, I think that's a path up.
Torrent is immune to poison?
Oh.
Torrent, your shoes are green.
Wait, what?
Am I just-
Oh, I'm just freaking going backwards.
Right, sorry, pardon me, excuse me.
It looks like there's more than one way to get to this area.
My apologies.
But it's per hoops are green for a baby.
I didn't mean to paint them green.
Can you paint?
You must be able, yeah, because horses, shoes,
horses' nails are, like, the same thing.
So in theory, you can give a horse a pedicure,
which is hilarious if you think about it.
Oh, they must do it for sure, horses, actually.
There's a wind current.
I want to go up.
Uh, I am...
I can almost come back down a wind current.
Wait, it's not a wind current?
Am I being vagus?
It's not a wind current.
Why are you- I have no idea.
Okay.
You just have to care for me.
Because we have adapted the animals for our knee.
Yeah, so now they require special care.
Thousand of dread.
That sounds pretty cool.
Not gonna lie.
Then...
Raise this potency of magma.
Magma is dread, please.
Oh, hello.
Is this your house?
Bubble, thank you for coming, a member.
Enjoy this, me, the memory page.
Old Baal, Tyrant Drake.
Uh, it's a dragon.
Is your fury still yet to crest its zenith?
Hurry, hurry, and lay it all to waste.
Lay waste to the proud, the conceited,
each every last one of that arrogant law.
Huh, no, this is definitely a dead end crossing, right?
So how do we keep that?
Thank you for coming, a member.
Bubbles!
Are there any bubbles?
Who are you?
I didn't expect his tongue.
Try attacking.
I mean, yes.
Where y'all?
Oh, somewhere.
Oh, wait, sorry.
I don't think any of you are gonna be here by...
Wait, there's nothing here.
Okay, there's nothing here but we mushroom.
That's fine.
And then we take the skywind up.
Legend of Zelda style.
And then we go upsy-pupsy.
Whoa!
Tyrant, Tyrant, don't you get a little,
like, feel a little sick doing that?
No? No, that doesn't faze you at all.
Feel like anything special?
No.
Upsy-pupsy!
Jeez, Lois!
I'm in a castle.
Oh, wait, is anyone here?
No.
We have unlocked a fort of Reprimands.
That's where you go when you misbehave.
You go into Shibi's fort of Reprimands.
Hydration check.
I'm a...
Tyrant just jumping entire mountains like it's nothing.
Mmm.
Okay.
We're in fort Reprimand
and the teleportation is called behind the fort of Reprimands.
I'm allowed to call you guys in because I've not defeated it.
My face turned out one leafling is here.
Um...
Oh, I just burped out of nervousness.
Oh, wait, it's because...
No, it's that because...
So it should show up.
Wait, Beel's not in the fort.
Oh, am I going the wrong way?
Well, we did bit of exploring that we did today.
We'll be there, give us a second.
Give us a second, let us show up.
Okay, there we go, there we go, there we go.
Uh, right, I've got...
I think we're all limited to have any reefing to come in.
Is there any enemy reefing?
I've got enemies.
Got a lot of enemies.
Got enemies.
Yeah, a lot of enemies.
I've been main being mummies.
And mummies for a reprimandation, honestly.
I think it's just called a panini press, to be honest.
The fort is cool, yeah.
Maybe we'll do the fort, and then I'll see if we want to keep going or not.
I'll gauge interest.
I've got an enemy reefing.
I've got enemies.
Okay, let's hope you get it again.
Okay, we've got one reefling.
We've got two reefling.
And for the third reefling.
Behold!
The third reefling!
Right now, spawn in...
Right now.
Spawning right before me.
Rise, ye reefling!
Rise!
Are you whimpering?
Goat, goat, goat, goat.
Goat, goat, goat.
When she keeps talking.
Okay, let's see what we're dealing with.
One's whimpering, one's got...
You are beautiful.
We do need to get all the coconuts.
We can all talk to each other.
You are beautiful.
Wah!
Some bell stone.
No, just no more sinking stone.
I still need to see some bell stone.
I like how the coconut's done so evil.
But he's like...
Eh?
That reefling needs help?
Oh.
Can anyone catch some sort of distance thing from here?
Woah!
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, he's making it rain lightning.
He is raging.
Is that a giant?
We're in the middle of a fight.
He is raging.
Is he okay?
He's...
Woah!
Careful!
Oh, now we need to jump him!
Jump him!
Make him regret it!
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
We jumped him.
A broken room.
Okay, we managed to jump him.
Reeflings.
Spit rows that man.
Oh, he didn't touch me.
I have touched...
I have touched you, okay.
Flirting with straw and he's biting enemies right next to you.
What were you?
You see?
I go the wrong way.
You guys have only had access to this...
What's going on in there?
Oh, there's a knight!
There's a knight!
Careful!
He's...
Stop!
I'm whimpering too!
I'm scared!
Oh my god.
Woah!
Oh my god, he's got a jewel!
It's a freaking...
What's it?
Darth Maul?
When he has two sides of his lightsaber?
Oh my god!
Fuck him up!
Don't let him breathe!
He has terrible points!
He should be ashamed!
Call yourself a knight and you can't handle three on one?
What do you mean?
It's not fair!
I will not listen to your pleas!
I will not listen to your ignorance!
Oh shh!
He's a phoenix!
You little stinker team!
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah!
Hold on, mummy needs to heal.
And rest her stamina.
Okay, there we go.
Black knight, yeah.
What's it?
Edridge?
Jumping.
Enemy fell.
You guys aren't going to despawn through his enemy.
It wasn't a god, it was enemy.
Please tell me you guys don't despair.
Please tell me you don't despair.
No!
Wait, I'm going back.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, don't care.
Don't care.
I actually don't care, I'm going back.
Oh my god, streamers too scared to play games?
Yeah?
What happens next?
What happens next if streamers too scared to play games?
That was the boss.
In this castle?
Wait, so I can't...
More like, black and bruised knight?
Am I right?
So what was my reward?
Oh, other than failing an enemy.
No, my ears can hear that.
No, sorry, I have hearing.
I'm not.
I ain't doing it.
I don't care what's up there, it ain't that important.
There's a chest up that ladder,
there's also something creeping around up there.
I'm not risking it.
I can feel my soul leaving my body.
What, because I have bad?
Go back to the castle front.
Castle front.
I've got a shadow key.
I don't have a castle for fun.
Am I being perfectly good?
The grace castle front.
Castle front.
Ming deep further.
Is this the castle front?
Castle you fought really?
That doesn't help me.
You need a name to say.
I'm useless though.
I don't know.
That was the lion, so it's not this one.
Oh, got it.
I got it.
Sorry.
Take me a second there.
I'm bad, okay?
I'm tired, I'm tired.
I'm tired, baby.
You guys better be coming in and saving me.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Go back side to sit down there.
In come.
Save me from the enemies, I guess.
There's an enemy, isn't it?
I can hear something like through the wind.
Faultfish in the bad direction, honestly.
Waman moment.
Good luck everybody else.
I'm turning left.
Well, there's a few more reeflings in this section.
Who's not had a shot to clean a bit?
Uh, Alessandro...
Oh, crap, you've not had a shot, has it?
And then...
I want to find Pineapple and...
I think Shalamping was last, and then Pineapple, your next.
It's cute when you get lost.
Not frustrating.
The rituals, okay?
Even though it's exploration, so I guess
it's not much.
As soon as you come in, hand me your best shot, boom.
Hand me your best shot, as soon as you come in, boom.
I kneel.
Allow me to carry you.
Yes, I give you permission to carry me.
Okay, where the heck are we going?
Do I stop that whimpering?
Right, we're to go west.
Ooh, I see it now.
I see it, I see it, I see it, I see it.
This map is getting big.
Okay, we have a light.
Follow the beacon!
I thought we had to go west.
I meant south east.
Ah!
South was the jargon.
Just run past any enemy.
Got a lot of enemies.
Got enemies.
They well fistrode at you.
But I just ignore them.
Move it ahead for me, even more.
Okay, keep a move on, Reefland.
They're jumping us!
Ah!
Oh, man, it's coming.
Oh, flowers.
Are you guys okay?
Yes, how much you guys are okay?
I need to get those glowstones that do something.
Are they scared?
Is it gonna run away?
I'm so fine.
Take her to the priest there.
I just want to know who the next thing...
Whoa!
Something's after me.
I'm not looking behind.
I've got enough stamina to keep going.
Oh, wait.
One of the Reeflings are half health.
Wait, I think the Reeflings are getting jumped.
Both the Reeflings are getting jumped like holy hell.
I think maybe...
I think maybe we should have teamed up.
And four.
Are you guys gonna make it?
I'm scared.
I don't know.
Okay, we've got one healed up.
Are you guys...
Are you not able to run past?
There's an enemy to your right coming up.
To your right.
Just run past if you can.
Wait, the worms are...
Have health bars?
Oh, don't hurt the worms.
They're cute.
Ah!
I hear you healing.
Pain.
My arms.
My legs.
Each light a bloody ruin.
Bail!
Bail Bail.
Oh, terror incarnate.
There is life in me yet.
I will soon feast upon your heart.
Mark my words.
You too shall know fear.
Ah!
Oh, the pain.
The exquisite pain.
Okay, we're in dialysis.
That, I was like,
I'm pretty sure it's not that kind of game,
but that's how I want you guys to win for him.
That's what I want to be hearing.
Oh!
Mommy, are you in thrall?
Am I allowed to be?
She wants us to send.
Other than the pain part, I don't want to cause any pain.
Okay.
It seemed rather safe.
It's rather dark around these parts.
Let me pop a wee light on,
just so we can see what we're doing.
Okay.
Statue's coming alive, that's fine.
Jump on.
Are you squidding me right now?
But stomp my face, anime woman.
Yes, awesome.
Thank you for the two.
Oh, butt stomp!
I thought you meant butt.
Is that like a question?
Yeah.
You're more than welcome.
Oh no!
But then you can come back.
That's my face!
Oh my god, look!
It's my face as player model!
Check it out!
I got eyes, but aren't eyes?
Oh!
Wow!
It's kind of cool to see the inside mechanics
that we lost in the first place.
Thank you for you.
I can't progress unless all gone.
If you click multiplayer and then press Duff Finger,
it's like multiplayer
and then hit the finger saber.
I don't want to kick, I feel like...
Let's see.
What's behind cave number one?
Dragon's Pit.
Okay.
I don't know if I got reason to use this one.
Ain't it nice?
Ain't it just grand?
I need some.
Wait a minute.
We're in a place called
Dragon's Pit today.
Norm, have you had a show?
I don't think...
I think Norm and then Oz.
Again, if I forget the order,
I'm really sorry.
Can't summon in there.
At least I couldn't.
They may have done some quiet
hot patches, possibly.
I don't know.
For like quick fixes like that.
I assume the area...
He's not the thinker!
Nice job, Lazer.
One step closer to getting a screaming coconut.
So I need to say she's got a bit of diamonds, so...
Yeah?
What are you gonna do? You fart?
I need to kiss other leaflings.
Wait, I'll call up to you. Get ready.
And then I need to kiss you.
No! Oh, there's enemies everywhere!
Hold on, I'm trying to kiss the leaflings.
Don't be so rude.
Whoa, there's one behind us!
Chase!
Are we okay?
Everyone okay?
Oh, there's a fake wall here.
Oh wait, that's not a fake wall.
Dung ahead, as in nothing ahead?
Okay, soothing stone level one.
Yeah, maybe it is dung ahead.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa! He's back?
Does he infinitely spawn?
Oh, you need to whack him again.
If they have the little ghost thingy,
you need to be whack.
She's allergic to rest.
This sounds terrible, but at this moment in time,
I can't sleep properly.
So my logic is that I might as well...
Because if I go lie down and I can't sleep,
I will be so annoyed that I went offline
when we could have played some more together.
So instead of doing that, I'm like,
well, I'm probably guaranteed to pass out instantly.
Oh shit, I missed.
Because if I pass out instantly,
then I'll get more than enough sleep.
Does that make sense?
That makes terrible sense.
But it's kind of the truth.
Have you tried ASMR?
I watch video games to sleep too,
like people playing video games that have an interest in.
I currently watch Binding of Isaac gameplay.
I'm not very good at it,
before anyone's like,
oh my god, AMLG Pro, no, I'm just...
I just watch, like,
because I've been watching Boutro to sleep,
I've been watching Binding of Isaac to sleep.
I've been watching Civ 6.
I can't understand it.
But I've been watching people play it,
and I think it's probably one of those games
that I'll play when I retire, basically.
Holy shit, he's putting magma everywhere.
Is he supposed to do that?
Ow, like, it burns.
It burns, everything burns.
Oh my god, this whole cave is burning.
Like, I don't think I could play Civ 6
to make it fun without having, like,
actual game time in it.
There's just some games that aren't good for strumming.
And I would say
Civ 6, when you're not
experienced with it at all,
is one of the...wait, am I being done?
He's still up, wait, what's his health?
Oh no, he's going down.
Wait, hold on, I need to restore my stamina.
I need my stamina.
Oh my god, he's stuck.
That's a cool design.
Honestly, I'm so down for a dragon.
Actually, I need to mention that
to the concept artist.
I'm really interested in developing
a lollipop dragon
with a very unique color palette.
Ancient dragon smithing stone, yeah.
I wish that worked for me,
even if I'm disgustingly ghosted.
I can still be up.
No, like, my brain will be like,
you've had enough.
And I think I'm going to hit it
if I keep going,
which is what I want.
So this is, like, tactfully streaming.
Like, I don't want streamers like,
oh, you're going to rest.
I'm so tired, you're going to rest.
Me, like, now let's push the fucking limit.
Like, let's push one.
Okay, we're going down this time.
Fucking hell, man.
But if I caught any of the vealer girls doing this,
no, they're getting spanked and put into bed.
I'm coming to their hooses.
I'm going to their hooses.
I think they can get away with this.
Only I'm allowed to do this.
Ooh, there's a bull.
Oh, look!
It's the sip bull that I kicked.
Oh!
Was I supposed to do that?
Oh, my God.
I didn't know we were supposed to do that.
I was so happy about the sip bull
that I was going to cook for everyone on the farm.
Oh, my God, I had a damn heart attack.
Right, Ian's ready.
Are you steady?
I have no idea what's behind.
But let's do it!
Oh, shit, I don't have my crossbow out.
Oh, shit.
Okay, melee.
Whoa, wait.
You're...
Okay, it looks like bleed damage, athletic build.
Super skinny Malinky.
Terrible poise.
That's what we like to see.
Unable to resist.
Hold on, I need to recharge my stamina.
Oh, my God.
This is my kind of fight.
Yeah!
That's right.
Get a staggered, get a staggered, get a staggered.
Oh, that's my kind of fight.
I love it here.
Hello.
Dragon Hunter's great katana.
Yeah, definitely.
Me look like a samurai build type thing to that.
Do you guys always have to go...
I said, I'm installing a mod right now.
That means you guys get to, like, hang around after you do a boss fight with me.
Strony, are you telling me I need to spank you
when I need to look after you?
It's the only way I'll listen.
If he looks after you, Strony, then we sling.
And we spank me as well.
Three stack on it is easy.
Plop, plop, plop, get staggered, get staggered, get staggered.
There's a head coming.
Did I unlock a...
Did I unlock anything?
No.
Yeah.
I swear if an enemy pops out, it's one of these things.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, thank you.
Touch me.
Can I summon the Duman?
It's not a punishment if you enjoy it.
I don't think I can summon you guys at Dragon's Fit Termina.
Go outside, okay.
Streamer gets told to go outside and touch grass.
Yeah.
Analysing foot of the jagged peak.
Hmm, I wonder if there's a dragon fight ahead.
I don't know, I just have some weird inclination.
There might be a dragon fight ahead.
No idea why.
I think there might be a dragon fight ahead.
Oh, there's that flame guy.
Go to the cave's entrance, link back.
Can you guys put it down here?
Okay, if you guys go to Dragon's Fit Termina,
you can really come outside.
Why is there only 50 areas?
Map required ahead, therefore, water side.
Sorry, I didn't realize it wasn't active.
I thought it was the map.
Oh, there you are.
Okay.
There wasn't any pineapple.
We knew an ally.
Oh, my brain's getting marshed.
I can't remember who was who
and who wasn't who.
I'm trying my best.
I'm so sorry.
I can't remember anymore, my brain.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
I promise I'm trying.
Can't grab the map in this area, so it's blind.
Or just run past the dragon to the right.
Not, I need to say.
Okay.
I'm well very...
Oh, sorry.
There's so many allegations.
Might be found in the...
Oh, no, who doesn't come in?
Is it DC?
Unable to summon 4 partners.
Someone's got...
Someone's internet does not like me.
I like how you have a staff to point the way.
It's pretty good.
Remember that thing that Wiefling blocked me from falling?
Oh, no, sorry.
All three Wieflings blocked me from falling to my death
because you all knew fine well.
I would have kept walking because I was blabbing away talking on stream.
That was very cute.
I like that moment.
I'd be...
Maybe I should get a commemorative doodle for that as well.
I want a commemorative doodle of you guys carrying me through Elden Ring.
And then maybe I'll just get like a doodle meme.
One of those colored doodles in memes.
And it's like, stop, don't go.
And then like I'm saying something like some capitals ran as I usually do.
And like you guys are like blocking me from walking forward.
That would be funny.
Mm-hmm.
Wait.
Oh, no, the dragon is alive.
Hold on.
What do we do?
Are we just avoiding by going right?
I think we're avoiding by going right side.
I can do that.
That's a very sleepy dragon.
Very, very sleepy dragon.
Okay.
If he's a slumber, he doesn't have to.
Three Reflings carrying Strony on a palanquin.
Oh Reflings, what's a palanquin?
Is it the Egypt chair?
Like you...
Whoa.
Yeah, damn.
What are they feeding you?
You guys still eat GMO food?
This is what's happening to your GMO...
Yes, it's also something called a litter.
I'll unsummon you.
Fuck that.
Isn't it your bedtime?
5 p.m. is my actual bedtime, but I'm trying to flip my sleep.
So I fall asleep right now.
So I fall asleep right after stream.
So I can wake up at 1.
So if I do fall asleep right now,
I'm gonna be like after the end of stream.
If I fall asleep instantly,
I will have done my sleep the way I want it to be.
What is banging and thrashing about?
I can hear it.
Who making all that damn noise?
Oh, I hope he's dead.
I don't want his furry body to be...
suffering.
Oh, that is a flame?
I can see him.
No, I think he definitely gone, the fur guy.
Oh, it's the dragon's heartbeat?
I see a stone dragon, but his heart still pulses?
The noise is ugly on a farm.
Are you getting your stuff?
Did I touch it?
Oh, examine.
Communion with bail.
Additional items required, okay.
Virtual dragon communication.
Offering a dragon heart, ghost breath.
Channels, dragons, just use a flame.
Right, so I don't need to do any of that.
Okay.
We claimed the dragon?
Like in the other one?
Wait, what?
Oh, there's someone here talk to.
Oh.
Eject yourself.
Feasting upon a dragon's essence.
Yeah.
On the throbbing heart of the oldest,
violent dragon of them all.
It would be the purest form of communion.
The fullest sating of your hunger
and your consummation as a dragon.
She wants to become part dragon?
Oh, she is?
Look at her hands on the devourer?
Eat?
Eat or no eat?
Eat wagon or no eat wagon?
Hmm.
Oh, it's a sin.
Do not partake.
You have yet to be a true one.
I am patient.
There will come a day when hunger knocks.
I don't know, man.
You don't look like this.
You look like this.
Okay, let's go.
I wonder if it gives you like a special thing you can do.
Yeah, the airtree don't like when you start messing with dragons stuff.
Okay.
The sound of standing on the scales
almost gravel-like.
It sounds like cabbage, honestly.
I'm wondering what foley sound they use for it.
It sounds like cabbage.
Okay.
Oh, is this the red flowers?
Oh, my God.
No, that's putting me to sleep because of the hue.
I need to get out of here.
Oh, no.
New area load.
I'm afraid we fling.
It's the same.
Where are we on the map?
Yeah.
Damn, this map just keeps getting bigger and bigger.
Oh, we are on the red.
We're about to do a big U-turn to that blue thing, I thought.
Is that all the blue things?
Oh, no.
Shadow is hitting three.
I feel blessed to show the beauty of this human coconut tunnel.
Lord ahead.
Okay, I'm not going down there, then.
I'll go up and pray that there's something up here.
Bruh.
You've never been mean to me before.
Why are you being mean to me now?
The moment my refunds disappear, the game's like,
let me just go absolutely eat on you.
No, I'll go to the marina.
Not secure anymore.
No, I think I'll back.
Honestly, try to terrify me like that.
It's working.
I don't really want to get attacked by a marina because they have distance magic,
but I'm just going to go for it.
And then get past real quick.
I'm here.
I'm casting off a little spell.
Sorry, can't reach me.
Okay, I'm happy with this.
I'll take this.
I don't know what it is.
What it does.
I don't know where it is.
I'll take it.
Give me a...
Okay, this is called...
Rest well, those who need to sleep.
Yes, please don't feel bad about needing to sleep.
I feel you.
This is called...
Shadows Hidden Grieve.
I think I can come here.
I'm pretty sure it just has cute...
No, my cute worm does.
Literally, the worms are so nice.
Oh my God, worm and gentoo?
Question mark?
Worm beach ever?
Wait, why are you smacking me?
I'm sure I heard it.
I went to do...
Would you still love a beach over if she was a worm?
Possibly.
I wonder where the reviews are so far so good.
Wait, is that the bottom of the map?
Or is that you can go even further down?
I don't see any enemies though.
If I spot an enemy, it means you can go down there.
You can go even further down?
Oh my God.
Oh, there's a statue...
Oh no, there's a church there.
I have terrible news, Reeflands.
I don't think...
I don't think you guys can come in.
You get there's that ravine there that I just completely avoided down the street.
It's a shite of heads.
Strong, poor heads.
Why can't I get Reeflands in them?
If I've not done it.
Oh, for goodness sake.
It's just that stupid thing where it's like, cancel.
Okay, that makes a lot more sense.
I was like, oh, you've not been in for a bit.
I was like, oh no, is everyone like unable to...
to get in?
But it says there's a nullify effect thing.
I didn't find out what you're using.
Thank you, gay Disney.
Did you not...?
Again, I'm so sorry.
I'm forgetting.
I'm not even able to write English anymore, seriously.
This list is getting out of hand.
Oh no, wait.
I did it wrong.
Oh no, did someone time out already?
How did you time out that fast?
Okay, we've got evil.
No, whoa, everyone's timing out.
What's going on here?
Can anyone...?
Okay, we've got one in.
It's like timing the fuck out.
I haven't done this yet, Montoya.
For evil reason.
I think it's just the neck.
I don't know what kind of fate we got ahead of us.
So we're going to do it.
Got hit by a connection sign or something.
Oh, there we go.
You both come in the same thing.
Are we ready?
Wait, are you telling us to go that way?
I realize we're going this way.
My bad.
I thought we were going to go where?
Where's the other one?
Where is the mariner guy?
Oh, no, I have to fucking respawn you.
Oh, yeah, couldn't, right?
We just got together.
Oh, Reeflings, I ask you kindly please leave so we can move to the next bit.
Hold on.
I'm going to readjust my cosy cover.
I'm getting ready to sleep.
We're doing a sleep stream, you guys, so listen to me for it.
I'm literally just people cosy and moat now.
It's over my head and everything.
Oh, I'm getting nice and calm.
Mommy's yawn.
I need to put it over me so I'm all nice and cool.
You need to charge my controller.
Can you guys come down here and then I summon you here?
Can we be that cheeky?
Can we be that deviant?
Okay, I'll see you at the bottom.
She says she doesn't see a summoning site.
Is this a boss site?
There's a grass, okay.
Are you disabled again?
Ah, fuck, let's see.
Don't you need to be on top to get the spoon?
I'm like trying to look.
I can see an enemy at the gravestone.
Where did I go? Up there?
Oh, if I go there to head, I'll knock them out.
I assume there's going to be a safe community there.
Oh, Torrent, how you keep me so safe?
That's too little bit of architecture.
Oh, did I pass it?
I'll tell you what, we'll go to the next one.
I think there must be something over here because the map's over here.
And the worms are friendly again.
Yeah, that's right.
You better be friendly again.
You stinky stinkerkin.
I like how their face is red.
Just show that they're not friendly.
Okay, let's see what we're looking at.
Okay, okay, so we are heading to the dead end.
So I assume that means like, oh, there's going to be a boss.
Let's see if we can get a save.
I do want a save site at this point.
Okay, at least there's one right there.
And then there's some angry worms over there.
Okay, let's go to this save site.
I can see this crab.
I need to get the map so I can continue to build.
Wow, the game doesn't let you progress.
Are these nectar blood virgins?
Okay.
How do I get to level up?
I actually have quite a lot.
I've got a new lesson.
Right, and then level up.
Okay, I do.
There's not too many of them.
The first six HP is rough.
Does someone say...
Is it arcane?
Is it intelligence to spray my crossbow?
I can't remember.
Or is it faith to spray the crossbow?
I don't know.
I mean, maybe just endurance.
Okay, I'll go back to Bale.
I didn't know about that drop down from up top.
No, no, no.
Arcane?
Maybe not arcane.
Alright, I'll just do endurance.
Why not?
Oh, someone says intelligence.
Magic.
That's not magic, defense up.
That's main.
Main does...
Oh, main does just like the do-do-do-do-do-do.
Okay.
Does shove in endurance then?
Does it really matter at this point?
No, when I go my reasons to look after me.
Okay, sorry.
Someone says teleport.
Go to the grand altar.
Now that we have the map,
we can grand altar of dragon communication.
Oh, communion, sorry.
Main is mana, so it's good for everyone,
not just me, just when I do my little ultimate.
I have no idea where you guys are taking me,
but dragon altar.
Come, come, come.
I'm just gonna pretend that's a good sound
and not at all the most dangerous sound ever,
like something like stomping around that's so humongous.
It takes like 20 seconds to stomp its other foot.
Wah.
Wait, you disconnect?
Right there.
Put away, look, put away.
I've actually got quite a few new ones there.
Let's switch it out.
I want to do the new one.
Uh...
Mm-hmm.
I want all mother.
What does all mother look like?
Oh, refling, oh, refling.
Please forgive me for being so bad.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, let's get enemy.
Shlumpling, were you in last?
I think Shlumpling, you came with us last time.
Okay, light the way.
Where the heck are we supposed to go?
But once...
I don't like that.
That sounds so ominous.
Wait, once the enemy refling comes in,
are we going up this way?
Okay.
Enemy refling's spawning in.
Oh, yes.
No way.
Let's go.
Right, follow the glowing refling in the distance.
Follow him.
For he's gonna lead us to success.
And he's gonna lead us to the end of me.
Oh.
That was definitely not to the song.
I would stay with me.
Na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
Oh my god, I completely forgot
I was gonna try and do parody songs.
Holy shit, I've like completely forgotten them.
Oh, I don't have the fail on me.
I'll leak my files on the members' stream, how about that?
I wanted to do a parody song
because last time we played Elden Ring, I got killed by One Thrust
and I was like, One Thrust is all it took
but you know that song is One Kiss is all it takes
and I was trying to write a fucking dumbass parody song of it
and I was like, One Thrust is all it took
and all the possibilities, it was so bad
but I came up with another one for Azura and Sheeby
and I don't know if it's gonna come out shit or not
it's like the most simple basic parody
but do you know the song?
Do You Like Waffles?
Do You Like Pancakes?
Do You Like French Toast?
It's Gonna Wait To Get Enough Of Waffles
Basically, I wrote a parody of that and it's hags
and it's like, Do You Like Hag Lips?
Do You Like Hag Lips?
Do You Like Hag Hips?
It's Can't Wait To Get Enough Of Hags
basically, but I've never recorded it or none
and I was gonna have it
that the music video has Azura and Sheeby fan art in it
Hag Love basically is the hook
so I need to make that
so I've been secretly pervading any Sheeby and Azura fan art
because I want to make that
and like I want like all the fan art to be shown off
and like oh special thank you
like we'll put like all the credit in the video and all that
I thought that would be really sweet
that would be so cool
Yeah, I had another one
and it was like a schizophrenia parody
that sounds really bad saying it out loud
but you know how like oh you have schizophrenia
because da da da da da
and then obviously I was like okay what's
oh I can't remember what the song parody is
oh it's that it girl
I T G I R L
it's an it girl parody
oh what does the song go like
A T I G I T G I R L
basically the song spells out a six letters
and then I was going to change it to get so like yeah
she's get so oh fuck I can't remember it though
what we're gonna have to manually claim
or do you guys have to get out
so I like I'm not kidding like I plan so much stuff in advance
I was gonna do like one parody song per month
just for the shits and giggles
and that hag one is probably the only one
that's actually even plausible for me to record at this point
the other what the fuck are you doing
what did you do to the shade
okay I need to go up
okay I understand I understand
and so I've got like one thrust is all it took for the reef
line I've got a hag love song
and and before someone like listen to this and steals it
and uploads it and be like no you can't prove it
you have to try again try again
fuck it up fuck it up
what a fucking view that was honestly
where are we at bridge
oh my god
um what an earth are we like walking towards
I can't remember any of the other parody songs I am
I am I made
I say made is basically someone else's
and like the melodies all there
I just swap out the words to whatever I want
but I guess that's what a parody is
look at me so hard
wait am I wait can I call you in here
why is there so much death here
huh
are people jumping off the map
nope well
for what
I
know I can't call anyone
made me to admit
you're on your own here
just stick to Torrent
and there should be a cavern up ahead
I hear a lot of noises I don't like
it's fucking dragons juking it out
you have to be shitting me
of course this dragon is juking it out
why wouldn't it be
where the fuck is this cavern
please be around the corner
so I don't see any of these dragons
of course it's not like it's easy
cavern cavern cavern de devern
I need a cavern
if they're fighting each other
don't you love it when the video game
has two enemies fighting each other
and then they both stop to fight
a random person on a horse that comes on by
honestly at adora
it's my favourite thing
I really wish more games
would constantly add that into the game
but how the fuck do I keep doing that
am I supposed to hit double A
double A
what?
am I being trolled?
she almost sounded like she meant to
I thought it was a flower
okay hold A
okay just hold A
I've been double jumping
you just fucking hell things getting orange
we're in Mexico now
is this the cavern?
this must be the cavern
looks like a little hidden secret up here
gotta go to the best of logs
thank you
okay so there's just multiple paths
I don't like this
I don't like this one but
keep going up
red spell loses sleep
thank you so much for helping us
I apologize
I apologize if you can
yeah let me just stick to work
does that just run her head?
does this go ahead?
left of the dragon
oh
sorry dumbass
nope
giddy up bullseye giddy up
giddy up torrent I am not kidding please
I am not kidding
whole ass
I'm not even looking behind me
don't look back torrent you don't want to know what's chasing us right now buddy
okay these are dead thank god
please be hella be the name
whoa whoa whoa
oh okay no
please
whoa is that what I'm hearing?
thunder strike?
god the sleep
you need more
I'm still on my man
is that real dragon over there?
I'd say follow the path there isn't one
hold on let me get a cheeky bird's eye view of what's going on here
okay don't go that way
can go that way
can go up the dead dragon way
oh no they're coming to get me
okay let's keep a giddy up bullseye
you've kept me safe this long torrent keep it up
keep it up
why is there so many dead dragons up here
maybe I
oh my god I need to stop asking questions
hold A
oh my god torrent
torrent oh jeez louise torrent
are you giving me a heart attack on purpose?
hmm
a reefling
another player made it down there
be wary of storm but still no dark end
hold on here
oh
left up
man this is getting steep
it sounds like a thunder battle out here
here
um
no I'm fine right
I'm going to go all the way back down the mountain
this is making me do a big math review so I'm
so crazy
track back a bit you can still get back up
oh okay
oh wait
can't be that I'll just go high
oh okay okay okay dumb dumb dumb dumb
sounds like crimson
okay okay let's try that again sorry sorry
I'm a bit special
right that went way back
okay let's not swing our sword again
jump
hold A
yo when can I summon you guys in?
this is getting a bit too intense for me
my heart rate shouldn't be too elevated
compared
yeah yeah yeah I'll sign I'll sign I'll sign
alright alright alright
okay
we're still going up
oh my goodness Taryn
aren't you oh my god please
please
let the reefling be with me
oh freeze the heavens I'm never being happy
you're here though
okay two
who's in last
oh I've sat down sorry
I've sat down I've sat down
I think you weren't in
and then it goes
that goes who
maybe?
is it just a fella?
no I'm
no I don't know
ready to die alive come on guys
let me just harvest these plants
with the girl I am
wait am I doing a heavy roll? no
no
okay let's see what this boss is anyway
oh lord it's a dragon isn't it
it's a dragon there's no way it's not
a dragon
absolutely no way
um
he's so big I don't think I can even
keep tracking on
he's so big
oh my god he's so big
a whole 700 damage look at me go
oh my god that tail is
so long to do
oh his wee wings are gone
they're just little spears now
oh for buddy
hope he gets bent
I'm gonna die it over
that looks good
oh wow
oh my god
I think we're out of our depth
Brooklyn
oh no I think we might be out of our
depth I'm like
oh my god he's only got one leg
he's like a wee amputee
of a dragon and every
wait does he only have one leg
or am I just making it up
he does
his wee per leg
oh my god
you know I'm actually doing pretty well
taking a whack from a dragon outside man
right his tail is in my face
of course I'm gonna hit it
not miss it
oh my god I'm way out of my depth here
Reefland
it's like impossible
to predict what he's gonna do
okay so he gets a bit
stuck when he does the fire
I can't even reach his little
meaty gammy leg
oh my god
literally disabling
disabling
bullying a disabled dragon
that feels so bad right now
I'm not sure how I feel about this
it seems awfully ableist to me
oh I'm getting cornered
well
I'm not sure we're gonna get past him
he's a dragon that tore
off
haven't seen gammy for a long time
he's grown this much
why is she so mad at ya
I have terrible news
I think we might have to do
something else cause
there's no way my pitiful
crossbow ball is gonna do a thing
maybe if I do blood damage
I'll just do bleed and then
if it's a dragon I guess I'll use
ace against the dragon
maybe that's how it works
that's how it totally works right
we can do it are you sure
I don't mean to be a doer
but that dragon
are you sure
I think it would be easier
to kill the bucket fire guy
honestly we got
bucket fire face to half
I mean I know that was just her first attempt
and I did pitiful but
I'm a bit insimidated ok
I'm a bit insimidated
we'll see what we can do
does anyone have spiral shard
what does that do
what does spiral shard do
let's see
I can't go in
we don't know if we can
I
didn't even hit him
nope but he's hitting me
ok maybe aim for his body
I'm not safe
easier just do this
manually aiming
it is I'm actually hitting him
more like this
oh for fuck's sake I'm in
I'm aiming for his butt
go to sleep go to sleep
tranquilizer tranquilizer
serpentine serpentine
does he even have sleep damage
I
is he going for me
I think he might have been
is that a glitch
what happens if I do A
I don't know
don't look at me
oh shit they're just doing ultimate
oh his wee legs
uh
ok ok hold on a minute
we're in the 60s
uhh
um
um um um um um um um um um um
Um, I think I've lost question mark.
Um, gonna be honest, we'll try it a few more times.
I think we're better going back to, um, little snake man.
I think our odds are better with snakes.
Everyone just exploded.
Yes, I definitely agree with that thing.
I think we're in trouble.
Let's see, let's see, I'll keep doing my bow and arrow bleed effect.
Um, I don't mind doing that.
Maybe do some dungeon exploring.
Yeah, I think if we can't do this, I wouldn't actually mind going back to, um, limb grave
and getting like loads of different coconuts and stuff so we can all talk.
I think Bailey and the 18 inches of mesmer are equal in terms of difficulty.
Oh, oh no.
Oh no, this can't be.
Um, if that's the case, I might be more tempted to do some like caverns and stuff.
Elsewhere.
Although, what do I need to do?
I just need to level up my stuff.
Oh, wow.
I need to go on fire resistance.
I didn't even get a moment to breathe.
Remember when that one guy said, really, la, na, la, was similar in difficulty, honestly.
How far into the DLC?
We've somewhat uncovered everything.
We're stuck at a few bosses, so don't think you're out of your depth.
We're currently trying to, I don't want to spoil it, so close your ears if you don't
want to spoiler, but, um, mesmer halt progression, bail is just optional.
Okay, wait, hold on, who, where or who is mesmer, where is he?
Where are you mesmer, you little shit.
Dark chamber entrance?
Maybe?
Dark chamber?
Okay.
We're going to see what we can do at dark chamber.
If this is like the story of like, oh, you're supposed to do this next, um, I don't even
know if I have the reaction time to be able to, um, move out of his way when he's the
one who's the one who's the one who's the one who's the one who's the one who's the
one who's the one who's the one who's the one who's the one who's the one who she's
He is just rapid fire I'm going for bleep sorry I accidentally did ace for a bit there that's
I like all the arrows staying in and I was actually kind of funny.
I dodge. Someone got a bleed on him. I don't know who it is but it's a team effort.
It's a team effort. Pincushion boss one and three. Right okay okay okay. He needs a minute
to get back off the ground. Okay we're not watching this. Why does he hate me so much?
I can't even comprehend what's going on I'm sorry I genuinely can. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no.
okay I think we can do it I think we can do it I think we can do it I have I have
faith I think you did go into his house and attack him I have faith I think we
can do it I just won't absolutely walk myself and myself right so I do have
the lead
this place is supposed to change I'm wondering
oh it's a dwelling arrow it's not easy oh I'll do poison and bleep
I'll do poison and bleep
we just in norm did you have a chance
men's room probably actually easier than bail with three people but all the
space one attack small space are relatively small and no area yeah I think we
can do it flinch files flinched flies what's this raises stamina boost fire
damage negation yeah I'm gonna put on that just because it's how unbelievably cruel
that guy is ready wow let me get out of the way so we just corner me with that
fireball
I still hit
wait I'll go for poison first I guess oh wait snake be poisoned I don't know if
snake are considered poisonable we'll find out shortly is he green
that is so terrifying that move
maybe we're to see
oh my god he just hammers and hammers and hammers
the fact I am still moving after that shows how tarnished or so OP
I
tried to bleed oh yeah you got it
it's not moving
just be careful I will skip the animation
okay I'm gonna skip the animation
oh and the attack stage of course the stage
hey we fling I can sure
there's an MCC helping us as well
trying to get bleak damage
I
and PC do you want to do anything
are the NPC no one rare which we fling had the dark moon
I think they may have gone asleep no
yeah Russian is your turn
I survived a party
He's not got a face on there, more hands to the love pick, even his mum and her despises.
Right, we're going for it.
We've got champions and stuff going on.
Right, let me move to the side and dodge this, should be the chart.
So, dodge it and then run away.
I can't do...
I actually can't do it, lol.
Fuckin' hell.
He's actually pretty...
Taking a decent chunk of damage from a weak book.
Can you not...
Can you not change enemy at the last second?
It really messes me up.
Sorry.
I think this might be the old, we need a mage type thing and then I'll try and take the aggro.
And then melee can try and stun.
Fuckin' hell, blind us in the middle of battle.
But in a humorous way.
Oh, he just changed up on that third refling.
Wait, am I alive?
Holy shit, I thought I was gone.
Oh, man.
Oh, I got crit!
Oh, shit, he got crit on me though.
Oh, no, he got me, I don't survive this.
Oh!
I think we can do it.
I think we can do it, we just need to compliment each other a bit more.
Oh, your hair's looking great today.
Oh, he switches so quick.
Literally the 5 M blow he does, he like swaps between 3 of us at one point.
I don't think he takes poison damage.
Back from my work and I say I believe in mommy and the refling.
I think this is the last one in me, like unironic.
Oh god, I can't remember, I didn't have...
I definitely didn't have you.
I feel like I had you in either, yeah.
This is definitely my last one.
My eyes are like fuckin' falling out of the sockets right now.
I'm sure we can bend from any direction too.
But I think we can do it, I think we can do it, we just do it.
Hiya!
I think we need any blessings?
Is that a blessing on us?
Any more blessings?
Let's do it, let's do it.
Did I just need a run this time?
Oh, I need to wait like a millisecond before I do the next roll.
Okay.
What are you doing?
I'm not focused enough for this.
Mommy's time.
Unironic then.
Oh frickin' just think I just healed up.
I need just another one and then...
Okay, there we go.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm trying to take the aggro, but it ain't happening.
Okay.
Azze, azze.
So I ain't gonna make it to the snake-flicking tier.
I don't know how I dodged that with no attempt to dodge that.
No, no, no, not like this.
Not like this, not like this.
I don't even think there's a Wikipedia on like, is he poison immune?
I don't think he's a poison immune as far as I'm aware.
Although I haven't seen poison go on him, so I'm gonna make a stop.
Maybe time for the crossbow.
Hopefully you aren't having nightmares of him.
It's interesting to see their attack pattern when you don't fight back.
Hopefully you aren't not.
Check.
Mm-hmm.
What are you saying?
Well, maybe use my crossbow bolt instead.
If I do my rapid-fire blood crossbow bolt, it causes rapid-fire crossbow, and then...
And I do... I can do scarlet rot, and do frost.
I think frost and baked shrilly.
I honestly thought it sounded like an alternate word, so I'm gonna be honest.
I didn't have you in the last fight.
Right.
I didn't have you in the last fight, and I didn't have you in the last fight, I'm pretty sure.
I'm a 9% sure.
Maybe 8%.
I messed up, I'm sorry.
No, don't be sorry.
We're just giving up playing him.
I'm having a good time.
I may sound tired.
Don't get me wrong.
I may sound exhausted, but it's nothing to do with the game, and it's nothing to do with these things.
It's just I've been having lack of a deep sleep.
And then I took medication to try and force myself to sleep, and it just was the nightmare.
Okay, dodge, wait, dodge.
Yeah, okay, dodge, wait, dodge.
There we go.
Okay, we're gonna use the ultimate.
We're gonna miss everything in the ultimate, but that's okay.
Okay.
I'm wondering if everyone needs to wear the fire talisman to negate more of his attack.
Okay, we're gonna...
Miss all the walls.
I just did the bleed.
Oh.
And just like that.
And then there should be another attack and another.
Oh.
Oh, shit, the NPC.
Maybe I should bring them in.
Sorry, hold on.
Let me bring in the NPC to take the heat off of everyone a bit.
It's such cold summon.
Oh, I can't.
Only when a frickin' refland is down...
Okay.
Too early.
I'm missing.
I'm actually gonna heal.
Did we get sneak fees?
I did not expect that switch.
Oh, no, skipping.
Please, thanks for not getting me.
Crazy.
Sorry, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
I just need to apply a few bleeds, so that's all I need.
Yeah, they're trying me.
Okay.
It seems like the snake, when the snake goes up, you need to delay your dodging.
This part, I don't know about dodging.
Okay.
I need to heal.
We just can hardly do any damage on them.
That's the problem.
Oh, I'm out.
Jesus, I'm out of bleeds.
I'm applying cross, whether or not it's gonna achieve anything is a different story, but...
Fuckin' hell.
It's a barrage.
This has to be his ultimate.
This has to be the ultimate.
There is nothing more he can do.
That's ridiculous.
He cannot have another ultimate in him.
Oh, but he does.
He's summoning them at will.
Yeah, I don't think I can apply cross to this guy.
Okay, let me go up and dodge.
Oh, wow, I thought I had that.
I thought I had that nailed.
Maybe not.
Oh, he's still going for me.
Shit, sorry, I thought he was gonna change.
Seems like cross damage is applied on him.
He's just bleeding.
Wait, did we tell her?
What, he doesn't...
That was a good attempt.
Can someone give mommy a physical shield?
You can do a shield and crossbow.
Wait, hold on, I might need to pull it some equipment.
It's apparently so, but I don't believe you.
I couldn't land full on everything.
No, I'm not.
I don't seem to think I have a stroke.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, crossbow works one-handed down this part.
But the EI becomes so weird with the part.
Chat, what'd I get from Willy?
You eat an entire chicken to yourself?
Honestly?
Willy's chicken to all of us.
I don't think he even...
I've never seen him get fucking...
I can see him get blood loss.
I've never fucking seen him get bloody frostbite.
Well, I'll just try anyway.
I don't think he can get frostbite.
Willy's...
There's fire on them.
Meteor has...
Attack power magic.
Is he susceptible to magic?
He's like, skinny...
He's skinny mainly.
And he's magic himself, so why would he?
I'm trying my Willy Ricans, I'm trying.
I'll look if I have a shield to go.
Yeah, crossbow's gonna let the shield go down.
I have a shield to go down.
Okay, I have a shield, hold on.
Maybe a little bit?
I'll let him do that one.
Uh...
Maybe a little bit?
I don't know.
There's some dirt that we have.
Wait, so what happens if I shield?
Oh wait.
I don't think I'll do that, sorry.
I'm just gonna put that one in there.
What'd that do?
Okay, the Ricans are trying to help.
He's not had a shot.
Or is everyone...
Oh, you've not had a shot.
It boosts my damage.
Okay.
Honestly, I'm tempted to...
Do you have to try this one?
I don't think it's gonna work.
Radar Arrow is good.
Radar Arrow?
Radar, yeah.
Hi!
This is Radar?
But, who read that wrong?
Radar Arrow is so good.
I'm so sorry.
I'm losing my ability to read and speak and think
and do anything pretty much at the same time.
Okay, are we ready?
I don't know about the shield.
Okay, like that.
Wow.
I've never used the shield before.
I'm gonna be honest.
Oh, Radar's Arrow.
Oh my God, sorry.
You're correct in yourself.
Right, let him come in.
Oh, I was fartily on the pause there.
Uh...
What the fuck?
Wait, I can't rapid fire over the crossbow now.
Uh, I mean, I guess.
Oh, this guy is not getting around.
How about I stop?
Another lie.
That kinda hurt.
That kinda hurt kinda.
Oh, I'm getting things off.
Oh, blue crab.
Yeah, I'm healed up.
Fuck me.
I don't know how to manage that one.
Oh, wait, sorry.
Flash me.
The only reason I'm putting that away for now is to fucking...
Oh, shit.
I missed everything.
Okay.
Ah.
I don't know what to do.
Got hurt, weaselings.
I think mommy's all it is.
Stop fucking with me.
She about lasted me again.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Wait, we tried to miss.
You have to buy them, but they're only good to go with.
Wow, is there any way we can explore, maybe?
Maybe we go explore instead.
There was that weird bit down here.
This!
I wanna...
I see purple on the map, so I'm gonna go down here.
How do I go down here?
I can't remember.
I don't think there's a safe safe here.
I don't know.
Oh.
I discovered all of that.
I think they need it.
Um...
Am I gonna go down this way?
It looks like there's a little path.
If I somehow make my way down there,
if I somehow go there...
Why not really?
There's some.
I hide in a clutch shield that needs strength.
Do you want it?
I don't know if I'm gonna use shields.
I'm absolutely married with them.
Or does it just boost my defense overall?
Like, I don't have to do anything special with them.
Or, like...
I've never parried an attack.
That's what I'm trying to say.
So...
I'll tell you what.
I might go here,
and then raid my wee horse all the way up this river,
and see what's going on over here.
There's a ladder you have to get down there.
It's on the bridge before the storehouse.
There's a secret coffin in the castle
that fast travels through to the desert.
The castle we've already cleared.
Go to storehouse first.
Do you think?
One second.
Oh, alright.
Wait, horse.
First floor.
Storehouse first floor.
I don't know if I can call you guys in there.
I don't know if I can tell you in there.
I'm sure I can.
Like, fucking God, I can.
I don't want to be undone the Samoan.
Okay, we're in storehouse first floor.
And you guys are going to get...
Samoan.
Is that you?
That's you.
Okay, okay, it's you.
Hold on.
There's a coffin in the storehouse.
I think it might be your turn.
I don't know.
How are you making even more noise?
I think.
I'm so sorry, I can't remember the order anymore.
Puddlefish and asparagus.
Wait.
Is that a South Park?
What do you want me to eat?
Puddlefish and asparagus or something like that?
Are we ready?
Hello, thank you for coming to my service.
Okay, let me put my sword on.
Sit wet all over the house with sword if you're not sure.
Okay, let's go.
I'm on my way.
Sit wet all over the house with sword if you're not sure.
Why is he keeping that?
Okay, you perish.
We're not having anything.
Get your poise out of here.
Let's not pretend you didn't have any poise.
Break him.
Break this man.
Okay, I'm out of stamina.
We're going to break him now.
Whoa, get in jump with the reef.
Get in jump with the reef.
Get in the reef.
Okay, they don't have much.
Like hold the rope.
Still a rip pickle.
Check and see if we can move.
We man ready to jump me go.
Oh shit.
Whoa, why?
God, he's actually so small.
I can't even hit him.
I wish I had that helmet.
Don't fall in the water.
Careful when you put a light on.
If you darken this cistern.
You don't need to get that hat.
Oh my god, this is so fun.
You should make a game about going deeper into the earth.
And you just get to slide around and stuff.
Oh, picture.
What do you do?
Hello, Mr. Picture.
Domain of dragons painting.
Curious.
Fake wall.
I'm just so good at it.
Could you guys see that that was open?
Because you've already been here before?
I'm just checking there's nothing behind us.
I don't trust this game.
Oh, we do the coffin again.
Oh my god, it's the coffin of Ali, Andy and Lily.
The hit tool.
Wait.
Oh, it doesn't let me interact when you guys are here.
I was going to say let's all fit in at the same time.
And whatever happens, pass it.
But we can't open it.
Oh, I've got a little mantat.
Rest in the coffin.
The one bit of sleep I've had this entire journey.
I did enjoy it in the game though.
I assume the tarnish knew it was going to fall and the tarnish wasn't just like,
oh, I'm going for the wee nap, right?
Surely.
Surely the tarnish knew it was going to fall down and not just be like, oh, where am I?
I mean, I'm probably that daft, but...
Let's start some.
See him a mile off.
I don't exactly what the model does.
Yeah, I know they've returned to their world.
You boot them out, you twats.
All right, there's a suit thing here.
Wow.
Wait, I'm heavy rolling.
What did I change?
Wait, am I going crazy?
Why am I heavy rolling?
Oh, because of the shield.
Get that one.
Get that shield.
Okay, there we go.
Wait, I can't come on the new area.
What do you just mean to do?
Oh, we're right in front of the thing!
We try to make it if there's an enemy over there.
Well, let me put a finger down here.
Put a finger down if you sucked my boyfriend out at the back of Denny's or whatever that
by room was, I can't remember.
I have just discovered what the boss fate is here.
Um, this...
I mean, can I scoot past and get to a safe point under his crotch?
Oh, look, it's like that fire giant destroyed.
Oh, sorry, I thought that was where to go.
I promise I'm not just being a weirdo.
I genuinely thought that was where I was supposed to go.
A furnace visage, which means fire face.
A visage just means face in French.
I can hear a few cries.
I don't know why they're crying though.
I'll give them something to cry about.
Something's attacking me.
Something's stomping about.
And a cave? Oh, is it dragons up there that are fighting?
Oh!
What was that?
I don't know what that was.
Sorry, I got such afraid. I'm sorry if I scared anyone in that.
There's savings like that building?
I will give you something to cry about.
It's just like my mama.
Oh, there's another...
Give me that. Fuck out of this area.
How'd I get out? I'll just go straight down.
Bye!
It was lovely visiting. No, really, it was.
I had a fantastic time.
It was gorgeous. Scenery 10 out of 10 would recommend for a tourist spot.
Do not mind at all.
You were literally submerged in water.
You're not telling me.
You're like Charimander, sorry, but as soon as you're retail, doesn't it work?
You know, your clogs are popped.
I didn't make the rules, mate. I didn't make the rules.
I still can't summon you guys.
Me when I can't follow you.
And so that Ryan Gosling meme where he's got his like hand or fist or whatever.
And then put my wee hair on it and just feel like when...
...Strony can't spawn in the reefing to carry her through every single game ever.
Through every single game she ever plays.
Where are you from, okay?
Yeah.
I'm sort of a weird, creepy boo.
Come on. Am I just exploring the reefing?
What am I doing? I don't actually know if I'm achieving anything.
I'm mucking around here.
What the?
Mercy when she plays a fucking third-person game.
Right, she was such a good spot. Holy crap.
I'm glad she wasn't sick though.
If you didn't know, I played an untitled duck game.
A goose game with a mercy.
But she has severe motion sickness and the camera angle would not stop twisting.
It was such a shame.
We almost finished it.
But she did this burp and you could tell it was an ono kind of burp.
That was definitely an ono.
Sit down, sit down, sit down, sit, sit, sit, sit.
I'm getting fucking...
I'm actually gonna die. I'm ironically gonna die.
Why can I not sit down?
Because there's fucking enemy... I'm actually gonna die.
I'm actually gonna die because I'm so bad at this game.
Sit down.
You have to be kidding me.
Oh my god.
Don't ever.
Right, what we're doing here?
I don't know what we're doing here, but I'm just happy you guys can come.
Oh my god.
I'm already sitting, literally.
Sean is gonna be at the store and get into an awkward position and try to summon some reflin to help her.
I'm actually not that awkward in person.
So because I have an accent, people actually strike up a lot of caught...
Wait, is this a reflin?
That was a reflin, right?
It wasn't an MPC.
Sorry, we're at a place called Reclusus River Dunstrin.
Oh there you guys are.
Who hasn't been in...
Yeah, you've only recently came on, I think.
I'm not sure.
I'm so sorry.
Again, I'm sorry.
I've had naysleep.
I've had about what?
Five hours of sleep?
No, not even five hours.
I'm being a cheeky cheekerton, doing back-to-back Elden Ring because I want to.
Like, I wasn't...
Yesterday, I was like...
I don't feel stressed when I stream.
I feel so happy.
I don't have to worry.
Or anything.
Or on stream.
As soon as I click offline, it's like...
Oh my god.
Is there any enemy reflin?
Oh sorry.
Obviously better tonight.
I suspect I am most likely gonna do what's called a crash.
And I'm gonna get all my flops in.
Oh, can I not get an enemy reflin here?
Oh, I can, I can.
I heard it, I heard it.
Who's not been in...
Norm, I think...
Is it Norm?
Oh no, I can't remember.
Norm, did I have you in recent life?
Oh, I can't remember.
I like the path in here.
It's fun that enemy reflin is most of the time the torch car.
It literally tells me where I go.
I'm happy when you stream.
Yeah, it feels good, man.
Five hours is no sleep.
I've been average 4.5.
That must be an insomnia diagnosis.
Because there's no way...
If you have insomnia diagnosis, that's different.
I normally have 10 hours sleep.
Unfortunately, I have not been getting that, but...
Let's just go.
Meh, weh, weh, weh.
Boo-hoo.
Can't get 10 hours sleep.
I'm fine.
Oh, wait, no.
I thought that was a reflin that just went flying there.
Okay.
Nice and slowly.
Easy does it now.
Easy does it.
No one's trying to be a hero.
We don't need a speedrun.
Nice and easy.
Hey, kiddies!
Man, mosquitoes.
I've never fricking had problems with mosquitoes.
Because there's no such thing as a mosquito in Scotland.
They don't even...
They can't handle the climate.
Alright, let's just move on.
This thing going fucks up.
I'm irresponsible sleepers,
so I usually get sick the most every night and weekend.
I'm so jealous of people that...
Oh, Jean, that lets them get by with two...
Oh, well, it's really bad for their health,
even if they don't feel it.
Dry leaf roll.
Oh, what does that look like?
I assume it's all going to be worse for me.
Oh, I'm going to look like Melinda.
Me, listening to the reflin spite in the background.
What got me?
Oh, these biggest slugs have so much HP.
Hold on.
Right, let's move on.
Sorry, let's move on.
Let's get out of here.
The slugs are too much.
That's too much HP.
I'll change my weapon a second.
Oh, look like the oogie-boogie man.
Oh, I missed.
Wait, don't disappear, Mr. Beetle.
I need you.
Stop it.
I need you, Mr. Beetle.
Oh, I'm not that handy.
Oh, somber something.
Okay.
Once we're out of here, I'll change my outfit back,
because this is not quite what I'm looking for.
That looks pretty cool, though.
That looks exactly like one of them.
There's no such thing as a Miss Ketwin Scotland.
This reflin looks in Louisiana.
It's going to be bumped up on the list.
Of reflings to import?
That's hilarious.
I wonder if you've got enough bones to bump your sword to ten.
I probably could.
Oh, okay.
It's a boat.
Hold on.
Let me put my good stuff back on.
I was a lion's head with armor.
That scares me.
I don't know what's ahead.
You're freaking me out, right?
I'm doing a medium roll.
Let's go.
Oh, I can't get past her.
Okay, let's see what's behind door number one.
Okay, it's a crypt fight.
Okay, it's a skinny blood katana.
But when I'm on skinny blood katana, I do a tiddlywinker damage.
I do a wee tiddlywinkle.
Is that a button?
A fucking tiddlywink, honestly.
Right, I don't need fire resistance at the moment.
Just give me a stamina, I guess, one more.
There's a refling on standby.
I can't believe you would underestimate the skinny.
Honestly, I saw the long katana and I was like, okay, skinny bleed build, bruv.
They were not kidding when they were like, ah, by the way, this game's a wee bit harder.
Did I just have you both then?
Norm?
Look at me.
Sorry, I'm just going to push right now.
I hope the boss doesn't have poise, damn straight.
You better not.
Okay, here's the thunder.
Are you ready?
Are you steady?
Oh jeez.
Good luck.
See, that charm, that was actually me, that wasn't the thing.
Okay, let's try that again, the same as the apps again, bloateroo, the upgrade.
Hold on.
What's the plan?
Abracadabra.
Swinging.
You're allowed to swing.
I'd rather you didn't, but that is the bit.
Poise.
Refling, no.
Okay, the poise is breakable.
I think we all need to go in heavy, but I'm out of fricking...
I'm out of stamina, holy crap.
I'm like completely out of stamina when I'm trying to...
Oh, at least.
Okay.
Hardly any poise, which is good, but I need to back off because I'm out.
I need to back off because I'm out.
I need to recover the stamina.
Alright, so when I slam down any other time, she gets close chance,
but when I do it that one time, she doesn't aim right, okay.
Better scratch her a minch and fucking take a sniff
because she's got bigger fish to fry than fucking me, hen.
Raging.
Actual raging.
I'm too tired to have my angry voice on me.
Okay, are we got heavies?
Okay, I need you to back off.
Okay, I need you to be heavy.
That was a good try, though, now. Like, we're 100% gold.
I'm just fucking being straight, so...
We don't really have many cork brooches in most places in Scotland, either.
Yeah, I've never actually seen a cork brooch in Silicon to Australia.
Not fun.
That Scottish trash talk was actually kind of crazy.
Literally, she's got a badly packed kebab, fucking axe wound looking ass.
Honestly, it's trailing halfway out the door, hen.
If she jumps up and down, her fanny flaps clap.
Like, fuck off, honestly.
Okay, let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's do it again.
Let's do it.
Alright, I have points. Fuck your points.
You're shit.
We're just fucking going for it.
No, I need...
And don't get me started about your family tree. It's a fucking circle, mate.
That doesn't make any sense.
Maybe it does.
No, wait.
Why is it your family tree looks like a...
Is it? Your family tree looks like a circle?
If it's all been...
Hey, that's what I meant. That's what I meant.
And...
And I'm...
Did I not just summon you, or am I getting memory loss now?
I think I'm starting to get memory loss.
Oh, your family tree is a fucking reef.
Ah, that's what it is.
Someone put some...
You're found.
I'm dead.
Alright, let's try it again.
Alright, how about we... We've got our own fucking...
Weakening Kitana, but we...
Like, don't you mind those?
Okay, you're blessing yourself.
That's fine. You're allowed to bless yourself.
Fuck you. No poise.
No talent.
No skill.
Shit.
Masterful blade.
Bastard.
Honestly.
No way!
Okay, I think I'm gonna try and upgrade this sword next.
Cause...
I think I have what I need for it.
Oh my god, I'll...
I literally cannot be hit twice.
That's insane.
I literally cannot be hit twice in a row, or I'm gone.
No way she has heals!
That's against the fucking rules!
Alright, I need back walls on boots.
Okay, hold on.
Fucking get cornered, honestly.
Ah!
Ah, as if she's healing.
Is that even a heal, you really?
Ah, I'm out of stamina. I'm gone.
I don't even think I can dodge.
I can hardly even dodge to heal!
Fuck me, man.
I need to heal!
So when I jump, she hit...
Oh, cause she's bloody faster than me by a pixel.
Good news.
Strongly, my sister is pregnant. I'm gonna be the father.
No, no, you're not supposed to do that part.
That part isn't supposed to happen.
He cleaned us up with an ash of war.
When he does the stomp, he goes into super armor and can't be staggered.
Is that what it is?
You've not had a shot.
I placed my Sane, but I don't know...
I don't even think it's a Sane.
Have you had a shot? If you've not had a shot, I think...
Okay, these guys have had a shot.
I know we can do it like sauce. We can like a hundred percent do this.
Are you telling me like we can take down like incredibly massive bosses
and this wee skinny rat sitting in a fucking cat comb,
like a somewhat weird and festive little scurry and about.
We can't deal with that. No, sorry, I don't believe it.
I don't believe it.
I didn't believe it.
Let's try again.
I just have had more infinite stamina.
Honestly, I'm like, if I shove it all in your...
Do you use the light snows? Okay, we've been blessed.
Mate, you... fuck you.
I missed.
I missed horribly wrong.
I'm actually really wrong.
Careful of whatever her freaking Ash of War is,
so don't all get too close or else we're all gonna get walloped.
Oh, that was a good one. I like that. Do that again.
I'm actually gonna still heal because I don't trust it.
How does that man...
Holy shit, I don't know what you're doing, but yeah, damn.
I'm gonna make sure I'm full health because I do not trust.
Neatly...
I don't know about stamina.
I don't know.
Sorry, I'm very low stamina. I'm trying.
Fucking not regenerating because I'm jumping about the place.
Like a kangaroo.
Oh, that was bloody good timing that.
I'm worried about her sword art. I don't know when she does it.
Like, I'm getting nervous.
Oh my god, you're like fucking nothing at all about the thing.
That's actually kind of funny.
She's like just trying to get one looking.
I hope I make back off the wall.
Okay, she's out of heals. She's just showing us she's out of heals.
I don't know how I did that one, but I'll take it.
I'm young.
Nice.
Okay, I need to back off the wall because it's not gonna fucking hit if I'm against the wall.
That candlestick is unironically the candlestick is in the way.
Dude, I was gonna jump and attack, but who's gonna win?
Oh, I knew we could do it.
Thank you.
Did we even get anything to that?
Oh, we got armor. Holy crap. What kind of armor?
Check it out.
Shit.
Is it like a lay armor? It must be samurai armor, I guess.
I mean, I guess.
You took two turns to smash her? Yeah.
See, Kenneth is like actually mildly fair.
Then it's like, yeah, I'll put my time until like actually dodging and shit.
But Ken, when it's just like, or you need to like hack a billion diamonds, it's like, bro, you only got time for that.
Oh, okay.
I'm literally getting the more benefit than this.
Right, so we're done.
Is there more? No, wait, there's a giant out there.
Oh no, I have eye strain in my left eye. Are you kidding me?
Sorry, I'm looking around right now.
I have left strain in my left eye for some-
It left strain. I have eye strain in my left eye for something.
Are you joking me? Come on.
Where is it? Where are they? Oh, come on. We've only got one fucking hour left.
I'm just gonna relax.
I need to put a little plaster on my eye.
I need to do a mercy. Hold on.
When you soap the boss like that, it's kind of hot.
Okay, angry.
Oh, I just got all of them.
Right, so that was something.
Where else did you check in?
Okay, that was that, but I couldn't summon you guys in.
I assume if I summon you in here, there's no way the game's gonna let his wolf all the way to that giant to try and get the giant?
You ever wish you could like fake angry?
I feel like there's a word for it too, but I'm too interested in-
Like be an actual angry person?
I think it's just within your personality, I guess.
I always grew up like, you know, you're polite, you're quiet, you keep to yourself, like that kind of thing.
Can't summon us anywhere near there.
Oh, bro, why would they give such a big fight then?
The game's so rude, right?
I'm just gonna go here and then take my- oh no, the horse doesn't go up there, it in.
The best I can do is the water.
No, it's kind of- I think I'm stuck.
Recruits?
River downstream grade.
Someone take her behind the cat.
Well, act angry if they're actually being angry to get whole angry thoughts in.
Oh!
Act in it, yeah.
She says it's her voice size.
Um, yeah, like, no, I can like, if you want to give me a sentence, I'll try my best to say it.
I might be cringe because I'm exhausted right now, but yeah, I can definitely act angry.
Like, oh, I'm fucking reasonable.
It sounds so sarcastic because, like, it's not me saying it right now, but you know.
If you want to take the map, you have to go to the ruins of the North.
I'm taking what holds the benefit of low-energy angry mummy.
I'm at your region.
You will be looking after yourself.
I'm not even at the point of anger where I'm shouting at you, Reefling.
I'm at the point of disappointed anger where I have told you over and over again to look after yourself.
And yet, you keep coming back to me and you keep explaining to me that you don't feel well and something's not working out.
Like, that's probably emotionless as a tag for a reason.
Oh, I can definitely do emotionless right now, so I'm exhausted.
Sorry.
There's a boss in Six Sacred Fragments behind the castle.
This castle?
No, that's a room.
The shadowy castle?
Mmm.
Yeah, probably do emotionless right now.
Having someone disappointed at you is so much worse than just being angry.
Bro, tell me about it.
When I started my job at my cafe, I accidentally left a bin's out, but I didn't close them.
And Seagull's fucking ripped the bag open in the back door.
And my boss was like, strongy.
I'm not mad.
I'm just disappointed because you knew better.
And I was like, I'm so sorry.
Like, I completely forgot.
Somehow disappointed anger is way worse.
I thought I'd try my best to take you back to yourself, but when you're disappointed in me...
When she's not angry, she's disappointed.
Yeah, shadow keep.
There's a wall in the store room you can go through.
Shadow keep.
Shhh, shhh, shhh, shadow keep.
There's a wall in the store room you can go through.
Maybe for score, high, high, high, high, high, high, high.
Strongy, you just perfectly imitated my mom.
That was funny.
It's probably uncomfortable.
Hello, strongy.
Hello, cha.
Hello.
How's it going?
I'm very low energy.
We're just talking about how I can be like a scorny mother, basically.
But instead of being angry because I'm like low energy,
I just sound like a disappointed mum.
So how's force floor?
I would guide you, but I'm not.
Oh, I'm no home right now.
Oh, does anyone know what he wants me to do?
Maybe if we do some exploring, we'll find a way.
If you want to go out to get that boss, you need to go to the sun center.
I'll sink your church.
I'll be your church.
You can sink in my church.
If you want to go to that boss, you need to go to the sun center.
Wait, this one?
No, wait.
The ruins of...
I know, I'm sorry.
Or is this the sun center?
Or is this the red...
No, this is a fucking castle.
Shadooke, shadooke, shadooke, there's a shadooke,
There's a shadooke, shadooke, shadooke, shadooke, shadooke.
Shadooke Mingi.
Actually, would seagulls be considered our enemies or natural enemies because we're calamari?
Thank you.
Oh, is this one of them boxed with things where I kind of call you then?
Was it this way?
If I'm getting it wrong.
Bruh!
Imma wait for my reference for a freaking millisecond, please!
Have some mercy!
Go to church district entry gate.
I'm so sorry, I don't know this.
I can't believe it.
Go to church district entry gate.
Right, I'm fucking doing a complete wrong place.
See, this is what you have to put up with when you're a streamer.
Church district high road.
Church district entrance.
Sunken chapel.
Do you want me in the end?
I'm so sorry, I'm absolutely losing the floor.
I'm sure I'll wake up tomorrow and I'll be completely on board.
Exactly what to do for right now.
Oh, you want me to go to sunken chapel?
Sorry.
Sorry?
No, what are we doing in sunken chapel?
What will we do with sunken chapel?
What will we do with the sunken chapel?
What will we do with the sunken chapel early in the morning?
He won up, he rises, he won up.
I swear to God if you say I can't spawn anyone in.
Imma ask for a refund at it and I'm not actually.
I'll just be a big girl.
Oh, and you can upgrade my sword as well actually.
I need to thanks you for saving me.
Alright, now that I'm here.
There's some sort of exit.
Is it?
What is this?
I don't know what this is.
Wait, there's a fucking summoning thing.
Strony, when you're in the, if you press Y, you bring up the list of the...
Oh my God, that's a good spot.
What am I doing here?
I don't know.
Can you switch that?
How many DLC both of you?
Have you perished too far too many?
I'm absolutely terrified when the reflins can't help me.
Come on, you have to tell me there's like an enemy in here.
There's no way.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, I don't have my reflins.
No.
Should I just grab the items?
You know, I'm just grabbing the items.
No, no, no, no.
Can I even grab the items?
I can't even grab the room! I'm pillaging the remains! Any pillagers! I'm a pillager! I'm pillaging for sombers with worms!
Oh, there's two psalms. Get me out of here.
He's too big to fit through these doors. Close the doors. Close the doors behind me.
Ring the guards. Ring the guards.
Fuck me. Is there enemy?
Oh, fuck me! It gets worse! It gets worse! It gets worse! It gets worse!
When the reeflings aren't around, it gets even worse!
Okay.
You should seek to find a safe location.
Safe.
Safe?
Do these doors safe?
Okay, safe enough. I can just hide here. Right. What am I doing?
In the building with the flaming zombies, there's an elevator if you hug the right.
This?
Did I find it suspiciously?
Did I find it by accident?
I think I found it by accident.
No, that's not it. Okay, my apologies.
Wrong one. It was a 50-50.
Woah.
I'm so brave. I can do it.
Just go dead ahead. Surely just dead ahead and I don't have to think.
I don't have to say anyone.
Excuse me, pardon me, come through.
Excuse me, pardon me, come through!
Hug the right? You're not the right. Hug the right?
You're a statue. Hug the right?
Wait, what the heck? Why are you doing it like that?
Hug the right?
If you go past them and then to your left.
And then there's an elevator to the right.
You're right! Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Safety, safety. We go there in the end.
Motherfucker.
Fuck!
Fuck! I'm actually gonna have to do a fight?
Or can I just, like...
Can I just run ahead and there's like a thing or something?
Just keep running.
No button.
Shh, shh, shh.
If I make a break for that. No, there's an empty wall. There's no jump.
There's no fucking jump.
You went too far.
Shh.
There is a red enemy back there.
I can handle it. I can handle it.
Fuck.
I hate gaming on my own.
Oh my god, I can't do it. Holy shit.
I think I did it. Please no more surprises.
I can't handle it. I can't handle any more of that.
I knew I could get a damage bonus if I sneak that.
Which I'm glad I got it.
Oh my god.
Is there a safe thing and you guys can come in again?
Holy crap, this map. Why is this game so big?
Seriously.
Normally it's like, oh, why is this game so small?
There's not enough content.
Look how high, what elevated we are.
I cannot imagine the elevation difference.
What the fuck am I doing here?
Okay, where now?
Go left, and what happens when I go left?
Then up the ladder. Left and up the ladder.
Ladder, ladder, ladder, ladder, ladder, ladder.
Oh, the relief.
The fucking relief that watches over me seeing this.
Oh lord.
Oh lord, the relief.
Why can't I just have that all the time?
Why can't you just give me that all the time?
Goodness, gravy. How can he handle that?
My wee heart.
Oh, literally, an assassin is creeped up here.
Do not be detected by any nearby enemies.
Is there any other reefling that has this one?
It's called the storehouse back section.
Oh, don't let it happen again.
Oh, there's just moustaches in there.
They're back together.
Good morning.
Wakey, wakey.
Dude, lovers.
We're bitten from one another.
Our people face them.
And the mountain debates them apart.
I said that wrong.
Is there no other reefling that can join in right now?
It's okay.
If not.
Stranny, I don't like seeing you scared,
but you're actually giving me one.
Damn, it's fucking terrifying.
Why is there a mark on this right here?
I don't know.
My sign is done.
I'm not sure where I am.
Have you done something?
Are you in New Game Plus?
And the mountain fights them apart.
I'll give it.
You have 20 more seconds, Mr. Symbol,
to show up, or we're claiming that ladder.
I'm hunting for the symbol.
Do you think?
Right, hold on.
Let's do this.
Oh.
You smell like you need food.
And I'm the only one that can give you food.
What?
I got a katana.
Well, I don't like her katana.
The lift gets a real gunner.
Wow.
Didn't you want to go to sleep like six hours ago?
Maybe.
After moaning about a coconut?
Oh, right.
The moaning coconut.
I don't know why I can't see.
Oh, is it your turn now?
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
Let's do the test.
Hold on to the test.
A bit sway, rather pungent, but that'll do.
Um, I don't know why I need the symbol to show up, but it's not having it, right?
Let's claim these ladders and maybe something a little better.
Why is it blue?
Why are you blue?
Is it any blue?
Right, there's one enemy there, but I think he likes it a lot.
Wait, do you guys want to go first?
Please, gentlemen, first.
If the others know the way they can show you that pelvis along the table, demolish.
How does she know?
Jiggle, jiggle, jiggle.
Oh, we're still one.
Are we still one?
Yeah, we are still one.
Sorry, I thought it was one of those ones where it's like, it's optional to get off here if you want to grab some weird obscure item that no one knows about.
And it does some weird obscure thing that no one knows about.
Oh, something's going on up here.
Are you not two holding the handle?
Oh, it's the handle?
Okay, let's go.
Oh, stagger.
Low toys, don't care.
Don't talk to me.
Go home.
Back to the urge tree to you.
What's that?
You need a mile lower of the game?
Kind of.
Sometimes, not on the plane.
We can't jump up on that.
That's okay.
Are you getting ready to slap those two there and all?
I'm picking up fire serpent.
There is a window there.
Is this dangerous?
There's a window.
MGA?
What's MGA?
Metal Gear Solid?
I've actually never played this series.
Is it good?
I just thought people memed on it a lot.
Here.
Okay, I'm not jumping that way.
Wait, you'd love it?
With the politics in the game?
Stop!
Would that, actually?
You'd love that game, why?
Because of the politics.
Oh, okay.
It's nonstop tinfoil.
Stop!
Can I put tinfoil hat if you play it?
Is there any reefling that can come here?
Oh, no.
What?
Can't even open my map.
Oops.
I missed my rage.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait.
My other right is there.
I don't know why I don't know.
You're lucky I caught it that time.
And before there's symbol appears back there.
I don't think there is one.
My lady.
Wow, this is big.
It's literally about a secret shadow.
Shadow government that runs the world.
Oh, I like that.
I hear something.
Gentle, gentle.
We need to be careful.
Call me a rabbit because I need to be near here.
Um, um, um, um, um.
Wait, isn't it like that?
Um, the magic place and the main map.
What do you mean?
It's a mildly the same.
Okay.
Does anyone have long range other than my shitty crossbow?
I don't think I count.
But I need these guys.
These guys are going to like sonic rumors off the damn thing.
I need, wait, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
There's like, there's an enemy like right there.
Where are you going?
I don't know why the enemy did that.
Are we to turn back?
No, there's an enemy over there.
How did you do that?
Did you jump?
Be honest.
Oh, I didn't like that.
I don't know, but don't let me do that again.
Uh, uh, hold on.
I need to get this thing.
No!
Are you fucking serious and getting wall banged?
Aren't I ironically getting wall banged?
Are you joking?
I need...
Hi.
I'm so sorry, Reflin.
Oh.
Well, someone's mad.
I need to be careful.
Oh, they can see me from here.
Oh, Reflin, I don't...
That's exactly what I was worried about.
Tell you who.
No, Reflin, you're in the way.
Oh, darling, you're in the way.
Careful.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Sorry, darling.
You were to just leave at once.
I have no idea what this item is, but yeah, damn.
It better be worth the heart attack.
I'm not sure what you are, darling.
What are you?
Oh, right.
Okay, I'll hold on a minute.
Am I still getting wall banged by that wizard?
Is he losing at me?
Wait, where'd you go?
Reflin?
Did you go down the ladder?
Hello?
Hello, gay?
Reflin?
Hello?
I literally cannot see you.
Where are you?
You did go down the water, didn't you?
What the fuck?
Did he despawn?
Am I blind?
Hold on.
I think I'm going schizophrenic.
Did I not have a Reflin literally gating me that entire time?
Where is he?
I can't see you.
Whoa!
They're pissed.
Did you see that?
God, they're still locked onto me.
Okay, I might need to be a bit quick, Reflin,
just because I've got that enemy target in me
and they can probably...
All right, go down.
Get in.
In, in, in.
No, go.
You've been alone this entire time.
I really do need to pick up my...
Wait, the Reflin can spawn here.
There must be something weird going on.
He was never there, mommy.
Don't say such things.
That bat, literally that bat was like,
now this ain't worth that amount.
Have respect.
Okay, now that we've done that,
what did we achieve?
What did we achieve?
Was that what I was supposed to do?
Did I achieve what I was supposed to do?
Huh?
We achieved.
We need to go back up again.
I'm beat.
Oh, you're getting me back up.
The real Reflin where the friends can go down.
If they are, real question mark.
Oh, yeah.
We just did a, like, massive view turn.
When we could have done that the whole time
and we didn't have to do parkour.
Wait, we're going back.
Holy shit, they're pissed.
They're on the same level right now.
The freaking...
The witch is literally over there.
I'll go.
Um, should I cross?
Hold on.
Let's see what happens.
Oh, wrong one.
Oh shit, you didn't...
Oh, my bad.
I'm helping.
I promise I'm helping.
See, look, I'm...
I'm helping.
I think absolutely nothing should use me for a reason.
Okay, okay, I can do this.
I can do this.
I think we'll go a little bit away.
Skills.
Do you see that input skill?
Okay, now we go down.
Descent.
Is that not a dark go-short one?
We've seen it before.
Ha ha.
Oh, are we going the wrong way?
Oopsie doopie.
We may have made an itchy doopie.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
We're in.
Can we all fit?
Are you coming in too?
Oh, no, he says come this way.
Oops, we're getting a little turned around in this area.
There's a lot to be honest, so it's fine.
Oh, there's an item down here.
It's missing school and eat.
Come, come, come.
Go down, he says.
Down we go.
There's a bat down there.
I will destroy this bat.
What?
Yeah!
Next right, not happening.
What is this?
Hmm.
Okay, now.
This, like, the map just gets the ground.
There's only one at a time.
No.
Can you fit?
Okay.
I don't want to push you off by accident.
We have trained Johnny wrong as a joke.
Oh, I'll bite you.
Did you launch yourself?
Were you on top of that?
I think we're on top of that.
Easy, easy.
Wait, open this?
Oh, you don't have the right.
You don't have the right.
Okay, and then take this down.
Okay, we can do it.
I don't know what we're doing,
but we're doing something already.
We have the old mother remote.
Yes.
Old mother.
I might just pick it up.
Whoa!
This is new.
Is it?
I think so.
In the room to the right by the statue,
use old mother.
I'm curious.
Old mother.
What does this tablet do?
Have mercy for the start of the game.
Okay, sadly you have to leave,
but I assume there's another one.
Oh, that's so cool.
I love when games do that thing.
How on earth is anyone supposed to figure this out?
Naturally, though,
without being told what to do
or the dev team explaining what to do.
Oh, flowers!
Oh, my God.
There's so many!
How do you even perish here?
Oh, my God.
How do you?
Oh, my game crashed.
Oh, no, it survived.
You have to do parallel thinking,
looking up games on Google.
Yes, I can't have you guys here,
because the area is here.
Word of mouth,
people try random things in the first one,
but how?
Someone saw the statue and said,
Mom,
you just nullified it again up.
Is there anything coming up?
Oh, there is.
I think there's only C2, so...
I'll put C in.
Following the flow,
where is the flow?
Let's see if we can identify these flowers.
Oh, it's a recolor.
I don't know any of them.
I feel like it's a hibiscus
for the purple one.
The orange is just a generic coffee, honestly.
Or is it lavender?
No, that's not lavender.
Alright, link from Legend of Zelda again.
Is there any evil reeflings?
Or are we all perished at this point?
Okay.
Well,
no time like the prison,
we get to go through all these pretty flowers.
I can't believe it.
Oh, no.
Why is...
Why is that here?
Isn't that the thing
where an enemy comes out of nowhere?
Hmm.
This area is amazing.
It's so pretty!
Like, oh my god, dark souls actually
make like a really pretty ear.
Oh, eyes are so much blood.
Someone's getting walloped by something.
Ah, well, say no more.
Is he going for me?
I think so.
No, he's not going for me.
Yeah!
Okay, but...
Whoa, I can't even get it close.
I think I'm going to have to do baby stabs on him.
I'm too slow.
I think we're all too slow.
Can the horse even get staggered?
Oh!
We did stagger him.
Oh, no.
Sorry, I think I messed up.
I think we're doing all right.
Hello.
Well, thanks for the replays.
We're doing all right.
Oh, that stamina.
Ooh!
Oh, I'm getting freaking...
I think we're going to do it.
Whoa, that was a big swing.
Big swing.
Oh.
Wow.
That was fantastic.
Blessings of Marica, be upon me.
Do you guys despawn?
Or do we get to stand because it's...
Are you guys despawning or saying?
I don't know how it works here.
Grab it and twist his thoughts.
Grab it.
Okay, let's see what you guys get to say.
Okay.
See?
Exactly.
This is why...
Whoa.
Who not?
Enemy tangles spotted on 9 o'clock.
But we're not going to bother them,
so they're not going to bother us.
What's the tree sent another one?
They said,
Oh, is the tree sent another one
not hard enough for your new area?
Let's just add another one and buff them up.
Oh, my God.
See, this is where we're living.
A shaman's village.
Aw.
Look at all the flowers.
We love pretty flowers in this place.
Oh, is there a golden seed here?
Or is there no such thing as golden seed here?
Uh...
Straight to jail.
Teasing.
I'm teasing.
Whoa.
Is that noise?
I'm getting trolled.
Hello?
I heard something.
Knock, knock.
Okay, no one's home.
That's where I've been.
Not the music being the most peaceful music
I've ever heard in the entire series as well.
Just like a very quiet, low-toned heart.
Not giving off any emotion of excitement or...
I'm fucking losing it.
There's something here, guys.
Is it me?
I think it might be background noise,
but they're, for some reason, made it...
Is it me?
I'm going...
Sorry, I'm losing it.
I'm actually losing it.
I need to go to bed.
Holy crap.
I'm just straight up still spinning.
Okay.
We've got a golden lock of hair.
We've got Galadriel's lock of hair.
Holy.
Yes.
Good morning, woman.
I hope you're feeling better.
I fell asleep while I was...
What are you talking about?
There's nothing here.
Literally, I'm going crazy.
There's noises being made.
Attuded.
What are you going to do about it?
Oh, my God.
And I can't believe I complained
for a peaceful area where things don't attack you.
And I actually got it.
I actually got a peaceful, beautiful, nature-esque area.
Wow.
10 out of 10.
DLC.
Good.
Very recommend.
You've been going for 11 hours.
All this craziness.
Oh, did we hit 11 hours?
Well, there we go.
Honestly, every time Miya starts,
I'm like, I'm only doing six hours.
It's going to be shorter.
Oh, I'm only doing eight hours.
Oh, it's going to be shorter.
And then it's just like...
But after the eight hour mark,
I'm pretty sure we all just accept,
like, yeah, we're going for another four hours.
Are we going for them?
I don't have much heels,
but we can go for them.
Okay, we're doing it.
Jump them.
Regalings, stop this man.
He took half my health.
Oh, no.
It's his?
Oh, I'm out of stamina.
I'm sorry.
Miya, why am I not whacking him?
I literally have no stamina left.
Oh, I don't want to get perished.
I might get perished.
Oh, I missed.
I missed.
I have terrible news briefings.
I'm out of flash.
I think you guys are going to have to take over.
Hold on.
Let me get my board.
I can help.
I promise I can help.
Nope, wrong one.
Shit.
Hold on.
Hold the line.
You're doing great.
Mom's proud.
Oh, my God.
Please, man, you go away so I can actually help.
I've done a whole 75 damage.
Don't you worry, Reflins.
I've got you.
Is this guy missing on purpose?
Oh, God.
Where are the-
Hello?
Did he just go invisible or did I just, like,
go out of bounds?
Because what was that?
I'm trying to give him bleed arrows.
Trying being the main freaking-
Yeah, forget your silly damage.
Whoa.
I'm trying.
My crosshair's on him.
I just freaking do it, okay?
I'm-
Um...
Oh, what did he do?
I didn't even know he could do that.
You're carrying so hard.
Yeah, you're, like, my 75 damage.
Bruh.
How did I use this?
Oh, is that it?
Is it, like, unlimited use?
Trying to just, like, fire everything?
Oh, it's not even taking any stamina or anything.
Fuck it, I'm gonna try that.
Okay, let's try this again.
Rope hop to literally halfway across the map.
Who was an adventure?
Oh, you weren't an-
No, where-
You weren't an adventure.
Were you an adventure?
I'm moving up.
I'm- I'm gonna try the fire.
I don't know what the heck it is.
It's also dual wield if you get two.
Damn.
Oh, reflings.
It's time to get put to work.
Get back on the farm.
Weat those potatoes.
We are going to have a delicious supper tonight.
And...
No, no, no, I wouldn't do that.
I'm gonna try the flame.
I don't know.
I thought it was gonna do much,
but it's, like, literally three, so...
Let's get to it.
To it.
Let's get this party started.
You hit Y and right bumper to dual wield it.
Y and right bumper.
That was a left bumper.
Left bumper.
Oh!
Hi, cast pyro!
The fire?
Wait, wait, wait.
Set it on, set it on.
Please, what?
I'm sorry.
I feel like it would hurt.
I would, uh...
I am not sure...
Right, what happens now?
Achoo!
Oh, my God, it does nothing.
It does nothing.
I mean, I'm not surprised
considering it didn't specialize in it or anything,
but...
Yeah, let's just, uh...
Get this out.
What?
Whoa, we are doing stuff.
Stuff to him.
Oh, I always knock him out of that.
I'm so sorry.
I knocked him out of the special attack there.
Am I bad?
Oh.
I moved a little to the left
and managed to avoid his attack.
That was funny.
Hey, leave him alone.
Leave him alone.
Jeez, change, change.
Look at me.
He does not want to change off of you.
Jeez.
Okay, have it out.
Shit.
Okay, I actually have heals this time,
so not too much.
Oh, I knocked it.
Okay, that horse jumped over me.
Oh.
Not good, not good, not good.
Give me that.
Give me a good chip.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I need a cheeky heal after that one.
Hold on.
Jeez.
Get further and further away from me.
I'm trying.
Is there any damage to help me?
Oh, and of course,
I get a hit when I'm out of stamina.
We're almost there.
Take your days, horseman.
Oh.
Oh, come on.
The physics were going nuts there.
Oh.
Gee is a shot, mate.
Gee is a shot.
Oh, my God.
He just turned to face me last second.
Oh, goodness me.
Does he do some damage?
He's stuck on the hill.
If he does that holy shield thing,
by the way, don't let him actually...
Oh, no.
Hold on.
Oh, he took one HP in a dream.
Whoa, who's gonna die now?
Oh.
Whoa, the final blow.
I'm truly blessed that there's actually...
Oh, my goodness me.
Bro, are we where it's built?
I actually don't know if there's another one.
Right, well, we'll go back and pick up a refill
and really quickly.
Hold on.
I'm coming.
Real finger.
Wait, you let...
Oh, you...
Oh, because I...
Wait, that kind of just a boss as well.
It's starting to if you whip me
every more than half of it,
and I can explain.
Bro, but it's staying.
Like, whips are serious.
If you mean like a Raiden Crop,
I think that's okay,
but I couldn't imagine
like actually inflict some damage on a refund.
I just feel like I'm so sorry.
Then again, also me, like,
with literal acquisition.
Get up.
Wait, where is it?
Is there no...
Oh.
I've got one refill.
I've got two refill in here.
And let's go.
Follow the path then.
You can use part now.
Yeah, I've got my refunds
to help me follow the path then.
I'm the horse.
They can ride me.
That scared me.
Don't make that...
Oh, you're mean.
Aw, they had to put me...
Oh, you're healing me.
Thank you.
As long as you're trying your best.
Remember that time I said
I was gonna subtitle the mimosa video?
The mimosa ASMR flop?
She is so patient with me.
Wow, the boar's coming to get me.
It's a good thing.
I think there's a thing
and then there's like, ow.
I feel like that would be ow.
Stone bell bearing.
Mmm.
I do need to upgrade this sword.
I keep falling for like, exploring and like,
ooh, what's next, what's next?
Instead of like, okay,
maybe I should upgrade my base stuff
so it'll actually hit a bit harder.
Instead of being like, wow,
I'm only doing 100 damage every turn.
Hmm, what a surprise.
Does anyone even shop?
Is my tummy rumbling for food?
I ate.
I had a burger.
I'm chicken.
What are you eating?
Wow, there's a thing.
Oh, maybe I should have done that
and called you guys in
instead of making you go for
a jogging exercise routine.
Left foot, right foot.
A thing.
Oh, there's an enemy we've learned.
Oh, there's two enemy we've learned.
So there's not been none forever.
Have you been in for a while?
I don't think so.
What's that?
Did you just drop a turd?
What did you just do?
It's called first love students, do you know what?
If you upgrade your weapon,
you'll deal massive damage.
Okay, maybe we should try that tomorrow.
I didn't stop.
I didn't take forever.
That tree looks very menacing.
And I'm dead.
Whoa.
You're a bit too excited being spawned in.
What's going on here?
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we forgive you.
We forgive you.
You don't have to exile yourself.
It's got a little excited being coming back in.
Okay.
Two of the bell bearings are unfortunately
Azula.
Not to be confused with Azura.
Which is right before you finish the game.
Oh.
That seems a bit silly.
Do you know where you're taking us,
enemy recently?
Reeflings?
Does anyone...
Wait, we need a group huddle.
Reeflings, we need a group huddle.
Come.
Reefling, come down.
Come down.
We need a group huddle.
Okay, let me just...
Where the fuck are we going?
I'm so lost right now.
I've never seen this place before.
Where are we going?
Okay, we have a torch.
We have a torch bearer.
Okay.
Okay, let's go.
Okay, we're ready.
We're going back.
We're going up a hill.
Okay, I need to go to bed and fall.
Let me put up my desk.
Rest well.
Sleep well.
Sleep dream.
Have dreams of Karen,
Mayo, and Elvin ring.
Thank you.
That's all I need.
That's all I ask for.
Oh.
Oops.
Hmm.
There's two sacred tears
in the realm of the giants.
We're better off.
Hmm.
Yes.
If anyone needs to go to sleep,
please don't worry.
You may go to sleep.
I...
Unfortunately,
we're actually against the clock
and we've got around 30 minutes
now before the vod explodes.
Right, on the classic
11 hours and 55 minutes.
Ka-blamel.
Wah.
Where are these?
Oh, they're alive?
Well, I don't like that one bit.
No, sorry.
Night night,
I will have dreams of just Karen.
Another refling
that couldn't last as long as a memory.
A tale is all this time.
Only 30 minutes.
Shoot, I'll crash after that then.
Oh no, if you need to go to sleep,
don't stay up
just because like,
we're only going to be 30 more minutes.
Over the fingering place.
Out of context.
Oh, right.
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
The creepiest enemy
in the game
had to have had its own
literal massive maze.
Oh.
I'm not a fan.
Well, we just run for it.
I think we can just run for it, right?
I'm just running.
I'm just running
faster than I ever had.
I've already lost the lookout.
Okay, I found the lookout.
He's over here a little to the right.
Head south side, refling.
South side.
We're still running.
Faster than we ever could.
Let in our little feet.
Run.
South side.
Our main plan.
We're still running.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where the heck?
I blink and gauge refling
always disappears.
Apparently the morning shift
is pretty quiet.
What did I miss?
Um, we're in a,
the fart zone apparently,
because everything's green.
I'm not sure if that,
is that supposed to happen?
We're now in the finger location
in the DLC.
No idea what it is.
There's something in the distance.
There is no way that is attacking us
from the distance.
Hello?
Reflings absolutely annihilate
that figure.
It wishes there's nothing but harm.
And we will punish it
for its transgression.
Oh my God, they can do it
all from halfway across the map.
Hello?
Oh!
Okay, take that.
No poise.
No stamina.
No nothing going through it.
Don't,
from halfway across the map.
Right, do be careful.
Be vigilant.
I don't know what the purple does.
Oh, there's two more group top over here.
Did we just keep running?
Honestly, your side step is pretty good.
I won't, I won't admit.
Your side step is pretty good.
Okay, it's like a purple bomb.
Oh my God, it's spit-file.
It's spit-file.
Of course it's spit-file.
Why wouldn't I spit-file?
Oh, I'm out of stamina.
Okay, thank goodness.
They can just get staggered beyond belief.
Sorry, but this DLC,
everything seems to be staggerable
for the most part,
which just makes it so worth it
to be like two-handed heavy.
Alright, feels like that anyway.
That's just me, honestly.
I've just made,
oh jeez Louise,
something got me good.
I don't know what,
unless it was that one.
My brain literally couldn't process it.
We've got a finger mimic.
But what point in the DLC are we at?
That's the fun part.
I know nothing of the DLC,
so I can't even accurately give anything.
This is what the map looks like.
We're now in the fingery part of the map.
That's the best I've got.
This used to be some sort of
totem type thing.
I'll touch it in a teleport maybe?
Read the message.
What did I do?
I did it.
Time to finger.
I'm not built like I wanted to
draw for like a bug or something.
No, you can.
You are free to lurk,
you're free to chat,
and whatever is your comfort level.
Can I not interact with you guys here?
Or do I need to do something?
Do I stick my...
Well, you know, what on earth?
But rest well for those who need to sleep.
You need a special item for a quest.
Word of warning,
if you ever go to the church of eclipse,
you will be jumpscared.
Okay, thank you for letting me know.
I need an item of some kind.
Is that my fingy?
Did you talk to the guy in a church on a throne?
No.
I don't think so.
Am I supposed to?
Go get an item.
I gotta go.
Thanks for this yappies.
You're more than welcome, please rest well.
Do what you gotta do.
It's a finger.
I think you don't stick something in it.
You must likely do the opposite.
Back to manage my tire with you.
Okay.
Oh wait, sorry.
Everyone taught me.
Was it mana?
Me.
Wait, mo?
Wait, I don't have it?
Left of where you are in blue.
Ah, that's right.
Wait, I can't.
Oh, sorry.
Reefling is okay if you leave.
That can go teleporting.
To the left, there's a...
I don't think I need to fight though.
Wait, am I gonna have to come all the way back here then?
Am I just gonna come back here and horseback the first time?
Do that then.
Oh, it's been a pleasure.
Woo-hoo!
No?
Okay.
There's a man in here to speak to.
And there's no fight in here.
Don't...
There's no fight.
I know the area is safe.
I don't have to be absolutely terrified.
Fucking hell it's dark in here.
I'm fucking breaking it.
Okay.
Please don't be a fight.
Oh, there's blood everywhere!
Reefling!
There's literally blood everywhere.
No!
No, you can't do this to me.
I'm exhausted and you want me to fight?
Oh, there's blood everywhere.
Where's the enemy?
It's not all a lock and onto an enemy.
You gotta fuck up his shit.
Fuck up his shit.
Please, let me speak to you and give me a finger or something.
Hello?
Well, we don't often receive visitors.
No, apparently you killed them all the way down the floor.
Welcome to Manus Meta.
It is a pleasure to have you.
Oh, give me your finger or whatever.
You are so forsaken as these.
Chance encounters are precious indeed.
Seeing that we have convened here on this day,
allow me to mark the occasion with a modest offering.
Okay.
Okay, get me the hell out of here.
Why is there death in there?
Why are people dying in there?
Did they attack him?
And he absolutely walloped them?
Right.
I'm just going to speed run through this area because
we've already checked if we're clear to that.
Oh, it's a mama finger and all her little...
Oh, and it's Papa's finger.
God, you guys fucking breathe like nothing on Earth.
You need to get our tubes shot.
Holy shit.
Do you know like after the third child,
it gets really irresponsible?
They're just going to school.
Okay, they're just going to school.
Wow, I can't see nothing.
I guess you could see the finger bit.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, I just dropped my piece of paper that has
everyone's name on it over here.
Okay.
Aw, Reflin's leave me for literally five seconds
and I'm in an utter, like utter disarray.
Utter disarray.
Utter dis, the fucking...
I will call you guys in and you can hold my hand
down to where I need to go.
Oh, of course.
Oh, of course, I can't just walk down.
Oh, I'm looking so bad at the game.
Oh, sorry.
Serves you right for your lame joke.
It was one of your jokes.
A Reflin joke.
Literally, the one time I don't get my hand held down,
I immediately get fucking...
And absolutely obliterated in the skyline.
Why do they always put something weird in these games?
Oh, they can't even handle it, honestly.
It was my joke and it was funny.
Yeah, that's why I stole it.
Is there any other Reflin that's able to guide me
through fingerstone hell?
Fingerstone hell?
Barely even nor.
Sorry, fingerstone?
That's hardly even.
Doesn't make anything.
God, they're so pretty.
Why are they getting closer to us?
Reflin that spawned in?
Just be careful, they're getting a bit close.
It's locked onto you, Reflin.
I think it's locked onto you.
I think we're about to get pummeled by this.
Okay, he's ready.
With the powerful aura of the Reflin,
they retreat for his stamina,
his menacing aura is just far too much
for the game to handle.
It checks out, it's checking out.
Look at him, he's sizing up the Reflin.
What does he say?
He's thinking about it,
he thinks about challenging the Reflin,
but is he going to make a mistake of his life?
He's going to make the mistake of his life,
he couldn't help it.
It's too much.
It's overwhelming, truly.
Oh, he regretted it, he regretted it.
He underestimated the Reflin,
and now he's gone.
Back to the urge tree with you.
Finger papa is dead.
Sorry, he was asking for it, that's for Hansy.
Can you have too much testosterone,
you think you rule the world?
Right, how the fuck do we get past them?
Oh wait, we can run past these ones, can't we?
They can't keep up.
I think we can just run past.
Are we just destroying the entire bloodline?
Okay, nah, just walk past them.
My weapon's too shit.
I need to help with the wiggly worms, really.
Oh shit, the Reflin's getting gang banged.
Oh no, he's getting Reflin run.
Do you have enough heals?
Yeah, you're good.
It's the worms that we need to be worried about, honestly.
Look at that little fire barrier.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, see that hand?
Just run past, just run past, we have stamina.
Because the mummy...
This Reflin said nah, it's personal,
you don't ever do that to me, you jumping me like that?
Hands, F around and found out, what's going on?
I remember the first time I found a finger hand monster,
I think my neighbors also remember that.
Right, this is the part where I got fricking jumped
by like a whole gang of worms.
I need to be careful of those fricking pulsing bombs.
I wish I had like the lightning strike magic,
where you can like fire...
Is it like Zeus? I think it's Zeus.
Yeah, that...
Basically do it for like how far away?
That's not even for me, I'm getting nervous.
I don't know if I just need to do the magic one.
I need my Glyx one, I thought that was coming for me.
Really got handed to the Reflins?
Well, from how good they are at like holding my hand.
I'll get you out of there.
Whoa, they spawn in on you!
No, I'm just going to save you!
What happened?
How did we do it so perfectly last time?
If you get caught by that fucking pink thing,
these ones can just spawn over to you?
Oh no, I got caught!
Wait, I can still roll though.
Oh my god.
That's outrageous!
So hard for no reason.
No, didn't you bother me?
Fucking cheeky wee shit.
Honestly, I'm out of stamina on everyone.
Grab someone else you wee fucking wee.
Weirdo.
I better go right through me.
I'm not having that.
Oh, it's a Paralysm scale.
It's me! I'm Paralysm.
Oh shit, are we healing?
Oh no, I'm not healing.
Okay, let's be up these worms and then we're there.
I think this one's already locked on to us.
It is. It's just been a wee liar.
Yeah, they're both locked on to us.
It's just pretending to not be locked on.
There we go.
A liar.
Is that one locked on to us?
It looks like it. Yeah, it's locked on.
Time to go at nine o'clock.
There we go.
Look at my survivability percentages.
Go up when I've got refunds.
It's amazing.
I did this all myself.
Smile.
I've never seen them do it.
I love how we're doing that harder.
Hands in this area is a bit touchy.
Finger ruin is finger ruin.
Either way, it's getting done.
Okay, now I can do what I need to do at this area.
Can I do it while you guys are present?
Yes, I can.
Oh, it's a horn.
What does that do?
A cerulean seat talisman.
I don't know.
You don't...
Why am I not being told my stats?
What does it do?
I don't know.
These are where all the fingers that get lost go.
Well, at least they have a horn.
Wait, why is it that it's not telling what it lost?
How strange. Am I going crazy?
A little bit.
Greatly boost magic.
Oh, well...
Right, so we got our finger talisman.
We've been through the flowers.
We've also been through this incredibly crazy path.
Oh, there's another finger city?
Oh, I thought we did it.
There's more fingers?
Hey, when you go back to the church,
there's another NPC leaning up against the pillar to the right
that you should go back to the same church.
Okay, Riesling, thank you for insisting me all this way.
I don't know why I got so banged up, like, going on my own,
but honestly, just proof that I need you guys.
Thank you so much for helping me get here.
Hope that helps.
Dangerous again, honestly.
Okay, and then there's someone...
Go back to the church, there's an NPC leaning on the right
that I need to talk to in order to...
How much time have I got?
I've only got less than 5 minutes.
We're responding.
NPC to the right in this room?
Okay.
Man, I can't see shit, I need my glakes on.
Oh, crap.
Oh, there you are.
Sorry, couldn't see you there again.
Hi.
Anything else?
Are you sure?
Hey, I got, like, this talisman thing, do you want it back?
It's not really mine.
It's like a thing.
Oh, I did it the wrong way.
Wait, man, idiot, did I get the wrong...
Am I a dum-dum?
Ask about the name Black Armor.
Do they have time to do the other thing, you rune?
You think?
Okay.
Okay, I'll move on, how do I get there?
This one?
Why would it give me a map?
It's not even highlighted.
Why go through these animals to school?
Ooh, enjoying it.
I'm exhausted, but, like, I can't get enough.
I was, I said, like, fucking, at the start of the stream,
I was like, this isn't going to be an endurance stream.
At six hours in, I was like, am I going to go off soon?
Eight hours in, am I going to go off soon?
We need to actually go off in 20 minutes
because the board's going to explode.
Check the papers from the inventory.
Examine using X.
Well, I can't fucking see it.
So, do you want to try again?
Switch view.
Switch display.
Are you trolling me right now?
Will you start a second stream?
No, it's my bedtime for me, sadly.
Um...
Am I being trolled?
No, that's fine.
I'm being trolled, and I'll literally not look at that figure.
Surely I can.
Select an item to interact with it.
A, use leave discard.
Okay, now make it bigger
so I can actually read the damn thing.
Are you fucking joking?
Like, I know it's down there, but, like, are you serious?
Are you trolled?
That's all you can see.
The game won't even, like, I know it's here,
but...
Wait, how do I get down there?
Can you just put a bridge here?
So, really, in close?
What? Go...
Okay.
We may have to explode operations, however,
because I don't know how much time's going to take.
Gee, I wonder where it's close.
Ah, truly a mystery.
I'm out on my own.
You'll see such things.
You'll see such horrible things to me.
Does that have to do with someone who's a big girl?
I assume, what, if I go around,
and then there's a walk, walk, and then...
a walk?
I'd have watched what I've been playing all day.
Honestly, me, though.
I've got my thing down.
Oh, no, I can't lose you then.
Tomorrow's Elden Ring, yeah, tomorrow's another Elden Ring,
and then I don't know what we're going to achieve tomorrow.
Um...
Oh, there's a bee weeping.
Uh, Rusyn...
Who's...
Who's been...
Who's the last time?
Shilinfin, did I have you in at the horror?
I don't know, though.
Um, I'm so sorry if I'm, like, avoiding...
by accident.
Rusyn, I've been seeing you at the floor.
I can't remember until...
Are you playing on PC?
Yes, it's PC, and then you can stream snipe, uh, technically,
due to, um...
holding my hands to the game.
Uh...
I'm itching my face.
I'm itching my weeping.
Uh, actually, I'm going to have to thank someone to redirect.
Thanks for the second.
You guys are going to take me to the worms.
We're going to do the worm, go back to the church,
and we're going to do it in under 10 minutes,
so I have enough time to redirect into, uh, a lovely strumming, okay?
Maybe someone from Yumi Plus is on right now.
Go ahead.
It's tomorrow stream, the last time you play Elden Ring.
I don't know when the DLC ends,
like, because we're...
I'm kind of getting my hand held through, like, everything at the moment.
Um, tomorrow I'm going to upgrade weaponry, um...
and just keep going.
I don't know what we're doing.
I've never played the DLC before.
But I'm just enjoying it.
Like, it's so pretty,
and it's so nice, like, being able to enjoy it
and not be like, ah, I can't move.
What the heck?
We'll pick you up later.
Hello?
That just electrified you alive in your metal armor.
Oh, my gosh.
Why is this game so unforgiven?
Oh.
Whoa, there's a rolling ram, by the way, by the...
You just got annihilated.
You poor thing, you.
Yeah?
Ah.
Okay, up in the air is fine, better than, I know.
I know a lot.
Oh, right, no.
Nah, I'm still playing.
I doubt we're gonna...
I don't know if we're finishing it in 12 hours, though.
Um, if we don't finish it,
but you guys tell me I'm close,
we'll do about, eh, we'll...
we'll delete.
Can we not go through?
Oh, is that a fake down?
Oh, it is a fake down.
Oh.
Um...
The Baltral stream was kind of a question mark.
Is this actually happening or not?
Cause I don't know...
How can you guys so...
How can you jump so tall?
Can't even get up.
Breath.
Oh.
Get down here.
Man, I love pretty...
Pretty...
They should honestly do pretty areas,
and I know soul games are supposed to be like,
depressing, like, world ending type stuff,
but I mean, like, come on,
if you're gonna put flowers and deer in the game,
like, you know.
Well, who was the last boss you fought?
Eh, unsuccessfully, the snake guy is the best I've got
for his description.
Eh, we defeated a sunflower,
and...
We, like, boxed the crap out of a sunflower,
which I actually kind of enjoyed its mechanics.
Whoa, sorry, did I just jump into you?
Wait, what?
Is this granny a weepling boss?
No?
Weeplings?
Huh?
Is everyone just DC, or am I really dumb,
and I can't follow?
They're done?
Are we not going this way?
There were never any weeplings.
Wait, did they jump down?
No, they couldn't.
Wait, they just...
Someone do the hey-a-mo, where are you?
Oh.
Okay, sorry, I'm here.
There's a hand in there.
Oh, we are to go down, okay.
Okay, sorry, sorry.
Don't stream and drive at the same time.
And by stream and drive, I mean,
Clay, Elden, Ring, and Co.
What?
You're halfway done, then.
Oh, maybe we can't finish it tomorrow.
Miss Mer is a halfway point.
Is that the guy I can't kill?
The one that pulls out his wee eyeball?
He's a wee rude one, if that's him.
I'm gonna elabel up my sword and get huge for it.
Come on.
Do we make an error? All the refills here?
Oh, no, one fell down.
That's what's wrong, one fell down.
One fell off and bumped his head.
But that's okay, we're gonna get him back.
Okay, we got another thing in my bowl.
Thank you, Mr. Boo.
Oh.
That wasn't a good thing.
Well.
Good is objective.
Oh, it wasn't what I thought it was.
I thought it was one of them figure things.
Oh, we did it!
Okay, we're in another finger's room.
Is there a leafling here at this grace site?
Oh, I can't look, check the map to tell you what grace site is.
Have a good night, I'm gonna wake up and listen for it.
Oh, you should definitely get some sleep.
Alright, here's the last.
Gav, I think I...
I think Gav is next.
And then it's gone.
The helmet you're wearing reduces your healing ability.
Why would that even be a thing?
Let's put this on again.
Oh, wait, that's the matching helmet.
15 minutes, no?
If you have 15 minutes for me to blow this horn.
Where is it?
Okay, let's try it, let's try it.
We're on the clock.
We need to perfect this.
Surely we can perfect this.
Fuck that, keep running, keep running!
Keep running, you're gonna get absolutely rolled.
If I'm in, they're spawning in.
Oh my god, there's more of those worm bastards.
We need to stick together for the worm.
Just in case one of us gets in trouble.
Is the other refling coming?
Just be careful.
Yeah, be careful, the worms are merciless.
Those wiggly worms, they're terrible.
We said this like six hours ago, but I guess you are too trashy, Gav.
I didn't realize I had the help.
I know, someone said like it had something wrong with it.
And I think I asked like what it was, and then of course I never read it, but like read every other message.
Okay, we're against the worms again, but we can charge, destroy the worms, teach them a lesson, make them regret being born.
What are worms?
What's their category?
Call me Ashley, because I'm Colfin of Andy and Lily.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't have time to hit a button.
That's where you take it, you take it like a good worm.
Oh God, oh God, I'm getting jumped, they're jumping me, they're jumping me.
Okay, they didn't quite jump me, but whatever.
Okay, we did it, we did it.
I got saved from being jumped.
Worms and floods are not insects.
What are worms?
Okay, that one was alright, thank you, thank you.
Moment.
Okay, we did it.
We did it, we're gonna blow it, we're gonna go to the church, and then we're gonna redirect successfully because there's blood blowing up.
Okay, Reeflings, thank you so much, please leave, please leave, thank you.
Why are you naked?
What the heck?
Are you transforming?
You can become a dragon?
You're like half-dragon then.
Okay, I'll very quickly go to the church and talk to this man.
Wow.
Okay, talk to the man in the church and then I'm done.
Is anyone on you need me to flip on?
If not, be in you, you're next.
Unfortunately, my thoughts don't actually stream on.
Hello, I did what you asked for.
I'm not really sure what it was, but I did it anyway.
Hello.
Hi.
Thanks for the stream, you're more than welcome.
See you tomorrow, same time, same endurance.
Is the door still up?
Oh, I assume she's all flamed by now.
Ruins map, interesting.
Yeah, I don't know who's beaten up stuff in here, but it's not me.
Okay, we did it.
We did a heck of a lot of questions.
I hope you guys remember my progress.
I have no idea what I've done, what I haven't achieved, what I haven't achieved.
Oh, is there still up? Hold on.
Let me just message her real quickly.
And by message her, go into her live stream and ask if she's still on me.
But is there a stream for her?
Oh god, she's playing League, no wonder she's a fucking streamer.
Dragon?
Anyone?
Are you streaming streaming for longer?
This game is not fucking horrible. This game is weird.
Are you left?
Oh my god, there's almost 5k.
Anybody want to help me?
Anybody want to help me get dragon?
Anyone?
This game is not fucking horrible. This game is weird.
Are you left?
Oh, coward.
Coward, are you streaming for longer? Yes.
Okay.
I am.
You're getting a cheeky wish.
You are.
I am. You're sending them in here to be tortured?
Yeah, exactly.
I welcome them with open arms.
Are you squidding here, though?
Stronny, I love you and I wish I could have stayed the whole stream,
but my brain isn't wired to do so.
Oh man.
Keep up the grind, crazy lady.
Oh, I love you too, little reaper.
Thank you for the tip.
That was very kind of you to say, boy.
You heard it.
As there is a welcoming...
She wants to torture you, but in a nice way.
With League of Legends.
I have no idea what the game is about.
As long as she's happy, I'm happy.
She's doing fantastic.
I think all the girls are about to hit 5k.
You know that.
Hold on.
Let me check.
Hold on to me.
Check, ladies and gentlemen.
Are you okay?
Are you happy?
Hold on, let me...
Let me see.
Most of the ICN is 0 and 4.9k.
They're fantastic.
They're about to both hit 5k.
And then everyone will hit 5k in less than a freaking month.
The month isn't even over.
Oh my God.
Thank you so, so much, little refunds.
It has been an absolute pleasure to do it yet again.
Another endurance stream.
Thank you so much for carrying me.
Your advice, your patience through the highs and lows
of my energy levels going skyrocket into being quiet
to just going nuts and starting to sing so hard.
I don't know what I was doing, honestly.
Thank you all so much.
I will see you tomorrow at the same time.
And for more endurance,
we may or may not actually finish the DLC.
If we do, then the schedule is still confirmed
if I have the image of the schedule.
Which I will re-show you a question mark, maybe?
Is it successful?
That would be successful.
There we go.
So tomorrow is Elden Ring.
That counts as the Monday stream.
And then at 2pm, no, sorry.
It's not adjusted to my time zone.
At the normal time,
I stream.
At the normal time, I stream.
It's ASMR.
And then 2 hours of ASMR, public.
And then a private membership-only script write-in
where we do stuff.
And if it gets good reception,
I'm happy to do more.
If it's not really what people are looking for,
we'll kind of maybe just do it
like in an odd every one, every three weeks or something.
And then I have an Among Us collab with Yumi Plus,
Veealer versus Yumi Plus.
Please don't think we're actually versing each other
because it's not possible, because the game is randomized.
But if you ever wanted to hear me get angry,
because nothing makes me more enraged
when I'm telling the truth
and someone's like trying to pin something on me,
I never get so loud in my life.
So look out for that.
We are playing Mech Assault, the Xbox original game,
which is going to be scaled up beautifully.
And then there's going to be a membership ASMR stream as well.
Roughly eight hours later, because the estimation,
estimation is, is what?
Eight hour gameplay time.
A very old game.
Played it, I say played it.
I watched my dad play it.
I was probably too young to even fucking hold the controller
to be honest.
Boutro is a go.
And then RuneScape part four,
I'm going to release all the thumbnails,
which tells you what movies we're watching.
But RuneScape part four, we're doing a movie marathon
alongside it.
And then RuneScape part five,
we're doing a Veil or Marathon,
because there's so many streams from the girls I want to watch.
And what better excuse to shove them in the corner
whilst I make wines than doing that.
And then to have a wee bit of a shorter ending of the week.
We had two hour binding of Isaac Run.
And then it's normally one hour per successful run.
We're going to do Eden.
I don't know if we're going to win or not.
And then I actually wanted to watch the original Iron Man.
I've not seen it in many a year.
And I wanted to see if I sort of remember it being like this.
So we're going to watch Iron Man.
I don't know if it's a bad taste, but I wanted to try it out.
Did you figure out the movies?
We're going to do John Wick for the movies.
I couldn't find anything else that I was interested in
or was in the mood in.
I want to watch something that's pretty cool, high action.
I'm not really wanting to watch anything that's not really for the masses.
So I picked John Wick.
I think John Wick is the good balance of everything that I want.
Because at one point I was like fast and furious.
I'm like they're fast and furious to the moon.
Oh no, we're past the 11.55.